AND THE SENATE SPECIAL PANDEMIC
EMERGENCY RESPONSE COMMITTEE
WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WHAT'S AMERICAN MANY MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. TODAY
WE HAVE ELEVEN MEMBERS WHO HAVE
INDICATED THEY'LL BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY CENTERS
GONZALEZ SKINNER BATESBRADFORD
CAPPIELLO. JACKSON JONES
MCGUIRE MITCHELL I'M BURKE AND
WIENER WILL BE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY TODAY. I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IT IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER WITH ME IS SENATOR
MORLOCK. WE ALSO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
MEDICAL EXPERTS AND ADVOCATES
WHO ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
FOR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS.
THIS WILL GREATLY AID
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT
YOU USE THAT RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE REMOTE PROGRAM.
EACH TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO UN MUTE PLEASE SELECT UNMUTE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. R.
I. T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE.
ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN
ON THE SCREENS. STATE YOUR NAME
AND THEN YOU'RE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WITH ADMITTED ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW IWILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WISHES THAT THE TESTIFIED TODAY.
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON A
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AGAIN. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS THREE THREE SEVEN. TWO
SEVEN SEVEN THREE AGAIN. THREE
THREE SEVEN TWO SEVEN SEVEN
THREE FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES THEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
FOR TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE
HEARING FROM BOTH OF THE PANELS
OF WITNESSES ON THE AGENDA
PRIOR TO TAKING ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT. WE'RE GOING TO STATE
PUBLIC YES FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
ONCE WE HAVE HEARD FROM ALL OF
THE WITNESSES WE WILL HAVE A
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO COMMENT ON THE
TOPICS ON TODAY'S AGENDA. WE
WILL HAVE A HARD STOP ON THIS
HEARING AT FIVE PM. PLEASE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WERE ABLE TO
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM. DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE THE
STREAMLINED HEARING PROCESS AND
CONDUCTED HEARINGS IN THIS
CLOSE THE MATTER TO THE SAME
MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS. WHO ARE JUSTIN TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO THAT
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. TODAY'S HEARING ABOUT
COVERT NINETEEN IN CALIFORNIA
STATE PRISONS AS A FOLLOW UP TO
THE HEARING HELD BY THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE ON JULY FIRST.
WE WILL HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION AND OTHERS ABOUT
THE WORK TO PREVENT THE SPREAD
OF COVERT NINETEEN IN STATE
PRISONS AND WHAT HAS OCCURRED
DURING THE FOUR AND A HALF
MONTHS. SINCE THE EARLIER
SENATE HEARING ON THESE TOPICS.
ALSO IN TODAY'S SECOND PANEL WE
WILL BE HEARING FROM THE CDC
OUR STAFF AND ADVOCATES BUT THE
TRANSFERS OF SOME PRISONERS TO
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT FACILITIES.
INCLUDING THE PORT OF CALL IS
BEING USED ON SUCH TRANSFERS
OCCUR. NO OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY ARE BEING ADEQUATELY
PROTECTED WHEN THE STATE
CONTINUES TO TRANSFER SOME
PRISONERS SCHEDULED FOR LEASE.
TO ICE DETENTION CENTERS
INSTEAD OF RELEASING THEM UPON
COMPLETION OF THEIR SENTENCES.
NOW I WISH TO. ALLOW THE CHAIRS
OF THE RESPECTIVE COMMITTEES TO.
REPS GIVE OPENING REMARKS- IS
SENATOR SKINNER ON YET SO I'D
FIRST LIKE TO ASK A CENTER
SKINNER WHO SERVES AS CHAIR OF
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE. TO
MAKE SOME BRIEF OPENING REMARKS
AT THIS TIME CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH DOCTOR PAN
FOR CHAIRING AND GOOD AFTERNOON
AND VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
THIS IS A JOINT HEARING WITH
NOT ONLY THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE BUT ALSO OUR
PANDEMIC- I MERGING SHE
RESPONDS COMMITTEE. SO WE KNOW
THAT ONCE THE VIRUS. WHAT THE
FIRST INCIDENCES OF THE VIRUS
IN OUR STATE PRISONS IT SPREAD
RAPIDLY AND THAT SPREAD WHILE
THERE WERE MANY ACTIONS THAT
WERE TAKEN SUCH AS STOPPING THE
TRANSFER FROM US FOLKS WHO WERE
IN COUNTY JAIL INTO THE STATE
PRISON SO WE WERE NOT CREATING
TRANSMISSION THAT WAY. ALSO
DOING A VARIETY OF THINGS TO
TRY TO LIMIT THE REALITY IS
THAT THERE ARE SO MANY STAFF
WITHIN OUR STATE FACILITIES
THAT GO IN AND OUT IN FACT AND
A DAILY BASIS. THAT WE HAVE
SEEN AND CONTINUE TO SEE IT
UNFORTUNATELY VERY RAPID SPREAD
OF THIS VIRUS WITHIN OUR STATE
FACILITIES AND NOW THAT WE HAVE
GREAT THESE VERY SIGNIFICANT
NUMBERS OF VIRUS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AT HIGHER NUMBERS PER DAY
AND WE HAVE SEEN EVEN AT THE
PEAK. WE ARE LIKELY TO SEE
SIMILAR WITHIN OUR FACILITIES-
AND I THINK THAT WHILE- NO THAT
WAS NOT OUR PRIMARY. REASON FOR
GOING HEARING WE REALLY WANTED
TO DO OVERSIGHT ON THIS IN
GENERAL I THINK WE REALLY DO
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE FACT THAT.
IT IS SEARCHING THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND IT REQUIRES A WHOLE I
FEEL A WHOLE NEW LEVEL OF
DILIGENCE AND PERHAPS NEW
PROTOCOLS ARE ACTIONS TO
PROTECT THOSE PEOPLE THAT WE
HOLD IN OUR STATE FACILITY SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM.
THE PANELISTS FROM THE PUBLIC-
TO GIVE US THE ABILITY TO
FIGURE OUT IF WE ARE TAKING THE
APPROPRIATE STEPS OR WHAT OTHER
STEPS WE MIGHT MAKE AND THEN I
KNOW IN THE SECOND PANEL WE ARE
OF COURSE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE FACT. THAT THERE ARE STILL.
TRANSFERS TRANSFERS AND OF
COURSE THOSE TRANSFERS ARE ALSO
VERY DANGEROUS IN RELATIONSHIP
TO SPREADING THE VIRUS SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO- THERE THE
COMMENTS AND REMARKS AND TO OUR
DIALOGUE AS LEGISLATORS. AS TO
WHAT WE DO TO MINIMIZE THIS
SPREAD M. D. DEATHS THAT RESULT
POTENTIALLY THANKS VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A CENTER
SKINNER I WOULD NOW LIKE TO
INVITE TO CENTER GONZALEZ WHO
CHAIRS THE SPECIAL PANDEMIC
EMERGENCY RESPONSE COMMITTEE TO
ALSO MAKE ANY OPENING REMARKS-
CENTER GONZALEZ. THANK YOU
SENATOR CAN AND THANK YOU TO
SENATOR SKINNER AS WELL AS OUR
COLLEAGUES HERE ON THE WELL
THINK ABOUT THE PUBLIC SAFETY
AND A PANDEMIC EMERGENCY
RESPONSE COMMITTEE. I'M GLAD
WE'RE HAVING THIS- DISCUSSION
TODAY- ENTITIES HEARING IS
IMPORTANT IN ORDER TO BRING
FOCUS OF COURSE ON PREVENT TEEN
THE SPREAD OF COVERT NINETEEN
AS MENTIONED. IN A CALIFORNIA
PRISON SYSTEM IMMIGRANT
DETENTION CENTERS AND
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES AS
WELL- I AM ALSO DEEPLY
CONCERNED ALONG WITH- MY SENATE
COLLEAGUES IN THE MIDST OF THIS
PANDEMIC THE IMMIGRANTS
SPECIFICALLY WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
TO BE RELEASED. FROM LOCAL AND
STATE CUSTODY CONTINUE TO BE
TRANSFERRED TO ICE DETENTION
FACILITIES WHERE WE KNOW THAT
THE VIRUS CAN IN SOME
INSTANCES. INSTANCES ARE
SPREADING VERY VERY QUICKLY AND
KILLING- MANY CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS- SO WE KNOW THAT THIS
IS HAPPENING AND IT'S HAPPENING
IN OUR STATE WE HAVE TO GET
CLEAR THE ROLES
RESPONSIBILITIES AS TO WHO
EXACTLY. AND WHY EXACTLY- THIS
IS STILL OCCURRING IN OUR
STATE. AND THERE ARE LOTS OF
MEDIA REPORTS THAT ALSO
INCLUDED THE- HORRENDOUS
CONDITIONS IN THESE DETENTION
FACILITIES TO WHICH WE NEED TO
ADDRESS TODAY. SO WITH THAT I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU AGAIN MR
I'D SHARE DOCTOR AND FOR-
HOLDING THIS MEETING IN AND
SHARING IN SACRAMENTO AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM.
MANY OF THE PANELISTS STATE
AGENCIES AND IMMIGRANT JUSTICE
ADVOCATES AS WELL ON HOW WE
CAN. FURTHER PREVENT THE SPREAD
AS WELL AS RECTIFY THE
SITUATION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR GONZALEZ AND JUST
ARE THERE ANY OTHER SENATORS
WHO WISH TO MAKE A VERY BRIEF
OPENING REMARKS BEFORE WE BEGIN
OUR SPEAKERS. PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND FUTURE. OKAY SEEING NONE I
WILL GO AHEAD OF BEGIN WITH
FIRST PANEL- SO FAR IN FIRST
PANEL EACH PALACE HAS. HAS UP
TO FOUR MINUTES FOR THEIR
PRESENTATIONS BUT I EXPECT-
WITH FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS FROM
OUR- COMMITTEE MEMBERS- YOU'LL
HAVE EVEN MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO
SPEAK MORE AT LENGTH AND AT
THAT TIME- SO WE HAVE WILL
BEGIN WITH DR JOSEPH. BECK
DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION OF
CORRECTIONAL HEALTH CARE
SERVICES BUT CDC ARE WELCOME
DOCTOR BACK- PLEASE BEGIN YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND- IS MY SOUND OKAY ON YOUR
END. SOUNDS GOOD. THANK YOU
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY REGARDING THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL HEALTH CARE
SERVICES EFFORTS. TO ADDRESS
THE COMMON EPIDEMIC. I'M
ESPECIALLY A PHYSICIAN WHO
SPECIALIZES IN INFECTIOUS
DISEASES AND I JOINED THE
DEPARTMENT IN NINETEEN NINETY
THREE DURING THE HEIGHT OF THE
AIDS EPIDEMIC. AFTER SERVING
FOR APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AT THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
FACILITY. S. CHIEF MEDICAL
OFFICER AN INFECTIOUS DISEASES
CONSULTANT. I ASSUME THE ROLE
OF STATEWIDE DIRECTOR OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES IN JULY OF THIS
YEAR. OVER THE PAST NINE MONTHS
THE DEPARTMENT HAS MPLEMENTED
UNPRECEDENTED ORGANIZATIONAL
CHANGES IN RESPONSE TO CONCORD
NINETEEN. THESE CHANGES HAVE
BEEN INFORMED BY OUR MEDICAL
AND PUBLIC HEALTH LEADERSHIP AS
WELL AS PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS
SAID THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL. STANFORD AND
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY. AS MORE IS LEARNED
ABOUT THE VIRUS WE CONTINUE TO
MODIFY OUR PREVENTION RESPONSE
STRATEGIES. CAN THE SITUATION
CONTINUES TO EVOLVE RAPIDLY AS
EVIDENCED JUST THIS PAST WEEK
BY THE ANNOUNCEMENT OF TWO
DIFFERENT VACCINES THAT APPEAR
TO BE. AT LEAST 90%
APPLICATIONS. VERY EARLY ON WE
REALIZED THAT THE BIGGEST RISK
FOR OUTBREAKS IN OUR FACILITIES
CAME FROM INTRODUCTION OF
CORBETT NINETEEN BY EMPLOYEES
CONTRACTORS VOLUNTEERS AND
VISITORS. OUR EARLY STEPS TO
CONTROL THESE RISKS INCLUDING
LIMITING ENTRY TO THE PRISONS
TO ONLY ESSENTIAL STAFF.
MANDATING FACE COVERINGS AND
JUST PHYSICAL DISTANCING FOR
OUR EMPLOYEES AND INMATES.
IMPLEMENTING ROUTINE GATE
SCREENING PROBLEMS ENTERING THE
FACILITY AND PROVIDED PROVIDING
ONGOING COVERT EDUCATION TO OUR
STAFF AND FOR PATIENTS.
ADDITIONAL SPECIFIC STRATEGIES
AND PRACTICES THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED INCLUDING HAVE
INCLUDED REDUCING NONESSENTIAL
MOVEMENT. EXPANDING OUR CODED
TESTING CAPACITY AND REDUCING
TURNAROUND TIME SO THAT WE
RECEIVE MOST RESULTS WITHIN TWO
DAYS. DEVELOPING SEVERAL
ELECTRONIC TOOLS TO TRACK OUR
TESTING IN TRANSFER AND RELEASE
INFORMATION AND MONITOR OTHER
ASPECTS OF OUR CARE AND
CONTINUALLY UPDATING OUR ONLINE
PROGRAM GUIDELINES. IN RESPONSE
TO EARLIER CORBETT OUTBREAKS
CAUSED BY TRANSFERS OF PATIENTS
FROM ONE INSTITUTION TO ANOTHER%
WE ADDED STRINGENT PRE AND POST
TRANSFER TESTING AND QUARANTINE
REQUIREMENTS FOR ALL PATIENTS.
WE ALSO MANDATED THE USE OF N.
NINETY FIVE MASKS FOR ALL
INMATES IN PATIENTS AND STAFF
DURING OUR TRANSPORTATION. IN
UTILIZING THESE REVISED
TRANSFER PROTOCOLS WE'VE SAFELY
TRANSFERRED OVER SEVEN THOUSAND
PATIENTS BETWEEN INSTITUTIONS
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS
WITHOUT INCIDENT. R. INMATE AND
STAFF TESTING PROTOCOLS WERE
DEVELOPED IN CONSULTATION WITH
CDPH AND THEY CONTINUE TO
EVOLVE AS WE LEARN MORE ABOUT
THIS VIRUS. THIS FREQUENCY OF
TESTING IS BASED UPON JOB
CLASSIFICATION NUMBER OF CASES
IN THE INSTITUTION RESULTS OF
OUR SURVEILLANCE TESTING. AND
THE MISSION AT THE PRISON. R.
OUTBREAKS AT SAN QUENTIN AND
FOLSOM TAUGHT US THAT THIS
VIRUS IS SPREAD BY AIRBORNE
TRANSMISSION. SOMETHING THAT
WAS NOT ACKNOWLEDGED BY THE CDC
UNTIL OCTOBER FIFTH OF THIS
YEAR. WE ALSO LEARN THAT ONE OF
THE BIGGEST RISK FACTORS FOR
SPREAD WITHIN OUR INSTITUTION
WAS HOUSING IN DORMS OR STYLES
WITH OPEN STOREFRONTS. IN
RESPONSE WE CREATED A UNIQUE
COM AT RISK SCORE SYSTEM WHICH
TAKES INTO ACCOUNT EACH
INDIVIDUAL PATIENT SPECIFIC
RISK PROSPEROUS NATION. AND
DEATH IN THE EVENT THAT THEY
BECOME INFECTED WITH COLD IT.
ALL OF OUR PATIENTS ARE
ASSIGNED A COLLUDED RIS ORDERS%
BEEN CALCULATED BASED UPON.
FACTORS SUCH AS AGE OBESITY AND
LUNG DISEASE. AND USING THIS
SCORING SYSTEM DURING THE
PROCESS OF OFFERING MOVEMENT
OUT OF DORMS IN INTO CLOSED
CELL FRONT HOUSING TO ALL
PATIENTS WERE SIGNIFICANTLY
ELEVATED. HOLDEN RISK WORSE
AFTER BECOME THAT ASK YOU TO
WRAP UP SHORTLY. CERTAINLY
OTHER SPECIFIC STEPS THAT WE
TOOK INCLUDED STRINGENT
OVERSIGHT OF OUTBREAKS OF THE
INSTITUTION BY DAILY PHONE
CALLS CONSULTING WITH THE PRISM
OFFICE THE COLEMAN SPECIAL
MASTER NOR CORTEX BURKE TRY
QUARANTINE SPACE THROUGHOUT OUR
FACILITIES AND PLANNING FOR
THEIR COMMUNITY BAXI SO TO
CONCLUDE WE CONTINUE TO FACE
ENORMOUS CHALLENGES TO THE
UNPRECEDENTED NATURE OF THIS
AND THIS OPERATE. IT'S AIRBORNE
TRANSMISSION ARE HOUSING
FACILITIES THEY'RE OFTEN NOT
CONDUCIVE TO PROTECTING
VULNERABLE PATIENTS AS POINTED
OUT BY SENATOR SKINNER THIS IS
FURTHER COMPLICATED BY THE LACK
OF ADHERENCE IN THE FREE
COMMUNITIES FACE COVERING AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCING
RECOMMENDATIONS WHICH IS
RESULTING IN. THIS CURRENT
STATEWIDE SEARCH. SO THREE OR
PRIMARY. CLINICAL STRESS FROM
FOR INCLUDE. MOVING ALL OVER
HIGH RISK PATIENTS TO THE
SAFEST AVAILABLE HOUSING.
ENFORCING EVEN MORE VIGOROUSLY
OUR PHYSICAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING DIRECTORS AND
INTENSIFYING HER PREPARATION
FOR A VACCINE DISTRIBUTION
OKAY. THANK YOU AND I'M
AVAILABLE FOR ANY OF YOUR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU DOCTOR
BACK- NEXT WILL HAVE CONNIE
GIPSON DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION
OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS AT CDC
ARE WELCOME. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
AND OUR EFFORTS AND WHERE WE
ARE RIGHT NOW AND WHAT WE'RE
PLANNING FOR THE FUTURE AS WE
WORK THROUGH. THIS COBIT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. FIRST I WANT
TO SHARE WITH YOU WE HAVE
UNDERGONE THE BIGGEST REDUCTION
IN PRISON POPULATION IN RECENT
HISTORY. AND WE'VE DONE SO IN A
MANNER THAT ENSURES PUBLIC
SAFETY AS OF NOVEMBER TWELFTH
TWENTY TWENTY CCAR'S M.
INSTITUTIONS IN CAMP. HAD A
POPULATION OF NINETY TWO
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY
ONE. THIS IS A 20% REDUCTION
FROM GREEK HOPE IT TIMES
BETWEEN JULY FIRST THROUGH
NOVEMBER SIXTEENTH CDC ARE AT
LEAST OVER TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS AND AGAIN THAT WAS
A COMBINATION OF THOSE RELEASED
ON THEIR NATURAL AS WELL AS A
RESULT OF OUR EARLY RELEASE
PROGRAMS THAT WE IMPLEMENTED.
AS WELL AS THOSE WHO WERE
IMPACTED BY THE TWELVE WEEK A
POSITIVE PROGRAM CREDITS THAT
WE IMPLEMENTED IN JULY.
ADDITIONALLY CDCR CONTINUES TO
PROCESS EARLY RELEASES ON A
ROLLING BASIS THROUGH THE ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAY RELEASE
PROGRAM. THESE RELEASES HAVE
HELP TO MAXIMIZE. PHYSICAL
DISTANCING IN OUR PRESENTS AND
HELP US A GREAT IN ISOLATION
APPOINTING SPACE AS WE WORK
TOWARDS- YES IN THE STATE'S
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION WE RESULT
IN TAKE FROM COUNTY JAILS IN A
SAFE AD CONTROLLED MANNER.
JAIL INTAKE INITIALLY RESULT
MAY TWENTY NINTH BUT THEY'LL
STOP JUNE TWENTY NINE IT A
POSITIVE CASES COMING INTO THE
SYSTEM. WE AGAIN RESULT IN TAKE
ON AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTH AS WE
GET TO A DOCTOR BIG JUST SPOKE
ABOUT PUT INTO PLACE OF
PROTOCOL. AS IT RELATES TO THE
EXPECTATION OF THE INDIVIDUALS.
BEEN MEDICALLY CLEAR PRIOR TO
TRANSFER. ONE NINETEEN AT TEN.
PER TO TRANCE. THAT THE STAFF
IN THE INMATES ON THE BUSES ARE
IN IN NINETY FIVE JOINT
TRANSPORTS. AND THEN WE COURT.
TESTED PEOPLE AGAIN AND
QUARANTINE THEM AND TEST AGAIN
BEFORE RELEASE OF QUARANTINE.
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
MITIGATING THE INTRODUCTION OF
CO THAT INTO OUR SYSTEM. SO FAR
WE HAVE ACCEPTED APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY THREE HUNDRED INMATES
FROM THIRTY EIGHT COUNTIES SAYS
RESUMPTION OF INTAKE. I DO WANT
TO SHARE WE STILL HAVE A
BACKLOG OF OVER EIGHT THOUSAND
PERSONS WAITING TO COME COUNTY.
FROM THE COUNTY JAILS. WE
ANTICIPATE THAT SOME OF THE
INDIVIDUALS AWAITING TRANSFER
FROM COUNTY JAILS WILL BE
RELEASED DIRECTLY FROM JAIL TO
THE APPLICATION OF THE TWELVE
WEEKS OTHER PROGRAMMING CREDITS.
PEOPLE HOUSE IN THE COUNTY JAIL
WHO WERE SENTENCED ON OR BEFORE
JULY FIFTH. WILL RECEIVE EIGHTY
FOUR DAYS A PPC AS LONG AS THEY
WERE DISCIPLINARY FREE FROM
MARCH FIRST THE JULY FIFTH
TWENTY TWENTY. IT DOES HAVE AN
ASTEROID PRISON PACKETS FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN SENTENCED
TO TWO YEARS OR LESS. AND WITH
THESE INDIVIDUALS CASE RECORDS
WILL CALCULATE A RELEASE DATE.
USING THEIR SENTENCING DATE AS
HER TERM DATE. BUT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS SUCH AS TO TWO
YEARS OR MORE THE BBC CREDITS
WILL BE APPLIED AFTER THEY
ARRIVE TO CDC ARE. ANOTHER
STRATEGY THAT WE CONTINUE TO
WORK ON AS DR BIG TALKED ABOUT
HIS MASS IMPORTS MET. AND TOBER
TWENTY SEVEN CDC RSPCA YET
ISSUED A REVISED MEMO ON MASS
EXPECTATIONS. WITH THE
EXPECTATION THAT OUR STAFF
AWARE AND THEIR MASS ANYTIME
THEY ARE NOT INSIDE A WALLED
OFFICE TOWER CONTROL BOTH. FOR
WITH THE ONLY EXCEPTION IS IF
THEY'RE RESPONDING TO AN ALARM.
THERE'S ALSO THE EXPECTATION
THAT WE ARE HOLDING OURSELVES
ACCOUNTABLE AS WE RECOGNIZE
THAT WE ARE THE ONES WHO ARE
BRINGING THIS INTO THE SYSTEM.
AS OUR STAFF HAVE BEEN HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR NON
COMPLIANCE. TO THE REST OF
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS. I WAS
JUST HAPPY BASS A PRISON
YESTERDAY AND I TO LOOKING AT
MASS. THE FINAL DEVELOPMENT I
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE FOR YOU IS
OUR ROADMAP TO RE OPENING SEC
ACS AND SEIZE YOUR WORK TO
RETURN A SENSE OF NORMALCY TO
THE PRESIDENT'S. DECISIONS
REGARDING WHEN AND HOW TO LIFT
RESTRICTIONS WILL BE MADE
AWFULLY AND ACCORDANCE WITH
GUIDANCE WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS. THE ROADMAP TO RE
OPENING WAS DEVELOPED AS A
MULTI PHASE MULTI DISCIPLINARY
APPROACH. ELEMENT OPERATIONS
TAKING IN CONSIDERATION CURRENT
COVERT NINETEEN CASES IN
INSTITUTIONS AND THE IMPACT OF
PREVALENCE VEHICLE THAT IN THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY. AS WELL
AS THE SAFETY AND SECURITY
NEEDS OF THE INSTITUTIONS
POPULATION WHILE BALANCING THE
IMPORTANCE OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS VISITING AND
ACTIVITIES TO THE WELL BEING OF
THOSE INCARCERATED IN STATE
PRISONS. AGAINST YOU TO PLEASE
WRAP UP SHORTLY. I HAVE-
CURRENTLY INTEGRATED SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER TREATMENT PROGRAMS
ARE HAPPENING AT THIRTY FOUR OR
THIRTY FIVE PRESENTS- WITH
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SIX INDIVIDUALS CURRENTLY
INVOLVED WE CONTINUE TO RUN- WE
HAVE PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
CLASSROOMS TECHNICAL EDUCATION
CLASSROOMS PRODUCTS CLASSROOMS
EITHER THROUGH CORRESPONDENCE-
ENDS. THIRTY PACKAGES FOR FACE
TO FACE AN SEO WHILE
MAINTAINING PHYSICAL DISCIPLINE-
WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OUR
INNOVATIVE GRANT RECIPIENTS TO
EXPAND THEIR PROGRAMS AND THE
DEPARTMENT IS LOOKING TO
EXPAND- PROGRAM IN WHICH WE
CAN. DO BRAG EARNING CREDITS
FOR A REMOTE LEARNING IN
ADDITION WE RECOGNIZE THAT IN
PERSON VISITATION IS IMPORTANT
PART OF REHABILITATION BUT IN
CONSULTATION WITH CDPH CCAC
ADDS. TO THE RISING NUMBER OF
KOBE CASES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CDCR WILL NOT BE DONE IN PERSON
VISITING AT ANY TIME SO PLEASE
ARAMBULA WORKING DILIGENTLY TO
LAUNCH VIDEO VISITING AT OUR
PRESENCE STARTING WITH FIVE BY
THE END UP BY THANKSGIVING.
THANK WEDNESDAY I AM C. C. W.
YOU'LL CREEK AND VALLEY WITH
THE REST OF THE PRISONS COMING
ON BOARD BY CHRISTMAS VIDEO
VISITATION WILL BE FREE TO
FAMILIES WHO CAN USE THEIR OWN
DEVICES. TO CALL AND WHAT THE
APPOINTMENTS. CLOSING YOUR SEE
THAT ARE MAKING CHALLENGE AT
INTO. FACING CHALLENGES AS
WE'RE TRYING TO REDEFINE OUR
NEW NORMAL. HEY THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS
WHETHER DEPARTMENT IS AT A
LOCAL MANY QUESTIONS OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WE WILL BE
TAKING QUESTIONS FROM SENATORS
AT THE END OF THIS PANEL AND
DEPRIVE YOU MORE OPPORTUNITIES
TO SPEAK MORE AT LENGTH BUT I.
DO ASK THAT. WE TRY TO STICK TO
OUR TIME LIMIT. NEXT UP WE HAVE
A JEANS KING. AND QUEEN THE
ELEVATOR CENTER. AND THAT BE
FORTY YOU'RE TALKING. THANK YOU.
THANKS TO THE CHIU AND MEMBERS
OF BOTH COMMITTEES FOR A LONG
THE SPEAK IT AGAIN. SINCE I
LAST GAVE TESTIMONY IN JULY
REGARDING THE OUTBREAK IS SANTA
WAS PANDEMIC IN OUR STATE
PRISONS THANKS OF RUNNING
RECENTLY WORSE NEED CDCR
OFFICIALS NOR THE FEDERAL
RECEIVER HAVE TAKEN SIMPLE
STEPS NEEDED TO ADDRESS THE
BASIC HEALTH NEEDS. OF
INCARCERATED PEOPLE WITHIN OUR
STATE. IN A FOUR AND A HALF
MONTHS SINCE WE LAST SPOKE OVER
TWELVE THOUSAND CARS THREE
PEOPLE HAVE BECOME INFECTED
CLOSE TO FIVE THOUSAND STAFF
MEMBERS. OVER EIGHTY PEOPLE
HAVE DIED. AS I WRITE THIS FIVE
PRISONS ARE EXPERIENCING TRIPLE
DIGIT SURGES IN CONFIRMED
CASES. EVERYONE OF OUR STATE
PRISONS HAS HAD AT LEAST ONE
OUTBREAK. THE PEOPLE I SPEAK
WITH INSIDE OF OUR PRISONS TELL
ME THE PRISONS ARE STILL
EXTREMELY OVERCROWDED CDCR HAS
OVER NINETY TWO THOUSAND
INCARCERATED PEOPLE CURRENTLY
IN THE PRISONS THEMSELVES ARE
STILL AT OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
5% CAPACITY. RELEASING PEOPLE
SIX MONTHS EARLY IS NOT IN THE
MOVIE PEOPLE FROM THE MOST
CROWDED PRISONS THE LAST
OVERCROWDED PRISONS SIMPLY
CREATES NEW POTENTIAL HOT SPOTS.
CDC ARTS POLICY OF LIMITING
PEOPLE'S ACCESS TO YOUR CURRENT
AND FRESH AIR BASTILLE FORCED
ME TO WORK IN THE AREAS THAT
BRING THEM INTO CLOSE PROXIMITY
WITH STAFF. INCREASES OUTBREAKS.
RELEASES HAVE ACTUALLY SLOWED
DUE TO A LACK OF PROGRAM BEGIN
ABILITY TO EARN PROGRAMS
EXPERTS. PEOPLE WANT TO SEE
THEIR FAMILIES BUT ARE AFRAID
VISITS WILL BE OVERLY PUNITIVE
EVEN THOUGH INTERACTION WITH
CORRECTIONAL STAFF REMAINS THE
MOST LIKELY WAY TO BECOME
INFECTED. IN RESPONSE TO THE
DIRE CIRCUMSTANCES INCARCERATED
PEOPLE THEIR FAMILIES IN FRONT
NOT PRISON STAFF OR
EXPERIENCING CDC OURS OFFICIALS
ARE WORKING ON PLANS TO CONDUCT
MORE TRANSFERS AND WE OPEN
PRESENT PROGRAM. THE CDC ARE
PLANNED SALES BECAUSE THERE IS
NO SELF SAFE WAY TO PROTECT
OVER NINETY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
THIRTY FOUR PRISONS. IN CLOSING
I'D LIKE TO GIVE UPDATES ON A
FEW OF THE PEOPLE I MENTIONED
AT OUR LAST MEETING. THRACO
EIGHTY YEARS OLD. WITH MULTIPLE
HEART PROBLEMS IS STILL
INCARCERATED AT SAN QUENTIN. IT
WAS NOT CONSIDERED FOR HIGH
RISK MEDICAL RELEASE BECAUSE HE
HAS AN INDETERMINATE SENTENCE.
LONNIE MORRIS DIMITRIUS MING HE
TOM WICKER AND GUESTS OF WENT
AS ALL REMAIN IN PRISON EVEN
THOUGH EACH OF HIGH RISK IN
EACH SIGNED A RELEASE PLANTS.
MY DEAR FRIEND GEROW WHO
CONTRACTED BECAUSE OF IT. WHILE
HE WAS BATTLING CANCER PASSED
AWAY TWO WEEKS AFTER THE JULY
HEARING. HE WAS NEVER
CONSIDERED FOR A HIGH RISK
MEDICAL RELEASE BECAUSE HE HAD
AN INDETERMINATE SENTENCE. I'M
HAPPY TO SAY PATRICIA RIGHT HAS
BEEN RELEASED IN SPITE OF THE
CANCER SHE CONTINUES TO FIGHT
HE'S DEVOTING CONSIDERABLE TIME
TO ADVOCATING FOR PEOPLE FROM.
THE WOMEN'S PRISONS WHO ARE
EQUALLY DESERVING OF RELEASE
WOMEN LIKE MARIA OUT I DON'T
KNOW AND YOU SEE A PROBLEM
WE'RE STILL INCARCERATED BY
BATTLING CANCER. BOTH BAILEY'S
BROWN ANTHONY M. AS FAMILIES
WERE INFORMED THEIR RELEASES
WOULD BE EXPEDITED ONLY TO HAVE
OFFICIALS HALT THEIR RELEASES
AT THE LAST MOMENT CAUSING
EMOTIONAL PAIN THAT IS STILL ON
GOING. MANY PEOPLE INSIDE ARE
EXCITED THAT THE LEGISLATOR
LEGISLATURE REFORMED ELDERLY
PAROLE TO INCLUDE PEOPLE WHO
ARE FIFTY YEARS OF AGE NO BEEN
INCARCERATED FOR TWENTY YEARS.
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE WHO QUALIFY
WILL HAVE TO WAIT SEVERAL
MONTHS TO BE SCHEDULED FOR
PAROLE HEARINGS SO I HOPE THE
CDCR REFERS ELDERLY PRO
CANDIDATES FOR RE SENTENCING IN
THE COURTS OR THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH. GRANSDEN CLEMENCY. MY
FRIENDS IS OUT OF PRISON ARE
UNIFIED IN THEIR BELIEF THE
TRANSFERS ARE DANGEROUS. THEY
LIVE THE POLICIES THAT CDCR
IMPLEMENTS A NO BETTER THAN
ANYONE THE RISKS AND REWARDS OF
PROPOSED TRANSFERS. THE THINGS
THEY ARE ASKING FOR A 1100%
CONSISTENT WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS MEDICAL
EXPERTS IN THE FIRST DISTRICT
COURT OF APPEALS WHICH IS
CALLED THE CDC OUR RESPONSE THE
SAN QUINN OUTBREAK. MORALLY
UNTENABLE AND LEGALLY
INDEFENSIBLE. IN RESPONSE CDCR
STATED THE RESPONSE THAT
OUTBREAK AT SAN QUENTIN WAS
REASONABLE PLEASE WRAP UP SOON.
ELDERLY PEOPLE WERE LACKING FOR
MINOR CASES WHERE PEOPLE WERE
CONFIRMED TO HAVE CALLED. OUR
PRISONS ARE HOME TO SOME OF THE
LARGEST CLUSTER OUTBREAKS IN
THE WORLD BECAUSE CDCR REFUSES
TO CONSIDER PEOPLE FOR HIGH
RISK RELEASE IF THEY HAVE AN
INDETERMINATE SENTENCE.
RESPECTFULLY A PERSON SINCE HAS
NO RELEVANCE UPON THEIR MEDICAL
NEEDS IF THE FEDERAL RECEIVER
AND CDCR DEEM THAT RESEMBLE TO
MAKE THIS THE DETERMINING
FACTOR. THEY'VE PROVEN TIME AND
TIME AGAIN THEY CAN'T FOLLOW
THEIR BASIC MANDATE OF KEEPING
PEOPLE SAFE FROM COLD. THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANKS FOR MUCH
MISTER KING- AND FINALLY OUR
LAST WITNESS ON THIS PANEL IS
DOCTORS STEFANO. BUT DOES HE I
HOPE I GOT THAT CORRECT. DEAN
EMERITUS AND PROFESSOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA BERKELEY
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
WELCOME. THANK YOU SENATOR IT'S
A PLEASURE TO BE HERE WITH YOU.
I'M WAS ASKED TO SAY A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WHAT UC BERKELEY AND
UCSF I'VE BEEN DOING TOGETHER
AS PART OF THE CODE IN
CALIFORNIA PRISONS PROGRAM
WHICH WE DO WITH THE AMEND
PROGRAM AT UCSF AND SINCE THE
LAST HEARING WHEN DR SEARS WAS
WITH YOU WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
PREPARING AND DISSEMINATING
EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS FOR
RESIDENTS AND WORK FORCE IN OUR
PRISONS HAVE BEEN CONDUCTING
WEBINARS FOR CLINICIANS TO KEEP
THEM APPRISED OF CODE NINETEEN
TREATMENT BEST PRACTICES. THAT
WE CONDUCTED AN ONSITE
EVALUATION OF THE RESPONSE TO
THE CODE THIRTEEN INTRODUCTION
CODE NINETEEN INTRODUCTION
EXCUSE ME AT- THE CALIFORNIA
MEN'S COLONY BECAUSE IT WAS AN
EXAMPLE OF A SUCCESSFUL
CONTAINMENT OF AN OUTBREAK AND
THAT COULD SERVE AS A BEST
PRACTICE FOR OTHER PRISONS
WE'VE BEEN PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ADVICE TO THE CDC OUR
LEADERSHIP ON AN AD HOC BASIS
AND WE'RE STARTING NOW A NEW
PROJECT TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
COVERT NINETEEN TRANSMISSION
WITHIN THE PRISONS TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT NOT ONLY THE MITIGATION
STRATEGIES THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED BUT ALSO THE PHYSICAL
CHARACTERISTICS OF EACH PRESENT
AND HOW THEY INCREASE OR
DECREASE SUSCEPTIBILITY. TO
TRANSMISSION. WHAT ARE OF OUR
THOUGHTS ABOUT HOW TO PREPARE
FOR THE NEXT PHASE OF THE UP.
BUT OF THE PANDEMIC. NUMBER
ONE. BUT JUST TO UNDERLINE WHAT
WE JUST HEARD FROM MISTER KING.
WE CONTINUE TO STRONGLY
ADVOCATE FOR ACCELERATED
RELEASE AND FOR LOW. THE RECENT
EXPLOSIVE EPIDEMICS THAT WE'VE
SEEN FOR EXAMPLE AT THE-
CALIFORNIA SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT FACILITY AND OF HIGH
DESERT. SHOW THAT WE CAN HAVE-
NEW OUTBREAKS WITH HUNDREDS IN
THE CASE OF THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT FACILITY ALMOST FIVE
HUNDRED IN THE CASE OF HIGH
DESERT. NO MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED JUST WITHIN THE LAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS. BUT THE
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE
IN LARGE CONGREGATE SETTINGS IN
THE PRISONS. ARE NOT ABLE TO BE
PROTECTED AND WE NEED MANY MORE
PEOPLE TO BE RELEASED TO BE
ABLE TO KEEP THOSE WHO MUST
STAY INSIDE. SAFE FROM THESE
KIND OF EXPLOSIVE. OUTBREAKS
SECONDLY WE NEED TO DO A BETTER
JOB OF COWORKING IMAGINE A
NURSING HOME THAT INSTEAD OF
HAVING A HUNDRED RESIDENTS HAD
FOUR THOUSAND RESIDENTS. BY
TAKING A PRISON A LARGE PRISON
AND SUBDIVIDING IT SO THAT
FUNCTIONALLY IT'S A NUMBER OF
SMALLER PRISONS. YOU REDUCE THE
ABILITY TO HAVE A SMALL
OUTBREAK TURN INTO AN EXPLOSIVE
OUTBREAK LIKE LIKE WE'VE SEEN
IN SEVERAL PRISONS. WE NEED TO
DO THAT BY KEEPING BOTH
RESIDENTS AND STAFF. ASSIGNED
TO THEIR MANY PRISON WITHIN THE
PRISON. THE NOW. THIRDLY AS
MENTIONED BY DOCTOR BACK WE'RE
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE ADVENT
OF THE NEW VACCINES IN THE
EFFECTIVENESS THAT THEY SEEM TO
HAVE. AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT- CALIFORNIA PRISON STAFF
AND RESIDENTS ARE PRIORITIZED
FOR THE VACCINES THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS ACCESS TO. MY
WITH A SPECIALLY UNDERLINED THE
NEED FOR STAFF TO BE VACCINATED
BECAUSE AS WE'VE HEARD FROM
OTHER SPEAKERS. IT'S STAFF WILL
PROVIDE THE VEHICLE OF
INTRODUCTION OF THE VIRUS INTO
THE PRISONS. THAT GETS
AMPLIFIED AND EXPLOSIVELY
WITHIN THE PRISON AND THEN IS A
DANGER TO THE COMMUNITY BOTH
BECAUSE OF TRANSMISSION BACK
OUT TO THE COMMUNITY. AND
BECAUSE OF OVERWHELMING LOCAL
HEALTH CARE RESOURCES. SO WE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGED THAT THERE
SOMEBODY IS REPRESENTING
CORRECTIONS ON THE GOVERNOR'S
FAXING PREPOSITION TASK FORCE.
AND WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
THE ACCEPTANCE OF VACCINATION
AMONG BOTH- STAFF AND-
RESIDENTS OF THE PRISONS AND SO
WE THINK IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT WE WILL CONTRIBUTE TO
WORKING WITH INMATES COUNCIL'S
FAMILY COMMUNITY PARTNERS AS
WELL AS THE UNIONS. TO TRY TO
REDUCE ANY RELUCTANCE TO BE
VACCINATED- IN THE CASE OF- THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
WIDE WE HAVE RECENTLY
INSTITUTED AN OBLIGATORY
INFLUENZA VACCINATION POLICY I
CAN'T GO TO CAMPUS IF I'M NOT
BACK SENATE AGAINST INFLUENZA.
AND IT SEEMS TO ME THAT WE GOT
A MINIMUM SHOULD DO THE SAME
FOR THE STAFF AT WORKING IN OUR
PRISONS BECAUSE WITH INFLUENZA
AND HOPEFULLY SOON COVERT
VACCINATION WILL BE ABLE TO
PROTECT THE POPULATION IN THE
PRISONS. ALMOST LASTLY I WANT
TO MENTION. THAT DR BIG BIG
MENTION THAT HE'S HAVING A
BETTER TIME NOW WITH THE TURN
AROUND TIME ON TESTS BUT THAT
HAS BEEN A MAJOR PROBLEM. AND
WITH THE SURGE IS HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA I'M VERY CONCERNED.
THAT THE TURNAROUND TIME WILL
FALL. IT'S INEXCUSABLE AROUND
HAVE LONG TURNAROUND TIME FOR
TESTING IT'S BETTER TO HAVE
LESS TESTING IN THE COMMUNITY.
THAT HAVE WEEK LONG TURNAROUND
TIMES BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE A
LONG TURNAROUND TIME. YOU CAN'T
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE RESULTS
OF THE TEST TO INTERRUPT
TRANSMISSION AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE DOING THE TESTING FOR. IN
MOST CASES SO WE NEED IT
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT. THESE
EPIDEMICS AND OUTBREAKS HAPPEN
EXPLOSIVELY WITHIN PRISONS WE
NEED TO PRIORITIZE THE PRISONS
FOR RAPID RESPONSE- FROM THE TO
THE TESTING SERVICES. THANK YOU
CAN FINALLY I WANT TO MENTION
SOMETHING THAT'S ALREADY BEEN
MENTIONED I WAS VERY VERY HAPPY
TO HEAR TODAY ABOUT THE NEW
TABLET PROGRAM WE'VE BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR THAT. IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE IN
OUR PRISONS TO NOT LOSE CONTACT
WITH THEIR FAMILIES TO MAINTAIN
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH BUT ALSO TO
MAINTAIN. THEIR COOPERATION
WITH- PP AND- SOCIAL
DISTANCING. AND SO- THE TABLET
PROGRAM WILL GO A LONG WAY. BUT
IT'S ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING PUT INTO
ISOLATION QUARANTINE. IN ORDER
RATIONALE. FOR DOCTOR. LOOK
FORWARD WHILE. WITH CENTER. AND
TO REPORT EARLIER. WE NEED TO
MAKE THAT WHAT WILL. TO THEM
WHEN THAT HAPPENS ISOLATION
QUARANTINE IS NOT PUNITIVE. BUT
THEY WILL HAVE IF ANYTHING
ENHANCED COMMUNICATION. WITH
THEIR FAMILIES FOR PEOPLE ON
THE OUTSIDE AND WITH THEIR
FELLOW RESIDENTS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE- THAT I
THINK ALL THE PRESENTERS- I
SAID AS I MENTIONED EARLIER I'M
SURE WE'LL HAVE EVEN MORE TIME
FOR ELABORATION. AS MEMBERS
LAST QUESTIONS- SO I NOW WILL
TAKE MEMBER QUESTIONS FOR THOSE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY PLEASE
USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE- I SOMETIMES CAN'T TELL
WHT ORDER PEOPLE DO THAT SO.
PLEASE HAVE PATIENCE WITH ME
WITH THAT IN TERMS OF WATER- I
BELIEVE WE HAVE CENTER-
MCGUIRE- DOES HAVE A QUESTION.
SO WE'LL BEGIN WITH SENATE
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU AYE I WOULD
JUST HOPE THAT SENATORS WOULD
BE ABLE TO AMUSE THEMSELVES-
AND NOT HAVE- OPERATORS DO THAT
THAT THAT WOULD BE A REQUEST AS
WE MOVE FORWARD IN HEARINGS
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO. DIRECT YOUR
QUESTION TO DIRECTOR GIPSON-
AND IT SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO-
DEL NORTE COUNTY I DON'T KNOW
IF DIRECTOR GIPSON IS STILL ON
THE LINE. THANK I AM. RIGHT A
GESTURE GIPSON THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION I
DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
GIPSON OKAY THAT WOULD ONLY
SUCH ITEM ITEM. JUDGE GIPSON AT
WOULD I HEARD YOU SAY THAT YOU
UP AND DOWN COUNTY PELICAN BAY
THANK YOU FOR MAKING THE
TRAVELS UP NORTH AS WELL
YESTERDAY. YES I'M BETTER
DIRECTOR JUST A FEW ITEMS IN
THIS IS COMING FROM THE PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT IN I DON'T
KNOW OUR COUNTY AND I JUST
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO TRACK
DOWN THESE ANSWERS IN AND GET
YOUR TAKE ON THEM ACCORDING TO
THE PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT IN
DELAWARE COUNTY THERE'S BEEN
EVIDENCE THAT THE MANDATORY
TESTING- THAT IS BEEN A DANCE
IN THE PRISON HAS NOT BEEN
ENFORCED CAN YOU COMMENT ON
THAT- IT HAS BEEN ENFORCEMENT
INDIVIDUALS- THAT WERE SUPPOSED
TO BE TESTED EACH WEEK- AND
THAT IS OBVIOUSLY- I HAD A
CONCERN. TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT BEING SUCH A SMALL
COUNTY BUT I WANTED TO BE ABLE
TO GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BE ABLE TO COMMENT ON THIS AND
THEN ALSO WOULD LOVE TO BE TO
SET UP A CALL WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS THE
COUNTY DOWN OR DIG DEEP I HAD
TO DIG DEEPER INTO THESE ISSUES
BUT AFTER GIPSON AND A FEW
QUESTIONS BUT IF YOU DON'T MIND
JUST IN THAT. FIRST IN REGARDS
TO THE MANDATORY TESTING. SO I
AM ASSUMING. HE'S ME TALKING
ABOUT STAFF TO. OR A THE TEST.
I BELIEVE IT'S- TEST. SO I KNOW
WE'RE CONTINUALLY AS WE
CONTINUE TO TEST OUR STOP EVERY
TWO WEEKS- WE'VE RUN INTO STAFF
WERE REFUSING TO TEST AND I
KNOW WHEN I SPOTTED AWARD
YESTERDAY HE SAID IT IS A
CHALLENGE UP THERE BUT HE IS
HOLDING A STAFF ACCOUNTABLE TO
ENSURE THEY ARE COMPLIANT WITH
TESTY SO IT CONTINUES TO BE AS
DR BIG SPOKE ABOUT WE TALK
ABOUT WITH THE INMATES OR STAFF
POSTED EDUCATION BUT ALSO
THERE'S AN EXPECTATION THAT OUR
STOCK FOR TESTING WITH AND IT'S
THE WHOLE REASON WHY WE PUT
THE- TESTING PROGRAM INTO
PLACE. SO I KNOW- IS. IS A
CHALLENGE- BETTER IMAGES SOME
OF IT YEAH. IS THERE A
PERCENTAGE AND I'M MAKING THESE
UP TO SIXTY FORTY OR FIFTY
FIFTY DO WE KNOW WHAT THE
PERSON IN CHARGE OF THOSE STAFF
THAT ARE TESTED- IN COMPLIANCE
IN THOSE WHO ARE NOT. ENATOR I
DON'THAVE THAT INFORMATION BUT
I CAN GLAD TO GET IT FOR YOU. I
WOULD BE VERY MUCH. YEAH DEBBIE
BUT YOU SHOULDN'T THANK YOU
MADAM DIRECTOR THE OTHER
PIECES. YOU HAD SAID THAT- HE
HE SAW A LOT OF MASK WEARING
AGAIN THERE'S SOME ONGOING
CONCERNS ABOUT A LACK OF
ENFORCEMENT- WITH MASK USED
AROUND. THE PRISON AGAIN THIS
IS NOT AND I GOTCHA BUT JUST
WANTED TO SIMPLY HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION SINCE YOU'RE HERE
AND WOULD LOVE TO FOLLOW UP. SO
YOU DO BELIEVE THAT THERE IS
ROBUST ENFORCEMENT. OF STAFF.
TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE WEARING
THEIR MASKS IN. AND AROUND THE
PRISON IS THAT ACCURATE. HE AND
I SAY WE EVEN FOCUS ON IT. I
CAN SHARE WITH YOU WHAT I WAS
UP TALKING TO THE WHARTON
YESTERDAY. I MEAN ON TUESDAY
BECAUSE I DROVE BACK YESTERDAY-
HE'S HERE WITH ME THAT HE HAD
DONE CORRECTIVE ACTION ONLY
THIRTEEN EMPLOYEES. IN THE LAST
WEEK OR SO. OR NOT COMPLIANCE
WITH THE MASS ISSUE SO I CAN
TELL YOU- WE CONTINUE TO MAKE
SURE THE STAFF UNDERSTAND IS NO
DIFFERENT THAN ANY OTHER SAFETY
EQUIPMENT THEY'RE REQUIRED TO
WEAR. AND THERE'S AN
EXPECTATION YOU WILL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR NON COMPLIANCE.
THANK YOU MA'AM I. WOULD LIKE
TO BE A- MOVE OVER TO CONTACT
TRACING. MY UNDERSTANDING IS
FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT IN DELAWARE COUNTY.
THAT- THE PRISON IS ONLY
PROVIDING POSITIVE NEGATIVE
STATUS OF INDIVIDUALS BUT NOT
PROVIDED THE INTERNAL CONTACT
TRACING INFORMATION WHICH IS
BEING CRITICAL ESPECIALLY IN
SUCH A SMALL COMMUNITY WITH
SUCH A LIMITED CAPACITY WHEN IT
COMES TO- HOSPITAL FACILITIES
THAT'S A CHALLENGE AS DATING
THE COUNTY'S BEEN TRYING TO.
ADVANCE A ROBUST CONTACT
TRACING A PROGRAM DO YOU KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT OR IS THAT
AN ISSUE THAT WE'RE GONNA NEED
TO GET TO GO OFFLINE ON. WE
NEED TO GO OFF LINE- CONTACT
TRACING RIGHT NOW IS BEING LED
BY CCAC YES SO I DON'T KNOW A
DOCTOR BIG MAY HAVE SOME
RESPONSE OR WE MAY NOT NEED TO
GET BACK TO YOU SENATOR. OKAY
IT HAPPENED HERE FROM DOCTOR
BACON THERE'S JUST ONE OTHER
ITEM. MADRICK IN APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE WITH MY
QUESTIONS- INTAKE YOU MISTER
CHAIR ADVENTURES AS WELL. THE
INDIANA KINDS IS WOULD LOVE TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE A FURTHER
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS IS
THERE BEEN DELAYS IN GETTING
THE INFORMATION. TO PUBLIC
HEALTH STAFF. ON ON THE CONTENT
TREATING IT COULD TAKE DAYS
MANY TIMES OVER A WEEK. TO BE
ABLE TO GET THE INFORMATION.
FROM CDC ARE TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH AT WHICH HAS
DEEPLY HAMPERED THAT THAT THE
CONTACT TRACING EFFORTS IN
DELAWARE COUNTY. SO AGAIN MADAM
DIRECTOR I'M NOT THROWN I
GOTCHA QUESTIONS THAT IS WHEN-
I PUT A PIN IN THIS ONE. AND
THAT IS SOMETHING ELSE THAT
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO.
DETERMINE IS HOW. WE CAN
EXPEDITE THOSE. RESULTS COMING
BACK TO YOU- THE COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
BE ABLE TO COMPLETE THAT ROBUST
CONTRACT TRACING PROGRAM BUT
I'D BE HAPPY TO HEAR YOUR
RESPONSE AT THIS TIME. AM I
WOULD HAVE TO NEED TO FOLLOW UP
ON THAT. THANK YOU SOME MORE
INFORMATION UNLESS DOCTOR BIG
MAYBE CAN SPEAK ON IT. THANK
YOU MADAM DIRECTOR I'D THROUGH
THE CHAIR IF IT'S ALRIGHT I HAD
DOCTOR BIG JUST A QUICK
RESPONSE IN MADAM DIRECTOR WILL
BE FOLLOWING UP THANK YOU
AGAIN. FOR YOUR RESPONSES-
STARTER DECKS THANK TO PICK IF
YOU COULD PLEASE. GIVE A
RESPONSE. YES CENTER REQUIRE WE
AGREE WITH YOU 1100% IN THESE-
DAILY CALLS THATWE'RE HAVING
WITH THE INSTITUTIONS WERE
REINFORCING THE NECESSITY. THAT
THE INSTITUTIONS COMMUNICATE
WITH THEIR PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. IN ALL EIGHTEEN
COUNTIES WERE WE HAVE PRISONS
AT LEAST WEEKLY. AND I MYSELF
HAVE STARTED CALLS IN FACT THIS
WEEK I HAD A CONVERSATION WITH
DOCTOR REAL WALL FROM YOUR
COUNTY. AND COMMITTED TO HIM
AND HIS STAFF THAT WE WILL DO
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN. TO
FACILITATE- IS MANAGEMENT OF
CASES IN THAT COUNTY. PERFECT
THAT'S GREAT A JUDGE WE NEED
NOT TO BE ABLE TO INCLUDE YOU
ON THIS- THAT WE DO HAVE A
SCENE WHERE CDC ARE- IS WELL AS
THE COUNTY YOU WOULDN'T MIND
UNITED SHE- AT YOUR PROACTIVE
NATURE WITH DOCTOR RAY WHILE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER. UP IN
JAIL OR CAN I MISTER JR THANK
YOU DR BIG MADAM DIRECTOR THANK
THE FOR FOLLOWING NEXT WEEK.
THANK SIR MCGUIRE. SO JUST A
FOR DEPENDING OF THE OTHER
MEMBERS I WILL NEXT GO TO
CENTER GONZALEZ AND THEN I'LL
HAVE CENTERS SKINNER CAPPIELLO
BRADFORD IN JACKSON SO THAT'S
THE ORDER I HAVE. FOR RIGHT
NOW. A SERVER GONZALEZ. YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU FOR THIS FIRST PANEL-
I WANT TO START MY QUESTIONS
ARE DIRECTED TO- DIRECTOR BAKER
GIPSON- THE FIRST QUESTION IS
RELATIVE TO. IN SOME WAYS WHAT
US SENATOR MCGUIRE HAD ASKED AS
WELL ABOUT- THE FACE COVERINGS
AND SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
HADN'T BEEN. BETTER WORK ARE
BEING WORKED ON RIGHT NOW ARE
IN PROGRESS. I KNOW THE OFFICE
OF INSPECTOR GENERAL RECENTLY
ISSUED THEIR FINDINGS JUBILEE
WAS NOVEMBER TENTH SYSTEMS YOU
KNOW. NOT TOO LONG AGO- THAT
ADDRESS MANY OF THESE ISSUES.
FEES COVERING DIRECTIVES AT
TWENTY THREE OF THE THIRTY FOUR
PRISONS THEY VISITED DID NOT.
HAVE DIRECTIVES. THEY ALSO DOWN
FAILURE TO COMPLETE SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS I KNOW
YOU KNOW THIS VETERANS CETERA.
MY QUESTION IS WHAT NEXT STEPS
IF ANY WILL CDCR TO TAKE TO
RESPOND TO THOSE AND THEN
SECOND TO THAT I KNOW OUR
DIRECTOR GIPSON HAD MENTIONED.
A ROAD MAP TO RE OPENING SO.
WOULD THAT NEED TO BE UPDATED
AS WELL. SO IN RESPONSE TO THE-
I OFFER OF HIS GENERAL SUPPORT
THERE WAS A CLARIFICATION MEMO
THAT WAS SENT OUT JOINTLY BY
THE RECEIVER AND THE SECRETARY.
THAT GAVE CLEAR EXPECTATIONS OF
MASS WHERE FOR OUR EMPLOYEES.
ADDITIONALLY AS I STATED
EARLIER- CDCR CCAC AS EXECUTIVE
STAFF YES MY TRIP THE PELICAN
BAY IN MY OTHER PRESENTED TO
RECENTLY. WE ARE OUTDOOR SPOT
CHECKS AND- UNANNOUNCED VISITS
TO THOSE PRESENTS TAT GO OUT
THERE AND LOOK AT MASS
COMPLIANCE. AS WELL AS THE
EXPECTATION THAT THE WARDENS
AND THEIR MANAGEMENT TEAMS I
KNOW BACK TO BACK WILL SAY THE
CEO THAN THEIR TEAMS. OUT THERE
WALKING LOOKING AT AT. THE
MASTER PLANNED SOCIAL
DISTANCING REVIEWS AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE HOLDING
OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE AND- SO
THAT WE HAVE A COMFORT LEVEL
THAT. PEOPLE ARE LOOKING AT
MASS COMPLIANCE SOCIAL
DISTANCING COMPLIANT- WE ARE
WORKING. COLLECTIVELY DEVELOP A-
TRACKING DOT THAT WILL US BE
ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE AND SHOW.
THE EMPLOYEES WHO ARE HAVING TO
BE ADDRESSED ON THESE ISSUES
WHAT ACTION HAS TAKEN PLACE
WHETHER THIS IS A REPEAT
OFFENDER AND THEN THE ACTION
SHOULD BE ELEVATED AS WE
CONTINUE TO THE PROGRESSIVE
DISCIPLINE. PROCESS WE TAKE IT
VERY SERIOUSLY OUR OBLIGATION
TO TRY TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
MAKING THE WORK ENVIRONMENT A
STATE THAT WE CAN NOT ONLY FOR
THE POPULATION WE SERVE BEFORE
OUR STAFF THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
TO COMMUNITIES THEY LIVE IN.
AND SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE I KNOW
WE'RE ALSO IN THE MIX AND UP
PROCESS AND- WE BY SEEN ANOTHER
MASS MEMO THAT WALTER STAFF
ABOUT THE TYPE OF MATH THAT
EVERYBODY WE- ARE TO WEAR. SO
THERE'S SOME OTHER THINGS TO
THAT ARE IN THE WORKS. TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR EXPECTATIONS OF
THAT AGENCY OR OUT THERE ABOUT
MATH COMPLIANCE. AND IN THE
ROADMAP TO RE OPENING QUESTION
I'M SORRY. YES I HAD JUST
ASKED. ME- TO STRANGER GIPSON
IF THAT NEEDS TO BE UPDATED
GIVEN ALL THESE CLARIFICATION
MEMOS AND GET IT. ASIDE FROM
JUST MASK WEARING THEIR WORK-
QUITE A FEW- ISSUES LISTED IN
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT.
AND HOW THAT WOULD BE A DRESSER
THAT NEEDS TO IS IF THE ROAD
MAP TO RE OPENING NEEDS TO BE
UPDATED GIVEN THIS- NEW
INFORMATION. SO I THINK A
COUPLE OF THINGS I'M NOT. SURE
IT NEEDS TO BE THE ROADMAP TO
RE OPENING BECAUSE A ROADMAP TO
RE OPENING REALLY DEALS WITH
HOW ARE WE GOING TO BRING. HOW
DO WE DEFINE OUR NEW NORMAL
PROCESS FOR THE PRISONS GETTING
PROGRAM BACK TO OUR POPULATION
WHO BEEN OUT. THEN WENT OUT.
AND MANY PROGRAMS VISITING THAT
TYPE OF THING FOR SEVERAL
MONTHS NOW. BUT IT HAS. CHANGED
THE WAY WE DONE OUR SCREENING
PROCESS WHERE WE- EVERY
INSTITUTION HAS HAD. TO ENSURE
THAT THEIR SCREENING LOCATION
WHERE STAFF ARE BEING SCREENED
EVERY DAY BEFORE THEY COME INTO
THE PRESIDENT **** SYMPTOMS
QUESTION A TEMPERATURE CHECK IS
DONE. THAT EVERY STAFF PERSON
IS NOT ABLE TO BE CIRCUMVENT IT
I WAS PART OF WHAT THE- I. G.
FILE. SINGLE AT LEAST CHANGE
THAT PROCESS UP AND THAT'S PART
OF WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT WHEN
WE GO OUT THERE IS A LOOK AT
THEIR SCREENING PROCESS. MANY
FOLKS HAVE DEVELOPED AT AND
I'LL CALL IT A CHOKEPOINT AT
THE PRISON WHERE THEY'RE DYING
EVERY BE ABLE TO ONE LOCATION.
SO THAT- EVERYONE AND THEY CAN
ENSURE THAT EVERYONE IS
SCREENED BUT THOSE WHO THE
PHYSICAL DESIGNED AS OF. LATE
FOR THAT. THEN THEY PUT OTHER
MEASURES IN PLACE TO ENSURE THE
STAFF OF THE INAPPROPRIATELY
SCREEN. THANK YOU AND I HAVE
ONE MORE QUESTION VERY QUICKLY
YOU KNOW WE HAVE ANOTHER
COLLEAGUES THAT ARE WAITING TO
ANSWER. OUR TO ASK QUESTIONS
IS- CAN WE AND I WANT TO THANK-
MR KING AND MR TOASTIES.
INFORMATION AND THEIR- SEGMENT
ON THE PANEL WELL BUT I HAD A
QUESTION IF THERE ARE ANY OTHER
DIRECTIVES OR ANY OTHER
ALTERNATIVES OR SOCCER PLANNING
FOR HIGH RISK MEDICAL RELEASE
IN ADDITION TO THE ELDERLY-
PEARL ISSUE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE- LEAD ON IS THERE
ANYTHING ELSE. OTHER THAN JUST
SENDING THEM TO A DIFFERENT
FACILITY THAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED. I'M NOT AWARE OF
ANY OTHER RELEASE STRATEGIES
THAT ARE BEING PROPOSED OR
REVIEWED AT THIS TIME. AS I
SAID WE CONTINUE TO DO THE ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAY RELEASE
PROGRAM. FOR THAT ROLE IN ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS FULL SECOND
RELEASE. AND I KNOW WHO I'LL
SEE SEE SEE SEE OUR CCAC AS AND
I'LL LET DOCTOR BIG SPEAK TO.
WEAR CONTINUALLY EVALUATE OUR
PROCESSES AND DEVELOP AND
WESTRAC JEEZ WE CAN DO. TO TRY
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE WORKING
TO PROTECT OUR MOST VULNERABLE.
PATIENTS OF DOCTOR BACK. DR.
THANK YOU I WILL SAY THAT IN
ADDITION TO WHAT CONNIE SAID
WITH THE RECENT CHANGE IN THE
LAW THAT ALLOWS PATIENTS TO BE
CONSIDERED FOR COMPASSIONATE
RELEASE IF THEY HAVE A LIFE
EXPECTANCY OF TWELVE MONTHS OR
LESS INSTEAD OF SIX MONTHS OR
LESS THATWE ACTIVELY REACHED
OUT TO EVERY INSTITUTION TO
IDENTIFY PATIENTS WHO MAY IN
FACT BE ELIGIBLE FOR
COMPASSIONATE RELEASE AND OR
MEDICAL PAROLE AND THOSE ARE
ALL BEING FORWARDED FOR
CONSIDERATION OF REMAKES. THANK
IT AND ACTUALLY SIR GONZALEZ AT
YOU ALL I THOUGHT IN YOUR
REMARKS YOU ALSO WANT TO HAVE
MISTER KING AND- DOCTOR PATEL'S
THE ALSO. ADDRESS THAT QUESTION
OR NOT. NOT NECESSARILY UNLESS
THEY HAVE ANYTHING THAT WOULD
BE- THAT COULD BE ADDED TO THAT
BUT I THINK THAT- WAS A GREAT
ANSWER SO THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU CHARACTER. ARC THANK
YOU THANKS VERY MUCH- SO NEXT
UP WE HAVE CENTER SKINNER AND
THEY'LL BE FOLLOWED AGAIN BY
CABRILLO BRADFORD JACKSON AND
MORE LOCK SO- CENTER SKINNER.
THANKS SO MUCH I'M- SO IT JUST
HIT THE CDCR STAFF MS GIBSON
AND DR BECK I'M PLEASED TO HEAR
THAT CDCR IS LOOKING AT
RESTORING ACCESS TO- FAMILY AND
OTHER VISITATION THOUGH REMOTE
BY VIRTUALLY AS WE ARE DOING
HERE FOR MANY OF US- AND
LOOKING RE RE LOOKING AGAIN OF
PROGRAMMING SO THOSE GOOD
HOWEVER IT SEEMS TO ME RIGHT
NOW THAT THE MOST ESSENTIAL
THING IS TO GET THE VIRUS UNDER
CONTROL AND I WOULD POINTS TO
THOSE WHO. MAY BE- OBSERVING
THIS HEARING OR PARTICIPATING
IN THIS HEARING THAT CDC OURS
OWN WEBSITE HAS A TRACKER ON-
THAT SHOWS COULD BE CASES AND
COMPARES THOSE CODE CASES TO
THE NUMBER PER CAPITA WITHIN
OUR FACILITIES THE NUMBER PER
AND THEN THE NUMBER OF CASES IN
CALIFORNIA PER CAPITA IN THE
NUMBER OF CASES IN THE COUNTRY-
AND AS MR KING POINTED OUT
SINCE OUR HEARING IN JULY WHICH
WAS PROMPTED BY THE DISASTROUS
TRANSFERRED CHIU SANDPOINT
WHICH I'M LEAST A VERY
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF CASES IN
STATE COURT. AND UP TO THAT
POINT YES WE HAD CASES IN A FEW
FACILITIES BUT AND IF THE ANTI
VIRUS WAS DEFINITELY SPREADING
BUT. IT BECAME ALMOST- FIVE YOU
KNOW THE DISTRICT MASS. AT THE
POINT NOW CERTAIN SOME OF
MEASURE WERE TAKEN I DO NOT
MINIMIZE THE ACT HOWEVER WE ARE
NOW IN A SITUATION WHERE IN
THOSE FOUR MONTHS AS WAS
POINTED OUT. WHERE WE HAD THAT
HEARING THERE HAVE BEEN OVER
ELEVEN THOUSAND. NEW CASES. AND
IF WE LOOK JUST TODAY CLOSE TO
SIXTEEN HUNDRED NEW CASES SO
THAT WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY TWO CASES. PER ONE
THOUSAND INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS NOW LET'S COMPARE
THAT WE KNOW THERE'S A SURGEON
A REST OF THE STATE. HOWEVER
FOR THE STATE IT'S TWENTY SIX
CASES PER ONE THOUSAND AND THE
REST OF THE US WHICH IS WORST
IN CALIFORNIA IT'S THIRTY FOUR.
ONE EIGHTY TWO TO A THOUSAND
VERSUS THIRTY FOUR TO A
THOUSAND. THAT IS. IN A- I FEEL
AND I'M- NUMBER. SO WE NEED
MUCH BETTER CONTROL AND WHILE I
APPRECIATE THAT ARE WE HEARD
FROM THAT THERE'S- ATTENTION TO
THE MASKING FORSMAN. WE WERE
TOLD IN JULY. THAT THE MASK
PROTOCOL IS BEING ENFORCED AND
YET HERE TODAY WE HEAR THAT
EVEN IN HELLO CAN BAY THERE
WHAT YOU MENTION OVER TEN
INCIDENTS THAT OF LACK OF MAC
MAC NOT THAT THEY WERE ENFORCED
THE WORK BUT WHERE IT STAFF
WERE NOT COMPLYING. SO IF WE
NEED THAT MUCH TIME WE ARE
STILL HAVING THAT LEVEL OF
INCIDENTS OF NON COMPLIANCE ACT
WHEN WE KNOW THAT IT'S THE
EXTRA IT'S THE STAFF THAT ARE
BRINGING THE VIRUS IN AND I
DON'T SEE THAT TO BE CRUEL TO
STAFF. IS JUST THE REALITY THAT
IF YOU'RE- IN IF YOU ARE IN THE
CONGREGATE FACILITY AND NOT
GOING IN AND OUT YOU ARE NOT
BRINGING. THE VIRUS IN IT IS
ONLY DOES PEOPLE GOING IN AND
OUT SO I'M NOT TRYING TO. MAKE
I'M NOT TRYING TO CREATE A BALL
SIGNED STAFF RATHER JUST THE
FACT. SO I WANT TO HEAR FROM
BOTH MS GIBSON AND DR BECK. I'D
LIKE TO HAVE IT I AM NOT HAPPY
ABOUT THESE NUMBERS AND I WOULD
LIKE TO HEAR MORE ABOUT THE
ENFORCEMENT AND THEN I HAVE
THREE OTHER QUESTIONS. SO WIRD
DR PICKED ONE TAKE AT FIRST AND
THEN THE THIS GIPSON. I SHARE
YOUR FRUSTRATION SENATOR AND
THIS IS KIND OF PARTICULARLY
FRUSTRATING YEAR FOR ALL OF US
IN PUBLIC HEALTH I DON'T THINK
I'VE EVER SEEN BASIC SCIENCE
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES
POLITICIZED IN A WAY THAT
HAPPENED THIS YEAR. AND WHEN WE
HAVE SUCH AN EXTRAORDINARY
PERCENTAGE OF OUR POPULATION
TAKING THEIR LEAD FROM ELECTED
FOLKS TO SAY THAT BASICALLY THE
VIRUSES A HOAX AND- MASKS MAKE
YOU SICK. ANDERSON INFRINGEMENT
ON YOUR PERSONAL LIBERTIES IT'S
ONLY MADE OUR JOB ALL THE MORE
DIFFICULT THAT BEING SAID. IT'S
AN EXPECTATION OF ALL OF OUR
EMPLOYEES THAT THEY WILL WEAR
THEM. SECRETARY ALISON AND-
RECEIVER MR KELSO ME THAT
EXQUISITELY CLEAR AND AS CONNIE
GIBSON DIRECTOR GIBSON JUST
POINTED OUT. WE ARE GETTING
EVEN MORE ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN
ENSURING THAT EMPLOYEES WHO
CHOOSE TO NOT FOLLOW THAT
DIRECTIVE WILL EXPERIENCE
PROGRESSIVE DISCIPLINE. THE
OTHER FACTOR THAT WE FOUND
THROUGH OUR TOURISM FACILITIES
AS WHAT WASBEING USED AS FACE
COVERINGS VARIED SIGNIFICANTLY
ALL OVER THE STATE. AND WE SAW
THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE
IN A PROBLEM. PEOPLE WEARING
BANDANNAS AND GATORS AND MASKS
WITH VALVES AND ALL TYPES OF
THINGS THAT ARE NOT REALLY
GOING TO ACHIEVE OUR GOAL AND
SO RECENTLY THE DECISION WAS
MADE AND IS BEING IMPLEMENTED
THAT ALL OF OUR EMPLOYEES WILL
BE REQUIRED TO WEAR. THIS TYPE
OF. COVERAGE IT'S MORE. IT'S
STANDARD WILL BE MUCH EASIER
AUDIT OUR STAFF AS WE ARE IN.
FROM SURE THAT EVERYBODY
WEARING THEM THEY'LL BE
PROVIDED FREE OF CHARGE TO
EMPLOYEES. AND I THINK BY DOING
SO WE'RE GOING TO ACHIEVE. A
BETTER COMPLIANCE THE LAST
THING I WOULD SAY IS. BEING
DISTRIBUTED BUT IT WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED TO EVERY EMPLOYEE
TO PER SHIFT AS THIS ROLLS OUT.
AND THE LAST THING I WOULD
WORRY AS IT ROLLS OUT WHEN. I
BELIEVE THE NINE MEMBERS BEING
SIGNED THIS WEEK- THERE WAS A
LOT THAT WENT INTO MAKING SURE
WE HAVE ADEQUATE SUPPLY THAT WE
CAN HAVE HIM AVAILABLE AT EVERY
INSTITUTION. BEING SIGNED THIS
IT COULD STILL BE TWO WEEKS
BEFORE STAFF RECEIVE THE MASKS.
I DON'T BELIEVE SO I'LL DEFER
TO CONNIE FOR THE SPECIFICS ON
THE ROLL OUT. YOU KNOW ONCE THE
MEMO IS SIGN THAT WOULD BE THE
EXPECTATION THAT WE IMPLEMENT A
MEET ELAINE SO WE'VE ALREADY
BEEN SHIPPING A SURGICAL MASKS
OF SUPPLIES TO THE PRISONS
BECAUSE WE WERE PREPARING FOR
THAT SO. THEY WILL BE READY TO
GO ONCE THE MEMORANDUM IS THE
SOFTEST SIGNED AND DISTRIBUTED.
RIGHT YOU CAN- POLITICIAN
CONTINUE. OWNER NO PROBLEM
SENATOR AND I THINK THE ONLY
LAST THING I WOULD SAY IS AS
IMPORTANT AS THE SPACE
COVERINGS ARE IT'S NOT GOING TO
BE. PERFECT IT'S ONLY ONE OF
MANY THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DO.
AND THERE IS THIS NTURAL
TENSION BETWEEN TRYING TO MAKE
AVAILABLE TO OUR ALL OF OUR
PATIENTS ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT. ARE VALUABLE IN THE
SYSTEM AND IN TERMS OF VISITORS
HERE DURING ARTS PROJECT
PROJECTS IN EDUCATION AND-
GARDEN PROJECTS IN THE DARK
PROGRAM IN THEATER IN WRITING
ALL THOSE OTHER VALUABLE
THINGS. ALL OF WHICH ARE
ACCOMPANIED BY RISKS WOMEN'S
VOLUNTEERS ARE COMING INTO THE
INSTITUTION. SO WE'RE TRYING TO
STRIKE THAT BALANCE BETWEEN
KEEPING OUR PATIENTS SAFE AND
KEEPING THEM SO RESTRICTED.
THAT THEIR QUALITY. OF LIFE IS
EVEN FURTHER MINIMIZE. THANK
YOU I- BY. I DON'T WANT TO SAY
WELL. I'M GLAD THAT THERE WILL
BE MASKS DISTRIBUTED I. IT'S
NEVER TOO LATE BUT IT IS RATHER
LATE AND ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
NUMBER OF CASES WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW PER THOUSAND SO I JUST.
IT'S DISAPPOINTING I WISH IT
HAD HAPPENED EARLIER- THE NEXT
QUESTION I HAVE IS THAT THIS IS
BACK TO THIS ISSUE OF REVIEW OF
THE MATTER MEDICALLY VULNERABLE
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT.
CITIES HERE SELF IDENTIFIED
SOME FORTY FOUR THOUSAND AND I
AM MAY HAVE THAT NUMBER OF BUT
IT WAS AND IT WAS IN A LARGE
THOUSANDS TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE DETERMINED TO BE MEDICALLY
VULNERABLE AND A LARGE SUBSET
OF DOWN WERE ALSO DETERMINED TO
BE. POTENTIALLY LOW RISK FOR
VIOLENCE USING A RISK
ASSESSMENT TOOL THAT CDC OUR
HOUSE BUT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT ONCE THE REVIEW WAS
COMPLETED ONLY FORTY FOUR WE'RE
GIVING CONSIDERATION FOR
RELEASE NOW WHY AT THE POINT
WHERE WE HAVE THIS LEVEL OF
INFECTION RATE. WOULD WE STILL
RETAIN. SUCH A SICK. NUMBER OF
MEDICALLY VULNERABLE.
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS- THAT
HAVE LOW RISK FOR VIOLENCE OR
RECIDIVISM. AND WE HAVE MUCH
MORE THAN JUST THE
COMPASSIONATE AND MEDICALLY
PAROLE THINGS AT OUR AT OUR
DISPOSAL THERE IS ELEVEN
SEVENTY D. THERE'S THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF OTHER
TOOLS THAT CDC OUR HOUSE AT ITS
DISPOSAL. SO WHAT I WANT TO
KNOW IS WHAT IS CDC ARE DOING
TO RE LOOK AT THIS POPULATION
OF MEDICALLY VULNERABLE LOW
RISK LOW RISK FOR RECIDIVISM IN
VIOLENCE INDIVIDUALS. DID YOU
WANT TO DIRECT A QUESTION TO.
EITHEREITHER CCAR'S OFFICIAL
IN THAT FEELS COMPLETELY
ARTISTIC ON THE DOCTOR DID YOU
WANNA TAKE THAT ON FIRST. IT'S
REALLY MORE A QUESTION I THINK
FOR OUR CDC ARE COLLEAGUES IN
TERMS OF WHO IS EVENTUALLY
RELEASED WE ARE EVALUATING
PATIENTS WHO WE BELIEVE MEET
THOSE CRITERIA IDENTIFYING THEM
FROM A MEDICAL STANDPOINT. OKAY
PERHAPS MISS GIBSON DIRECTOR
GIBSON. SO I KNOW WE HAD-
EARLIER LATE FALL EARLY FALL WE
HAD ABOUT SIXTY HUNDRED SIXTY
TWO HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS WHO
WERE BEING SCREENED BY OUR-
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS AS
RELATE TO. A MEDICALLY
VULNERABLE POPULATION AND I'M
NOT SURE OF THE NUMBERS THAT
WERE RELEASED I WOULD HAVE TO
GET THAT INFORMATION OFF OF
THOSE REVIEWS. BUT THE BOARD
GET A REVIEW OF THOSE CASES AND
THEN PRESIDENT TO THE
SECRETARY. AND I KNOW- I DON'T
KNOW WHAT PERCENTAGE WHAT WAS
THE- FINAL NUMBER OF WHO WAS
RELEASED. AND HOW MANY OF THOSE
FOR LOW RISK OFFENDERS- VERSUS
MODERATE OR HIGH I WOULD HAVE
TO GET SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO BE ABLE TO
REALLY ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
SENATOR I'M SORRY. OKAY PERHAPS
WE I CAN SEND TO YOU IN WRITING
RIGHT POLITIES TO BE A TWO LAST
REMAINING QUESTIONS- WE HAVE
THIS RECENT- JUDICIAL RULING TO
THAT ORDERED RELEASES FROM SAN
QUENTIN WE KNOW THAT IT'S BEING
CHALLENGED BUT- THE- BOTH THE
JUDGE AND THE PLAINTIFFS AND
ATTORNEYS HAVE ARGUED THAT THE
ONLY WAY TO MANAGE THIS SPREAD
AT SAN QUENTIN IS FOR RELEASE I
WANT AND SINCE WE ARE NOW
CHALLENGING THAT MEANING THE
STATE IS I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR
FROM CDC ARE AS TO WHAT YOUR
SENSES IS WHAT IS THE STATE
WAY. TO TRANSFER INMATES UP
FROM SAN QUITE YET WE IS THERE-
GIVEN. THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS
THERE. WHAT IS THE- ASSURED
SAFE WAY TO DO ANY TRANSFERS.
THANK YOU SENATOR SO AS DOCTOR
BIG SPOKE EARLIER AS IT RELATES
TO ARCH TRANSFER OF PROCESSES
WE PUT IN PLACE ENSURING THAT
OFFENDERS ARE TRANSFERRED ARE
TESTED REQUIRED TíNH. AT
TESTED BEFORE THEY'RE RELEASED
OFF A QUARANTINE TRANSFERRED.
WITHIN NINETY FIVE ON THE
TRANSPORTATION VEHICLES IN
MASON STOP AS WELL AS WHEN THEY
ARRIVE AT THE NEW INSTITUTION
THEIR OFFER COBRA TESTING AGAIN
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
ORANGE LINE AND BONDED TO.
RIGHT I MEAN IT DOESN'T UP I'M
SORRY YOU INDICATED OXFORD
TESTING SO IS THAT THAT WE
CANNOT REQUIRE IT. I DON'T
BELIEVE WE ARE FORCING ME TO
CALL THAT ASK SO I'LL DEFER TO
DOCTOR BACK. IS THAT CORRECT DR
BECK OKAY. CORRECT WE'RE NOT
ACTUALLY FORCIBLY TESTING BUT
FOR THOSE PATIENTS WHO DON'T
KNOW. THEIR CORNERS WE NEED. IS
THAT BECAUSE WE LEAGUE. SAY
AGAIN YES SIR WE LEGALLY ARE
PROHIBITED. THREE THREE WE
WOULD HAVE TO GET A COURT ORDER
TO FORCE TEST THEM BUT IT'S NOT
REQUIRED SO WE HAVE WE WILL
EITHER TEST THEM AND IF THEY
DON'T THEN THEIR QUARANTINE IS
PROLONGED BUT WE DO NOT REDUCE
THEM OUT IF THEY'RE UNSAFE I
WOULD SAY. THAT THE PATIENTS AT
SAN QUENTIN ARE PROBABLY AT
THIS TIME AMONG THE SAFEST TO
TRANSFER BECAUSE MANY OF THEM
HAVE HAD COVETED AND THERE AT
LEAST FOR NOW NOT SUSCEPTIBLE
TO BEING RE INFECTED. IT SEEMS
THAT THEY'VE NOT HAD CODED THAT
WITHOUT THE TESTING. IT'S HARD
TO. IT WOULD BE HARD TO ASSURE
A SAFE. TRANSFER BUT I SUPPOSE
WITH THE QUARANTINE BUT WE'D
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
QUARANTINE. IN AN AREA WHERE
IT'S REALLY SEGREGATED OR ANY
FORCE MY UNDERSTANDING IS PART
OF THE PROBLEM IT STANDPOINT
WAS. WE DIDN'T HAVE AS MUCH
ACCESS TO AREAS IN STANDPOINT
WHERE WE COULD ACHIEVE THAT.
YOU'RE RIGHT SENATOR AND THAT'S
PART OF THE PROCESS THAT WE
WENT HROUGH WITH OUR- OUTSIDE
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT
EVERY SINGLE PRISON HAS CELL
BASED. HOUSING FOR RECEPTION
QUARANTINE AND THE FEW THAT
THEIR PHYSICAL PLANT DOESN'T
ALLOW THAT WE'VE MADE OTHER
ARRANGEMENTS. BUT THAT
QUARANTINE AND TESTING ON THE
RECEIVING END IS CRITICAL. MY
LAST QUESTION THIS IS AROUND
JUVENILE SO HOPEFULLY-
HOPEFULLY COMMUNITIES GIPSON
ARE YOU DOCTOR BIG YOU'LL HAVE
THE ANSWER TO THIS BUT I
WONDERED IF THIS CDC ARE-
TRACKER DOES NOT SHOW THE
NUMBER OF CASES WITHIN OUR DOJ
AND SO I WONDERED WHAT IS- WHAT
ARE WE DOING IN TERMS OF
TRACKING THE YOUTH THEY'RE BOTH
ON TESTING AND CODE CASES. AND
IF THE IF THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
IS BEING- IF HE'S IF THEY'RE
RECEIVING THESE REPORTS. SINCE
IT'S NOT ON A PUBLIC WEBSITE.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHY IT'S NOT ON
THE PUBLIC WEBSITES I DO
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT BUT I SHOWED
AS OF THIS MORNING WHEN I. J.
J. CURRENTLY HAS IS SHOWING NO
CURRENT GOAL THAT CASE AS- BUT
I CAN'T SPEAK TO WHY IT'S NOT
ON THE PUBLIC FACING AND I
WOULD THINK THAT INFORMATION IS
SHARED WITH THE- EXAMPLES. HAVE
THERE BEEN ANY JUVENILE DEATHS
IN APOLOGIES I HAD NOT TRIED TO
LOOK AT THAT I DIDN'T KNOW HAVE
THERE BEEN ANY YET. RELATED TO
KOBE. THE DOCUMENTS I HAVE TO
GO AHEAD AFTER THE- NO I WASN'T
SPEAKING BUT CENTER MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
ANSWER IS NO. YES I CHAU NINE
RIGHT THANK YOU THANKS. THANK
YOU CENTER SKINNER YOU CAN BE
QUESTIONS ALRIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER SKINNER- NEXT UP IS
SENATOR CAPPIELLO- WELCOME. COM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR- FIRST LET ME THINK THAT
PANEL THE ENTIRE PANEL FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY IT'S- VERY-INFORMATIVE AND HELPFUL- I'VE
HAD EIGHTY- NUMBER OF INMATE.
COMPLAINTS IN REGARDS TO DOUBLE
THEIR INABILITY TO GET TESTED
IF THEY IF THEY WANT TO GET
TESTED- THE LACK OF- AND THEN
ONCE ILL LIMITED SERVICES IN
TERMS OF CARE MEDICAL CARE AND-
ATTENTION- AT FOR IN TERMS OF-
AT IT. OF FEELING YOUNG AND NOT
NOT BEING ABLE TO ACCESS
SERVICES- AND THEN IN ADDITION
THAT FAILURE TO FOLLOW THE
PROTOCOL IN PARTICULAR MASK AND
JUST SOCIAL DISTANCING- BY THE-
THE CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS AND
OTHER PEOPLE THAT- DIRECT THEM.
IN THE PRESENT SO I JUST WANT
TO PUT THAT OUT THERE BECAUSE-
I I'VE HEARD ABOUT THESE ISSUES
AND I'M HOPING THAT THEY'RE
GETTING ADDRESSED AND RECOGNIZE
THAT IN- I HAVE A NUMBER OF
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES IN MY
DISTRICT AND IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND ALSO IN THE SALINAS
VALLEY. AND IN MOST OF THOSE
THE COUNTIES IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THE COUNTIES ARE
REFUSING TO RECOGNIZE THE MASK
ORDERS- AND THEY'RE DOING IT
PUBLICLY- THROUGH THEIR BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS OR THEIR
SHERIFF'S. AND ENCOURAGING
BUSINESSES NOT TO CLOSE AND NOT
TO WEAR MASKS SO WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THIS IN THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE FIND AND SO
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT- THAT- THAT INDIVIDUALS
GET CONSEQUENCES AT WORK IF
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO FOLLOW THE
DIRECTIVES AND SO I WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THAT I SEE THAT- BUT
I YESTERDAY FOUND OUT THAT
THERE IS A HUNGER STRIKE. IN
THAT CORPORATE FACILITY AND
THAT THE STRIKERS ARE ASKING
FOR COULD BE PROTOCOL SUPPORT
AND SO I WAS WONDERING IF MAYBE
DIRECTOR GIPSON YOU COULD YOU
COULD DOES IT SPEAK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THAT HUNGER STRIKE
AND CONCERNED- BLASTING WE NEED
OR- EVEN SICKER INMATES AND IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT THEIR REQUESTS
ARE ARE. FAIRLY REASONABLE- SO
I WONDER IF YOU CAN YOU CAN
ADDRESS. THAT DIRECTOR GIPSON.
YEAH AT THE- YOU AS I'M NOT
AWARE OF A HUNGER STRIKE A
CHORD SO I NEED TO. UP ON THAT
I KNOW WE WILL INTO. IN THE
HUNGER STRIKES BUT IT'S NOT
LIKE YOU STAND THIS IS MORE
THAN. ONE IT MAY POTENTIALLY
WHO'S PARTICIPATING ON THE
HUNGER STRIKE FOR THE SAME
REASON. SO I'M NOT AWARE OF
THAT I NEED TO FOLLOW UP AND I
CAN DEFINITELY GET BACK WITH
YOU. THAT WOULD BE GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT'S ALL I
HAVE- MISTER CHAIR OKAY THANK
YOU CENTER COVERDALE. NEXT UP
THE CENTER BRADFORD. WELCOME.
HELLO I CAN'T HEAR MUSIC UP
THERE WE GO GOOD. THANK YOU AS
A SENATOR AND FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP HERE AND ALL MY
CULTURE PARTICIPATED ALL MY
QUESTIONS CALLER FALL ALONG THE
LINES- THAT A PARDON REYES AS
RELATES TO. P. P. ARE AMONG
STAFF- I'VE BEEN CONTACTED AS
WELL AS SHOCKED ASSEMBLY CHEER
A PUBLIC SAFETY REGGIE JONES
SAWYER EARLIER THIS SUMMER
ABOUT. THE LACK OF ADEQUATE
EQUIPMENT FOR EMPLOYEES THERE
AND WE SEEM TO BELIEVE THAT
THAT STILL EXISTS TODAY- BUT
I'VE HEARD WHAT- DIRECTOR
GIPSON STATED THAT OUR
EQUIPMENT HAS BEEN. BEING
PROVIDED BUT I ALSO HEARD
THERE'S A CHANGE OF RACISM AND-
IMPLICIT BIASES I GUESS AS IT
RELATES TO THE ROLE OF THE JUST
QUIT MAN WHO'S BEING- I GUESS-
DISCIPLINE FOR EITHER WEARING
OR NOT WEARING IT AND THINGS
ALONG THOSE NAY- ALLIANCE. ALSO
I'M CURIOUS ON WHAT IS THE
POPULATION WHAT'S THAT NUMBER
OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
FIFTY YEARS OR OLDER WHO HAVE
DONE. SERVED AT LEAST TWENTY
YEARS. WOULD BE OLDER FOR
ELDERLY PEROT I THAT'S SINCE ON
WHAT KIND OF POP. WE'RE DEALING
WITH HERE AND UNDERSTANDING HOW
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND WHY WE
CAN'T BE A LITTLE BIT MORE MORE
RESPONSIVE AND NOT. GETTING
SOME OF THESE FOLKS HOME AND I
GETTING A MOTHER'S RISK FACTOR
THAT CURRENTLY EXISTS RIGHT NOW.
AND MY AND MY LOOK MY LAST
QUESTION I WILL ROLL IT ALL IN
ONE- ALSO WHAT IS SHE SHE ARE
DOING AND WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH. AND
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AND
THE PHOTO. AGENCIES AND
PREPARING FOR THE BACKS-
VACCINE ROLLOUT. THAT DIRECTOR
GIVES A BEGIN AND THEN WE HAVE
TO TALK- THERE'S UP. YES A
SENATOR FOR THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE FIFTY AND
OVER WHO WILL QUALIFY FOR
ELDERLY PAROLE I WILL NEED TO
GET YOU THAT INFORMATION I
DON'T HAVE THAT READILY
AVAILABLE. I CAN DEFINITELY
SUPPLY THAT TO YOU. AS IT
RELATES TO THE APPROPRIATENESS
OF THE P. AND THEIR
AVAILABILITY OF PP. IN THE
BEGINNING OF THIS PANDEMIC GAS.
EVERYWHERE PEOPLE WERE
EXPERIENCING A SHORTAGE OF P.
B. S. SO THAT WE S. C. C. R. C.
C. H. U. S. BUT THERE ARE
EMPLOYERS AND- ACTIVATING OR
DEPARTMENTAL OPERATIONS CENTER
WHICH HAS THE- OVERSIGHT TO
ORDER OR INQUIRE PP BAR STAFF-
LOOKING AT THE LEVELS OF THE
PRISONS HAVE SO THAT THEY-
REQUEST. UP WELL THAT'S NOT A
BIG KNOWS DIFFERENTLY- THE
SUPPLY OF PPD WITHIN OUR SYSTEM
AS IT RELATES TO IN NINETY FIVE
GLOVES MASKS. ANIL'S
APPROPRIATE SUPPLIES FOR OUR
STOP- SEEMS TO BE AN ISSUE
RIGHT NOW WE SEEM TO BE ABLE TO
GET WHAT WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
OUR STAFF GET IN AND IS PART OF
THE CONVERSATION WE HAVE WITH
INSTITUTIONS. IN PARTICULAR
WHAT WE DO OUR JOINT CALL CCAC
SNCC ARE. PRESENT IN THEIR
EXECUTIVE TEAMS WHO MAY BE
EXPERIENCED AN OUTBREAK THAT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS WE TALK TO
THEM ABOUT IS. THERE PP SUPPLY
AND DO THEY HAVE ENOUGH TO DO
WE HAVE BOTH IN THE RIGHT TYPE
OF PP AND WE PUT OUT THE P.
GUIDANCE. BUT IF YOU'RE WORKING
IN A QUARANTINE BUILD IN
ISOLATION BUILDING YOU'RE IN IN
NINETY FIVE. OF THE STAFF ARE
WHO WERE BORN IN AND OUT OF
THOSE BUILDINGS. AND SO I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THAT'S TO BE.
ISSUE ANY LONGER BECAUSE WE
ARE. DEFINITELY HAVE PLENTY OF
SUPPLY AND TO OUR DEPARTMENT
OPERATIONS CENTER WE ARE VERY.
RESPONSIVE TO THE PRISON AND
THEIR NEEDS. AS IT RELATES TO
THE VACCINE IN OUR PREPARATION
WE ARE. IN JOIN. WITH THIS CD
P. H. AND- I IDENTIFY- THE
PRIORITY FOR OUR STAFF TO BE
TESTED I KNOW DOCTOR BIG WILL
SPEAK ABOUT THIS VACCINATIONS
FOR THE INMATES WHAT WE ARE
DOING- EVERY DEAL OVER
CLASSIFICATIONS OF OUR STAFF TO
ENGAGE WITH THE POPULATION THE
MILES. SAID WE CAN COME UP WITH
SOME NUMBERS AS TO WHETHER ITS
OFFICERS SERGEANTS NURSES WHO
MATTER I'M THE NUMBER OF FOLKS
THAT WE WOULD NEED AND THEN
PRIORITIZE OF SPOKES. FOR THE
RECEPTIONS ARE TO BE OFFERED
THE VACCINATION WHEN IT'S
READY- THANK YOU BIG DO YOU
WANNA TALK ABOUT THE INMATES OR
ANYTHING. YOU'RE THE ONLY THING
I WOULD ADD IS THAT EARLY ON IN
FEBRUARY MARCH WHEN ACQUISITION
OF PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT WAS SKETCHY FOR
EVERYBODY. BERMAN ARE READ. TO
SOME OF THE I. A. K. TO BIRD.
FACE COVERINGS FOR BOTH OUR
EMPLOYEES AND FOR OUR INMATES.
AND DELIVERED THEM TO EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THEM. SO EVERYONE
WAS PROVIDED FACE COVERINGS
VERY EARLY ON. AND THEY ALSO
MANUFACTURED. ARE ALCOHOL BASED
HAND RUB SO THAT PEOPLE COULD
DO DISINFECTION BACK IN THE
DAYS WHEN ALL OF THE STORE
SHELVES WERE EMPTY. AS FAR AS
THE VACCINE PREPAREDNESS WE'VE
BEEN MEETING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH SINCE JULY. THEIR WEEKLY
MEETINGS ARE ONGOING NOW WE'RE
PREPARING EXTENSIVELY WITH THEM
AND- IN FACT THIS WEEK CARE
SUBMITTING PAPERWORK THAT WILL
ENSURE THAT WERE IN THE QUEUE.
FOR WHATEVER OUR SUPPLIES
PROVIDED TO CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU A SEPARATE FOR DO YOU HAVE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS- ON THE
ISSUE OF RACE THAT I'D HEARD
FROM SOME OF THE EMPLOYEES IT
IS. IS THERE ANY TENSION THERE
AS TO WHO GETS IT- WHO'S BEING
DISCIPLINED EVEN AS IT RELATES
TO THE AND MAKES THEM SO THOSE
ARE REYES SPLIT FACTOR AND ANY
OF THOSE ARE YOU AWARE OF THAT
BUT- IT HAS BEEN. BROUGHT TO
BOTH MYSELF AND SOME WOMEN ON
JONES SAWYER SAID TENSION THAT
THEY FILL THEIR SOME. BIASES
ARE. I HAVE NOT HEARD THAT
SENATOR AND- WILL DEFINITELY IF
YOU COULD SHARE- IF THERE'S
PARTICULAR INSTITUTIONS WHERE
YOUR HAND THAT THAT'S OUR
PROBLEM- PPVS ARE AVAILABLE
AND- SUPPLIES ARE AVAILABLE
BASED ON- THE STAFF NEEDS OTHER
APPROPRIATE PP AT THEIR WORK IN
A PARKING SPACE. AND ISOLATION
SPACE IT SURE THAT THE
POPULATION HAVE WHAT THEY HAVE.
SO IT- I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO
LOOK INTO THAT CONCERN BECAUSE
NO I'M NOT AWARE OF AND HAVE
NOT HEARD THAT. OKAY THANK YOU.
WE JUST HAD ALTHOUGH. DEAR
WHERE OF IT. AND THAT HER STAFF
FOR BEING SENSITIVE THOSE
ISSUES. IT'S AN ISSUE THAT'S
BEEN RAISED TO ME ON MORE THAN
ONE OCCASION SHOW AND THAT'S
THE ONLY REASON I RAISE IT NOW.
FROM SOME YOUR MEDICAL STAFF
WHO RAISED THAT ISSUE TO ME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS CENTER BRADFORD
I'M FINE THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD- NEXT UP IS
SENATOR JACKSON. WELCOME. OKAY
MY AND MUTED NOW GREAT ALL
RIGHT- I APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION AYE AYE AYE SURE
SOME OF THE FRUSTRATION- THAT
JOB IT'S TAKEN SO LONG TO KIND
OF GET OUR ACT TOGETHER HERE-
THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE-
RECALCITRANT STAFF THEY DON'T
WANT TO WEAR THEIR MASKS I
DON'T WANT TO BE TESTED. YOU
KNOW I'VE GOT A- THE COUSIN WHO
WORKS IN A SENIOR FACILITY I
AND IF HE DOESN'T GET TESTED
REGULARLY HE DOESN'T GET TO GO
TO WORK. HE DOESN'T GET PAID.
I'M I'M KIND OF CURIOUS AS TO
WHY THAT KIND OF- YOU KNOW.
STRONGER PERSPECTIVE STRONGER
IMPLEMENTATION OF BARI IS THE
YOUNG PERSON'S HASN'T HASN'T
BEEN EFFECTUATED I MEAN THE
NOTION THAT A GUARD TO US I
DON'T WANT TO GET TESTED. ARE
COMING IN TO WORK OR I DON'T
WANT TO WEAR MY MASK AND THEY
AND THEY CAN DO THAT. I GIVEN
THAT WE KNOW THAT A LOT OF THE-
VIRUS COMES IN THROUGH STAFF
AND IN PEOPLE FROM THE OUTSIDE
I WONDER IF- WAS GIPSON YOU
COULD SHARE WITH US WHY THERE
HASN'T BEEN A- A STRONGER-
INCENTIVE TO GET COMPLIANCE
FROM LIVE FROM THE STAFF.
SENATORS SO FOR AS IT RELATES
TO A MASS WARY OF OUR STAFF
COME IN AND THEY SAY THEY ARE
REFUSING TO DON THEIR MASKS.
AND THEY'RE DENIED ENTRY. AND
IF THEY ARE- ALLEGED TO HAVE
SOME TYPE OF RESULT COMBINATION
REQUEST THEY WILL WORK THROUGH
A SEPARATE PROCESS THROUGH THAT
PIECE BUT THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED
ENTRY AND AS IT RELATES TO THE
STAFF WHO ARE REFUSING TO TASK
I KNOW ARE HARD THIRTIES ARE
DEALING WITH THAT THE DEPRESSED
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS AND I
AGREE WITH YOU I AM VERY
CONCERNED WILL STOP USED TO
TEST WHEN WE KNOW THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE THE ENVIRONMENT
SAFER ALL AND WE CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS THAT BEHAVIOR AND HOLD
OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE. WELL.
THE LEGISLATURE TO ASSIST YOU
IN MAKING SURE THAT IF THEY ARE
IN FACT LEGITIMATE STEPS- THEY
SHOULD BE TAKEN- CERTAINLY
PROCESS YOU KNOW GOING FORWARD
IF WE DIDN'T DO THEM EARLIER ON
BUT WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF
ANOTHER A HUGE SPIKE AND
PERHAPS IF WE CAN SAVE SOME
LIVES WELL THAT'S A GOOD THING
SO IS MISTER KING SO ON THIS
THING. YEAH SAY THAT THIS. STEP
REALLY THOSE MOST RIVER. WE'VE
HEARD FROM FROM DOZENS IF NOT
WHO OF PEOPLE WITH SALAS INTO
PLAN AND ALL. FAMILIES BY
SUPPORT EVERY IN BACK SUS- A
ANY PLANNED DOESN'T ADDRESS
DRUM WE DO THE- BY. CAPACITY
FOR ONE HUNDRED AND PERCENT
WORKER IS. 52% HEALTH OFFICIALS
ARE CALL FOR- IS GOING TO BE
PROBLEM- EXANE. WE KNOW THEY'VE
BEEN ISSUED HAND SANITIZER ONE
TIME SINCE THE- SINCE THE
PROGRAM WENT ON MODIFY PROGRAM.
MODIFIED PROGRAM BACK IN MARCH-
PEOPLE ARE ASKING WHEN THEY
WILL BE ISSUED ON HAND
SANITIZER AND IN FACT A LOCAL
CELEBRITY DONATED A THOUSAND
GALLONS TO SAN QUENTIN. WHICH
TO THE BEST OF OUR KNOWLEDGE IS
STILL SITTING IN A WAREHOUSE
WAITING ON DISTRIBUTION- WE-
ALSO- A LOT OF PEOPLE OTHER DAY
AT THE MAJORITY OF PRISONS ARE
THERE BEING ALLOWED OUT OF
THEIR SAILS. AND GIVEN THE
CHOICE TO EITHER GO MAKE A
PHONE CALL GO TO THE ER OR GO
GET A SHOWER- YOUR TIME SHOULD
BE MUCH MORE AVAILABLE BECAUSE
YOU CAN DISTANCE MORE IN THE
FRESH AIR AND THE VIRUS DOES
NOT SPREAD AS WELL- AND EVEN
THOUGH THEY'RE NOT BEING
ALLOWED A LOT OF ACCESS TO
FRESH AIR. THEY ARE STILL BEING
CALLED A POINT TO GO WORKING IN
CLOSE PROXIMITY WITH- FREE
STAFF WERE COMING INTO WORK IN
LIKE THE KITCHEN AND OTHER
ESSENTIAL AREAS. SO A REDUCTION
IN THAT TYPE OF- COERCION
COUPLED WITH MORE- ABILITY TO
GO OUT IN THE OPEN AIR AND IN
FREE SPACE. ALL LAYERED ON TOP
OF DRAMATICALLY REDUCING THE
POPULATION WHAT PEOPLE ARE
ASKING. OKAY AND- THE DIRECTOR
GIPSON DO YOU WANT TO FOLLOW UP
ON THAT AND DISCUSS- WHAT ARE
SOME THE THINGS THAT THE MISTER
KING BROUGHT UP THE- TEACHERS
EITHER PURSUING OR LOOKING FOR
SOMETHING- YES I CAN DO THAT.
I'M AS IT RELATES TO THE
RELEASE OF THE MEDICALLY
BARBARA I THINK DR BIGGS TALKED
ABOUT CCA'S YES AND UPPERS. AND
HAVE BEEN THERE PROVIDE I DON'T
THOSE. WHO MAY BE ELIGIBLE FOR.
MEDICAL L. PEROT. AND LOOK AND
IS LOOKING AT THOSE CASES
CLOSELY. SO I THINK THERE IS
SOME MOVEMENT THERE A CCAC S.
CONTINUES TO LOOK AT THOSE TYPE
OF CASES THEY MAY QUALIFY FOR
MEDICALLY. I MEAN ELDERLY
PAROLE. AS WELL AS OR MEDICALLY
PAROLE. I'M SORRY. WHAT THE-
YES. ADDITION I AM SUPER TO
HEAR AND I WOULD. DO CHECK SENT
PLAN BECAUSE WE HAVE. THE OF
HAND SANITIZER. DISINFECTING
CLANS. BUT THE TO BE ABLE TO
PLAYED SO THAT IS CONCERNED THE
MEETING- YOU SAY THAT THE MA
STILL DON'T HAVE I WILL TELL
FOLLOW ON THAT BE. BECAUSE IS
OUT THERE IN THE DAY WILL
FLOORS FOR THE POPPY. AND WE
HAVE PLENTY DR SAID OF THESE P.
AT CALPE AYE DID IN THE FOR AS
WHEN IT WAS SUCH SHORT OF HAS.
WAS ACE TO MAY REPORT AND SO I
WILL FOLLOW UP THAT ABOUT SIX.
AND ASK FOR MORE YARD. I THINK
IT GOES BACK TO WHAT ARCHITECT
ABOUT- EARLIER ABOUT HOW DO WE-
ENSURING THAT WE GET MORE.
PROGRAM ACTIVE WHILE STILL
MAKING SURE THAT THE
ENVIRONMENT IS SAY AND SO WERE
ASKED TO TRY TO MITIGATE THE
SPREAD OF COBIT ONE THE THINGS
WE INTO PLAY WAS THAT EACH
HOUSING UNIT HAD A PROGRAM WITH
THE SOUTH. IN ORDER TO TRY. TO
WE DO. THE CROSS. OPPORTUNE
IMPACT. ONE HOUSING UNIT TO THE-
AS SO AND THEN. TO OUT HOW DO
YOU. WORK TO ENSURE AS MANY OF
THE POP AS MUCH OF THE POP. HAS
THE UPPER. FOR YOUR ACTIVELY.
AND I KNOW AS A TWO. PRO
THROUGH THEY'D OF THE RE
OPENING PLAN TO GET THE- BASE
TO. THEIR ABLE PLACE THREE
THEY'RE ABLE TO MAKE YOU KNOW
BRING OUT MORE THAN ONE HOUSING
UNIT AT A TIME TWO YARD. BUT
IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS WE'RE
VERY MINDFUL FOR BIG MINDFUL.
OF TRYING TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
GET SOME FRESH AIR GETS OUT OF
JAIL TIME. IT'S JUST HOW DO WE-
YOU KNOW WE DON'T WE ARE
NOWHERE NEAR WHERE WE ARE
PRETTY COLD WILL YOU MAY HAVE
TO REBUILD. ON OF THIS ALL GO
TO YORK. YOU'VE GOT TO BE ABLE
TO CREATE SPACE ON THE YARD
HAVE THE PHYSICAL DISTANCE
THEME. AND PRESS MITIGATE THE
SPREAD OF THE VIRUS SO WE
REALLY REDUCE THE NUMBERS OUT
ON THE YARD. TRY TO BE STATE
AND IS HOW DO WE THAT. TO A
THAT PAGE AND INMATES HAVE THE
ABILITY TO. GET SOME GUARD TIME.
BUT ALSO DO IT IN A SAFE MANNER.
SO YOU MENTIONED. THANK YOU YOU
MENTIONED. DOING DIDN'T SAY. SO
THAT NOT A- OUT THERE AT THE
SAME TIME. WHAT ABOUT THE NEW.
OF OR- CREATE MANY PRISON TO
KEEP TO CAN. THE WHY- CREATING
OUR- SUB. OF SMALL FIRMS. IS
THAT SOME. THAT YOU HAVE CAN
SEE. AN UNDERTAKER- AND IF NOT
WHY NOT. SO I'M NOT QUITE WHAT
THEY MEAN WHEN ARE I HEARD
OCTOBER TELL THE SPEECH TO-
CREIGHTON PRISON WITHIN THE-
AND SO- FOR MANY OF OUR PRISON.
EACH THIS. GRAHAM SEPARATELY SO
THAT WOULD BE LIKE IF YOU HAVE
BY WITHIN A PRISON IS LIKE FIVE
MINUTES SINCE AND THEY WILL WE
DID IS WE BROKE IT DOWN FURTHER
SAY ON THIS FACILITY ONLY BILL
AT A TIME CAN GO TO YOUR- SO
THAT WE TRY TO BE. THE PROSCAR.
FROM BUILD TO BUILD. SO THAT'S
WHY WE DONE IS SO I DON'T KNOW
THAT REALLY IS WHAT DOCTOR
TELLS WAS REFERENCE WHEN HE
SAID- COOL. CREATING MANY. BUT
MANY OF OUR- ARE LIKE MANY.
WITH A PRESENT AND THE WE IT
OUT BY ALONE ONE HOUSE UNIT AT
A TIME GO TO YOUR- SO MAYBE WE-
TALK PATEL SIX AND WORLD SAME
ROUTE ESSENTIAL TO GET INSIDE
LIKE IT MIGHT BE FOR THE FOR.
TIME RESPOND THAT IS WOULD YOU
IN MIND DOCTOR. WHAT WHAT WE
USE. THE PROPOSAL- THE MEASURES
THAT THAT DIRECT GIPSON
DESCRIBING ARE EXACTLY PART OF
I MEAN. PRISONS WITHIN. THE
DIFFICULTY IS WHEN THE
CROSSLINK BE THOSE YOU REMAIN.
SO IF YOU LOOK FOR IN AT THE
RECENT. A LARGE OPEN AT S. A.
T. F. THE SUBS OF TO TREAT THIS.
MY UNDER THAT THE WAS COULD. TO
BY THE FACT. THE KIDS STAFF.
AND THE LITTLE WERE WORKING A
THE BUTTER WHEN YOU. FOR WERE
MIXING WITH LARGE NUMBERS OF
OTHER. AND THAT WHAT HAVE THERE
FOR WAS THAT. THE NAY CHAU OUT
BREAK THAT HAVE. THE BETTER
MANUFACTURING VESSEL AND- WAS
UNABLE TO SEE VERY RAPIDLY TO
ALMOST HUNDRED. IF THE PRESENCE
ARE ON IT'S A WAY THAT THE
ISN'T STAFF ACROSS OVER THE
DOESN'T SHIFT IN HOUSING UNIT
THE AFTERNOON IN ANOTHER. AND
IT DOESN'T HAVE RESIDENTS ARE
WORK IN ONE A AND THEN SLEEPING
IN ANOTHER A- AND- THIS RAP.
TRANSMISSION FROM ONE HOUSE
UNIT TO A- THAT'S WHAT I MEAN
BY MORE EFFECTIVE. TO WEAR
THOSE MANY PRISONS THAT THE
DIRECTOR GIPSON DESCRIBED ARE
FURTHER ISOLATED FROM EACH
OTHER BY PREVENTING BOTH STAFF
AND RESIDENTS FROM CROSSING
OVER BETWEEN THEM. AND THAT
THOSE STAFF WHO HAVE TO CROSS
OVER BETWEEN THEM OF THOSE
RESIDENTS WHO AFTER CROSSOVER
THEY HAVE ENHANCED TESTING THEY
HAVE ENHANCED PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT- SO THAT
WHEN. AN INFECTION HAPPENS IT
CAN BE DETECTED EVEN MORE
QUICKLY BECAUSE OF THE
POTENTIAL. TO INFECT MULTIPLE
HOUSING UNITS AT THE SAME TIME.
SO IS THERE SOMETHING TAKE A
ABSENT THAT- SKIP THAT- AND HE
CONSIDER OR THE YOU'RE WILLING
CAN. I MEAN IF WE'RE IF WE'RE
TRYING TO. KIND OF. MAKE THIS
WORK. I WOULD USE TO THAT. YES
WHAT DOCTOR TOLD THE SAYS SENSE
AND SO FARAS- TRYING TO KEEP
THOSE WORK WHO MAY BE KITCHEN
WERE ASIDE TO ONE. IN AND SO
LOOKED LOOK AT THAT AND HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS- BECAUSE WE
ARE TRYING TO. YOU KNOW REALLY
HAVE OUR STAFF STAY IN ONE AREA
WORK ONE AREA UNDERSTANDING
SOMETIME WE BUMP UP AGAINST
HAVING TO. HIGHER TIME BECAUSE
UP CALL SO. BUT THE- TO SOME
THAT RECKON I THEM. AS RELATES
TO TRY TO MITIGATE THE SPREAD
WE COULD LOOK THAT CENTER.
RIGHT AND MY LAST- GO TO THIS.
SEEM TAKING A LOOK AT. MEDICAL
HIGH RISK OF PRISONERS EARLY
REAL. OR COMPARE WERE- SO THEY-
YOU CAN REDUCE SIZE THE PRISON.
IN DO SO. LOW RISK- IT MAY
STATUS JUST DOT. WELLBEING
INCLUDED WHAT ARE YOU DOING IN
REGARD IT SHOULD SHOW THAT YOU
THE- ABILITY TO TALK WHERE YOU
KNOW IT FOR THEIR OFFER. OR LET-
IS SOMETHING YOU MIGHT MORE. OR
DO YOU FEEL THAT YOU'RE MOVING
AT THE PACE THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY BE RESPONSIVE TO
THOSE ISSUES WITH YOU KNOW GET
TAKING PEOPLE GETTING PEOPLE
OUT OF DONE THEIR TIME AND ARE
AT LOW RISK OR WHO MIGHT BE-
HAVE THE HIGH. RISKS FOR
COALBED ARE OTHERWISE LOW RISK
FOR RECIDIVISM. WHAT HAPPENING
WITH THEIR PROGRAM BECAUSE THAT
SEEMS TO HAVE SOME PROMISE- AND
SOMETHING THAT IT'S- LIKE
THAT'S REALLY IN EXCLUSIVELY IN
YOUR DAILY WORK- THAT YOU HAVE
FULL. TO AND JUST TO MAKE THOSE
TO. FOR I'M WONDERING HOW THAT
BEING. OR FOR WRONG THE YOU DO
HAVE THE AT THE- OR THAT-
EXCLUDES OR THAT OTHERS TO
SHARE THAT ALREADY I THINK THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL IN TRYING TO.
ANTICIPATE HOW WE CAN. EXPEDITE
RELEASE WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE.
SO CENTER- I DON'T HAVE A
ANSWER FOR QUESTION TO WHETHER
OR NEXT I KNOW WE'RE DOING MAY-THINGS. TO ADDRESS THE- NEEDS
ENSURE THAT. THOSE WHO ARE MOST
MEDIC BOTTOM ARE WE THE NURSES.
AND I WOULD HAVE TO GO BACK
LOOK AT ISSUE AND ANSWER COVERS
A ABOUT- I'M NOT AWARE OF
THERE'S ANY OTHER STRATEGY HE'S
BEEN BILLS RIGHT NOW FOR A- THE
RELEASE OF MORE MEDICALLY. PAY
AT THE SIDE WHAT ARE BIG RED AS
WE TO THE WHO ARE YET- OVER AND
IF THEY MEET THE- FOR. BERLIN
TO THAT PROCESS- BUT I CAN DE
TAKE THIS BACK I AM SO I DON'T
AN ANSWER FOR YOU I JUST WHO
GETS TO DO THESE THINGS I MEAN
IT IT'S KINDA FEELS YOU YOU ARE.
THE SOLD OF WHETHER CAN
RELEASED ON AN EARLY RELEASE
PROGRAM FOR THE REASON THAT
WE'VE DISCUSSED- ACT THAT'S
REALLY TO YOU EXCLUSIVELY TO
YOU YOU KNOW UP TO THE PRISONS
EXCLUSIVELY. WHILE THE
SECRETARY DOES HAVE A- DO
RELEASE AS- AND I'M SORRY I
DON'T HAVE THE GOVERNMENT CODE
THAT ALLOWS FOR THAT. SO I
CAN'T SAY WHAT ALL SHE'S
ALLOWED TO DO BUT I DON'T WANT
TO. SPEAK ON HER BEHALF AS TO.
AT THAT ISSUE I DO KNOW AS A
SET OF SIXTY TWO HUNDRED.
EARLIER FALL LATE SUMMER REVIEW
BY P. P. H. AND I DON'T KNOW
THE NUMBER OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WERE APPROVED FOR RELEASE.
BUT I KNOW- THE BOARD OF PAROLE
HEARINGS THAT REVEALED THEY
WERE SUBMITTED TO THE
SECRETARY. AND THE FORMER
SECRETARY- MASON DECISIONS AS
TO WHETHER TO RELEASE OR NOT
AND I DON'T HAVE THOSE NUMBERS
SENATOR. SHOW IN A BOTTOM LINE
THERE'S NO MANDATE TO DO IT
THERE'S TRUST- THROUGH A
PROCESS THAT EXISTS OF THE
SECRETARY SO DECIDES IS THAT
ACCURATE. I THINK I MAY BE
OVERSIMPLIFYING IT SENATORS SO.
I WANT TO SAY I DO KNOW THE
SECRETARY HAS. THE AUTHORITY
UNDER GOVERNMENT CO. BUT I
THINK IT'S MORE COMPLEX THAN
THAT. THANK YOU AND I JUST LIKE
TO SUGGEST TO MY COLLEAGUES
SINCE. IN ABOUT TEN DAYS I WILL
NO LONGER BE A SENATOR- THROUGH
THE GREAT TERM LIMITS PROGRAM
I'M SUGGEST THIS MIGHT BE
SOMETHING WHERE WE SHOULD LOOK
MORE. CAREFULLY BECAUSE. IT
SOUNDS LIKE. THE DECISION MAKER
IS SOME UP IN THE EITHER- AND
THEN FOR. UNDER THE SIR. THIS
IS AN OP. FOR LEGISLATURE. ODDS
SAID PAUL IS TO WIN. ARE THESE
PRISON ARE SHOULD- AT RISK. TO
THE PRETTY. CRISIS THERE DOES
AS THIS ONE OR WHEN HAPPENING
IN THE FUTURE JUST GENERALLY TO
TRY. REDUCE THE SIZE OF OUR
PRISON IF THEY'RE ON NEXT-
CROWDED- AFTER. WHO JUST- TO BE
REALLY FOR. MEDICAL SO LOW RISK
REASONS BUT IT SEEMS THERE'S A
WAY TOO MUCH. A HERE. WITHIN
THE PRISONS- TO MAKE THOSE.
UNILATERALLY FRANKLY WITHOUT A
WHOLE LOT OF ACCOUNTABILITY. SO
THANK THANK YOU FOR YOUR
RESPONSES AND FOR THE TIME TO
ASK THOSE QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
HE SAYS JACKSON- PERHAPS I
WOULD NOTE THAT MR KING. IT DID
PUT HIS HAND UP BUT WE NOT
ACTUALLY TO. ANSWERS FROM IN
YOU'RE BEING BY SEN THE YOU
WANT TO CO HIM ACROSS. AND
RELATIONAL YOU JUST. MIGHT MISS
KING WE YOU RISK WOULD YOU. TO
THAT LAST UP. IS THAT INEC
STATE- AND- IF SO WHAT WOULD
YOU. THE DO- TO BECOME IN IN
THE PROCESS. IT IS AN ACCURATE
A SEARCH- THE SIX DIRECT GIVE
DIDN'T THE NUMBER I DO OF THE
EIGHTY TWO HUNDRED WHO ARE
HIRED LESTER ONE PER WERE
ACTUALLY RELEASED- SO LESS THAN
EIGHTY PEOPLE- WERE EVEN THOUGH
THEY THE ISSUE WAS NOT WHETHER
OR NOT THEY WERE HIGHER OF DID
THE ISSUE WAS THE TYPE OF SAN
THEY HAVE WHETHER THEY WERE
WHERE LIFE ARE NOT. OF THE VERY
FIRST THING THAT THAT NEED TO
HAPPEN THE MAJORITY OF SAN OF
CD OURS ELDERLY POPULAR ARE
PEOPLE WITH A SENTENCE HE WOULD
DETERMINE IS INSISTENT BE
YOUNGER- SO THE MOST VULNERABLE
PEOPLE ALL THE FALL INTO THIS
INDETERMINATE SENTENCE CATEGORY
AND ARE BEING EXCLUDED FROM
HIGH RISK MEDICAL CONSIDERATION
BECAUSE OF IT- AND SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S GREAT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO LOOK AT HOW DO
WE CREATE MORE AVENUES FOR
LIFERS TO GET OUT IN A LARGE
SCALE WAY IN RESPONSE. TO THIS
PANDEMIC. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
SENATE JACKSON CENTER MORE. YOU.
FOR I THANK YOU CHAIR I ALSO
HAVE. THE CHIU OF THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE SENATOR NAY
SKINNER AND CENTER SKINNER WAS
A NON TO SERVE YOUR VICE IN. I
WILL MISS YOU AND I ARE
COLLEAGUE A LOT- MY QUESTION IS
TO DOCTOR PROPOSED. I'M CURIOUS
ABOUT METRICS- HOW DO WE
COMPARE TO THE OTHER FORTY NINE
PRISON SYSTEMS IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE SHOULD KNOW HOW MANY
PRISONERS WE HAVE HOW MANY
CASES AND HOW MANY DEATHS AND
I'M JUST WONDERING- HOW THAT
DATA COMPARES TO THE OTHER
FORTY NINE STATES EVERY
AVERAGE- WE- WORSE ARE WE
BETTER. THANK YOU REAL QUICK
AND I WISH I WAS BETTER
PREPARED TO ANSWER IT- LET ME
SAY THAT THE LAST TO STATISTICS
THAT I SAW SUGGESTED THAT.
SEVEN OF THE TOP TEN PRISON AND
JAIL OUTBREAKS IN THE COUNTRY
WERE IN CALIFORNIA. SO THAT
ISN'T AN ENCOURAGING SIGN-
HOWEVER I DID READ. SEE SOME
FROM TEXAS SUGGESTS THAT
THEY'RE DOING WORSE- IN TERMS
OF MORTALITY. AND ONE SHOCKING
STATISTIC WHICH IS VERY MUCH
ALONG THE LINES OF WHAT SENATOR
JACKSON MISTER KING WE'RE JUST
SPEAKING ABOUT. AND THAT IS
THAT OF THE DEATHS IN TEXAS 58%
OF THOSE WERE ELIGIBLE FOR
PAROLE AT THE TIME OF THEIR
DEATH. AND AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT I THINK- IS A VERY
SOBERING STATISTIC AND
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD THINK
ABOUT- THOSE PEOPLE ARE AND DO
NOT HAVE DEATH SENTENCES. AND
YET THEY'RE DYING AS A RESULT
OF THE CONDITIONS THAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE HOUSED IN. MY NEXT
QUESTION IS TO- DR BECK- OF
BASED ON WHAT WE'RE LEARNING SO
FAR THIS YEAR WHAT WHAT HAVE.
WE'VE DEVELOPED AS BEST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES WHAT WE
DETERMINED THAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING. AND NOW THAT WE HAVE
MORE DATA. TO AVAIL OURSELVES
FROM. SOONER TO SEE I THINK THE
MOST STRIKING THING WE'VE
LEARNED IS THAT IF YOU ARE IN
ANY OPEN DORM SETTING. OR A HOW
UNIT THAT'S FUNCTION AN OPEN
DORM LIFE SAME PARTNER FALL
SOMEWHERE YOU MAY HAVE YOUR
INTERNET SO. BUT THE FRONT DOOR
IS ACTUALLY EITHER BY OR FOR
FREE. THAT IT'S INCREDIBLE
CHALLENGING TO KEEP SOMEBODY
SAFE AND THAT TYPE OF
ENVIRONMENT. AND ESPECIALLY FOR
OUR HIGHER RISK PEOPLE THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE ARE HIGHER
CRUDE RESTORES- THERE'S A
THERE'S AND URGING TO GET THEM
MOVED INTO. THAT ARE LESS
LIKELY TO EXPOSE THEM TO KOBE.
AND THEN OF. BY LAST QUESTION
IS TO. MR AS WERE- PRISONERS BE
RELEASED BACK INTO THE PUBLIC
SECTOR WORK WHAT DO WE DO TO
ASSURE OUR CONSTITUENTS STATE
THEY WANT TO FEEL SAFE SO WHAT
DO WE- WHAT ARE WE ARE WE GOING
TO GUARANTEE THAT FOR.
CONSTITUENTS THANK YOU A I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
QUESTION- THE MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE INCARCERATED
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE PRISON
SYSTEM WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN IN TEN
FIFTEEN YEARS ON TWENTY YEARS
THERE ARE NO MORE THE SAME
PEOPLE THEY ARE TODAY THEN YOU
AND I ARE THE SAME PEOPLE WE
WORK DURING OUR TIME- PEOPLE
ARE CONTACTING US ALMOST EVERY
DAY WITH SOLID RELEASE PLANS
FOR THEIR LOVED ONES AND
FAMILIES- AS HAS BEEN THE CASE
FROM THE BEGINNING OF TIME-
FAMILIES ARE THE NUMBER ONE WE
INTRIGUED. PROVIDER AND THEY'RE
STANDING BY READY TO TAKE THEIR
LOVED ONES HOME AND HELP THEM
ISOLATED AT HOME SO THAT
THEY'RE NOT IN ANYMORE LARGER
CONGREGATE SETTINGS THE OTHER
THING THAT I WOULD SAY IS WE'VE
SEEN THIS YEAR- CDCR REMINDS US
OVER AND OVER AGAIN THAT
THEY'VE RELEASED ABOUT TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE MORE OR LESS ON
TIME. YET THE- THERE HAS BEEN
NO UPTICK IN IN RECIDIVISM AS A
RESULT SO WE SEE THAT WE CAN
SAFELY DO MORE RELEASES AND
THEY HAVE FOR PUBLIC. HEALTH
SAKE WE SHOULD. I AM- JUST
CHRISTMAS. BASED ON THE FIRST-
THERE IS AN THERE HAS BE A NASH
SOCIAL. OF PRISONS. I WOULD
ASSUME. JUST LIKE THERE ARE
THIS. FOR ALL OTHER FUNCTIONS.
BUT IT BE. HELPFUL IF THEY HAD
PROVIDE SOME OF. ANALYSIS OF
WHAT IS THE HOW PRISON HAVE.
HAVE BEEN TED POSITIVE HOW MANY.
YOU KNOW HOW MANY OF THE AND
WHAT BURKE IN AND WATER. SOME
OF BETTER SYSTEMS DO- TO KEEP
THE NUMBERS LOW AND WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE- FAILING SYSTEMS
DOING- THAT. THEY CAN IDENTIFY
AREAS OF IMPROVEMNT SO WITH
THAT MR THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME TO ASK A FEW
QUESTIONS THANK. THANK YOU SIR
MORE LOCK- MAY MAYBE- JUST
BRIEFLY ASK- DIRECTOR GIVES AND
IS THERE SUCH AN ASSOCIATION
THAT CDC ARE PERHAPS YEARS DATA
WITH WITH OTHER STATES. THE
SAID DRESS. MORLOCKS. OUR
CENTERPLATE PICKS ANSWER THAT
YEAH I SAY THAT THERE ARE
NUMBER OF. AND WE ALONG TO THEM
A NATIONAL COMMISSIONER
CORRECTIONAL CARE MANY OF OUR
POSITION ARE MEMBER THE
AMERICAN OF CRACKS OFFICER
WHICH RECENT. ARE A POSITION
PAPER IN FRONT OF THE RED SO.
URGING THEM TO OUR- PUT OUR
PATIENTS CENTERS TO THE OF THE
LIST FOR UNITS. AND TO YOUR
CENTER THERE DATA PUT OUT BY
TOMORROW PROJECT MOST RECENTLY
OCTOBER. TWENTY WHICH IS BY
STATE WHAT KRONE VIRUSES WHICH
THAT K. LITTLE THAT MEAN IN
TERMS OF K. AND- OUR- IN. OF
DEATHS AND WE CAN YOU MAKE YOU
WOULD LIKE. THANK THANK YOU
CENTER MORE LAW AND NOW GET
BACK CENTER. THANK YOU- SHARE
PAN- AND I APPRECIATE ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES ARE. I WANT TO GO
BACK TO THIS ISSUE OF. THE HOW
WE DEAL WITH VIRUS THE NUMBER
OF CASES THAT ARE THIS
CONGREGATE PARK FOR SO. AND AS
WE ALREADY- HEARD THROUGHOUT
THIS TESTIMONY THAT WE A NUMBER
ARE RIGT. THERE'S BEEN
SIGNIFICANT SINCE OUR JULY
HEARING. AND- IT- WE HAVE A
CASE THAT IS NOW BEFORE US IN
WE KNOW THAT. AS GIVE POINTED
OUT THE- THE CITY'S ART SELF WE
HAVE A BOROUGH OF- TOOLS IT'S-
DISPATCH CALLED SEP D. OR THE
MEDICAL AND OR ELDER PAROLE OR
COME RELEASE THAT WE A VARIETY
OF TOOLS THAT COULD. US TO AT
LEAST FOUR X. ENTRE SOMETHING
FOR PROVIDES TYPE OF FOR THOSE
WHO ARE MOST MEDICALLY. AND I
RACED THEY MIGHT WAS THAT THE
WERE AT SIX TWO HIGH. MEDICALLY
IDENTIFY THAT WERE LOW RISK AND
NON SEXIST MET OTHER. BUT THEN
ONLY FOR FOUR. WERE RELEASED.
YEAH AND I WILL TO AGAIN TO SEE
ARE THAT THERE ARE TECHNIQUES
IT CONCERNS PUBLIC. WE COULD
FREE USE USE A MONITOR. WE
COULD USE FOR LOW SYSTEM WE
COULD A VERY OF SIX. THAT WE
REMOVE A PARTY DEATH ST FOR
DIESEL WHO ARE NOT SENTENCE TO
DEATH BUT WHO IF THEY HIGHLY
MEDICALLY ABLE AND CAN TO HAVE
THE TYPE ABOUT THAT WE- THERE
ARE WAYS THAT WE CAN. GET THE
NEW STAY. YEAH PROTECT INTO
WERE THE STATE TIME. THEY ARE
PUBLIC'S. AND SO I WOULD A
LITTLE MORE ON. A LIVE MORE
RESEARCH AROUND THAT IN FOR
HALF THEY ALSO WE AS IF SAFETY
COMMITTEE AND WE HAVE THE P.
AND- RESPONSE COMMITTEE THINK
ABOUT WHETHER WE TO KEEP ME AT
SOME POINT WHETHER WE WANT TO
COMMUTE. SOMETHING TO DO. ON
THIS QUEST AND I POINT THAT OUT
NOT ONLY DO TO. HIGH NUMBER OF
K. OF THE VIRUS BUT ALSO THAT
WE- EVEN THE GOOD NUMBERS. THAT
WE HAVE A LOWER AND MOST OF%
THOSE WERE RELEASES ON THE
NATURAL BUT AYWAY EVEN WITHOUT
LOWER POPULATION WE ARE STILL
ABOVE. THE DESIGN CAPACITY IF
OF OUR- AND I'LL STOP THERE.
DID YOUR DOCTOR DIRECTOR GIPSON
YES THAT YEAH THE DRUG GIVES
AND- AS I DE SHARE YOUR CONCERN
ABOUT HIS THAT. OUR MEN
BANGALORE PROTECT AND I
DEFINITELY CONCERN ABOUT IS- AS
ALL OF US ARE OVER HERE. ABOUT
THE OF IN THE RATE OF IN WITHIN
A SYSTEM. I'M AT THE END OF OUR
WE WERE ABLE TO GET DOWN TO
UNDER HUNDRED K. IN. AS AS A
STATE. SO THE CITY ARE KNOW.
GUITARIST IN A IN THE
COMMUNITIES IN THE BRING IT
BACK IN- I DON'T A RISK WOULD.
TO THE RELEASE OF THE MEDIC
BOTTLE. MY POPULATION BUT I DO
SHOW BECAUSE OF HIS. THEIR
SAFETY AND A- THAT. THEY NOT
COMMITTED TO A DEATH SENTENCE
WHEN IT CAME TO I DON'T SHARED
AS- ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SKINNER
ARE. NO I THINK THE ARE MORE
IT'S POINT THAT WE ENTER INTO
SHE DISCUSS I'D AM. DIRECTOR
GIPSON YOUR- PAY. AND YOUR-
JUST WHAT YOU'VE EXPRESSED YOUR
LOOKING IN THESE ALSO YOUR A
THIS THIS. SO I KNOW THE YOU
KNOW FOR HAND AND- DOC BIG
SIMILAR. AND I ALSO THE FIRST
WE GOTTEN FOR OUR EXTRA AND
DOCTORS COOPER THE AN ALSO ME
KING WHO I KNOW- HIMSELF WAS.
HE'S NOT BEEN OUT OF-
INCARCERATION FOR DOUBT LONG
IT'S HE SAID KEEPS VERY CLOSE
TAX WITH MANY. CARS INTO. SO I
THINK WE HAVE HAD A ROBUST
PANEL AND I THINK THAT WE HAVE
SINCE. FROM EVERY ABOUT TRYING
TO IT I LIKE SOME OR ANOTHER
THERE LAW WORK. SYSTEM WE STILL
JUST BEEN A TO. EARN WHATEVER
IT SO I THAT WE IN THAT WILL
HAVE TO SOME. ARE AS TO WHAT.
COMMUNICATE WE MAY CHOOSE MAKE
A SUBSEQUENT TO THE TO THE
MINISTRY. I THANK YOU SAN
SKINNER- MAY I JUST MAKE A FEW
ROOM WITH WE MOVE ON OUR NEXT-
AGAIN I THANK OUR- PANEL
MEMBERS FOR YOUR- AND- THAT- WE
DO HAVE A- A LARGE AND COMPLEX
SYSTEM- I THINK KNOW CERTAINLY-
CENTER SKI. CHAIR OF PUBLIC. I
THINK IS- RIGHT- PROCESS AND
POINT AND CAN. I JUST MAKE
ANOTHER. MY THAT- YOU KNOW
WE'RE HEADING INTO THE WAY NOW
AND- I YOU KNOW I I'M THAT MANY
OF THESE ARE COMP HURDLE I'M
GONNA YOU KNOW WILL FOLLOW UP
IN WILL LOOK BUT I WOULD ALSO
MAKE NOTE THAT- YOU KNOW WERE
COME UP TO A BIT OF A TWO
TRYING WHEN IT TO WHAT'S ON.
WITH THE NEW OF CODE GOING UP
IN- BECAUSE AND OF COURSE
INCLUDES CAL WE'RE DOING THAN
OF THE BUT BUT YOU WERE NOT
WE'RE STILL PART OF THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY SO THAT HAPPENS US
AND- I DO SO- WORRIES-
CERTAINLY FOR THE PEOPLE IN THE
PRESS TO NOW THERE FOR AND IN
THEY NEED BE CAPS AND ALSO FOR
THE CA IN WHICH THESE PRESENTS
LOCATED WHERE THE IN WHICH THE
STAFF LIVES WELL. AND SO- I
GUESS MY- I GUESS I WOULD URGE-
IF THERE'S POSSIBLE. AND I KNOW
THE- EVERY DAY. BUT TO MAYBE
SWIFT ACTION- BECAUSE WE ARE
COMING UP- INTO SOME INTO THE
HOLLOW. SO OR COME UP IN.
SLOUGH SEASON. NINE ABOUT FLU
VACCINE- WE'RE COMING UP IN TWO
THE WINTER. AND- WEEK. THEM OF
CASE. TO INCREASE. AS A RESULT
OF THAT AND THAT'S WHY. PUBLIC
HEALTH MEASURES ARE GOING TO BE
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT TO TRY TO
KEEP THE NUMBER OF CASES DOWN
IN COMMUNITIES AND OF COURSE
THAT'LL FACT. EXPOSURE PEOPLE
IN PRISONS AND CERTAINLY WHAT.
CENTER SKINNER MENTIONED ABOUT
THE RATE IN OUR PRISONS RIGHT
NOW IS CERTAINLY VERY
CONCERNING HOW HIGH IT IS
COMPARED TO. THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITY BUT THAT TO FEEDBACK
LOOP IN THOSE COMMUNITIES RIGHT
HI. RIGHT NOW PRISON MEANS
HIGHER RATED COMMUNITY THEN
FEEDS INTO IRATE PRESIDENT. SO
AGAIN APPRECIATE THE DISCUSS.
AND- I THINK CENTER SKIN PRIDE
SIDE WITH. OR WHOEVER BECOMES
YOUR PUBLIC SAFETY NET SESSION
WANT TO DO SO. TO CONTINUE TO
DO. UPS ON ON SUNDAY. AS THIS
IS A FOLLOW HEARING IT'S- SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH. BYE WE'RE
NOW GONNA MOVE. TO OUR SO.
PANEL AND I JUST FOR MY- PEOPLE
THAT BE TAKING. COMMENT AT END
OF THE- IS A PANEL AFTER. QUEST
SO- IS ON. SOME STATE PRISON TO
IMMIGRATION CUSTOMS AND- THE
TO. CENTER AND- WE WILL- BEGIN.
WITH AND- THE FIRST WITNESS-
HIGH DICKSON- CHIEF CASE
RECORDS. OVER IT CITIES ARE AND
PLEASE WELCOME THE STICKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GET AFTER.
AND TO DETERMINE FOR MINUTES TO
PLEASE. OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. MY ROLE TO IS TO. CITIES
AS PAUL. AND PROCESS. AND WORK
TURN MEANING. WITH LONG.
AGENCIES WHEN PEOPLE IN OUR
CUSTODY MAY HAVE L. STAND
WARRANTS OR- MATTER IN JUROR.
AND IN THE- FOR THE PURPOSES OF
EARING ONE OF THE AGE INCLUDES
THE FEDERAL IMMIGRATION AND
CUSTOMS ENFORCEMENT ALSO KNOWN
AS ICE. BY WAY OF BACKGROUND I
WILL BEGIN BY EXPLAINING OUR
PROCESS. UPON RECEIPT OF AN
INMATE TO A RECEPTION CENTER
CITY SEE OUR STAFF COLLECTS
AVAILABLE INFORMATION ABOUT AN
INMATE DURING THE RECEPTION
CENTER PROCESS WHICH IS WHEN AN
INMATE IS PLACED IN CDC OURS
CUSTODY AFTER ADJUDICATION BY A
COURT OF LAW. THIS INFORMATION
IS CRITICAL FOR THE DEPARTMENT
AS IT HELPS US DETERMINE
HOUSING ASSIGNMENTS PROGRAMMING
OPPORTUNITIES RISK FACTORS
AMONG OTHER THINGS. FOR INMATES
WHO ARE FOREIGN BORN THE
INFORMATION COLLECTED SUCH AS
INMATES COUNTRY OF CITIZENSHIP
AND PLACE OF BIRTH IS IMPORTANT
TO ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO WORK
WITH FOREIGN CONSULATES
ESPECIALLY IN THE EVENT OF
THEIR DEATH WHILE IN CUSTODY.
IT MAY ALSO BE BENEFICIAL FOR
THE INMATE AS ONE OF THE FORMS
COMPLETED UPON RECEPTION IS A
FORMER PRISONER TRANSFER
TREATIES PROGRAM. THIS PROVIDES
A NOTIFICATION TO THE AND MAY I
HAVE THE RIGHT TO APPLY TO
RETURN TO THEIR COUNTRY OF
NATIONALITY. AS PART OF THE
RECEPTION CENTER PROCESS THE
INMATES COMMITMENT DOCUMENTS
FROM THE COURT- AUDITED AND
RECORDED IN OUR LIKE TRONIC
SYSTEM TO ENSURE THE
APPROPRIATE TERM AMOUNT IS
SERVED. AND A RELEASE DATE IS
CALCULATED FOR EACH PERSON.
THIS INCLUDES RECORDING ANY
LEGAL MANDATES THAT MAY BE
REQUIRED DEPENDING ON THE
CONVICTION TYPE SUCH AS
REQUIRED REGISTRATIONS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT NOTIFICATIONS. AS
PART OF OUR AUDIT PROCESSES AND
THE INMATES CASE FACTORS BASED
ON LEGAL DOCUMENTS AND
INFORMATION COLLECTED FROM THE
INMATE CASE RECORDS REVIEWS THE
INMATES CRIMINAL HISTORY RAP
SHEET TO IDENTIFY ANY
ADDITIONAL WARRANTS. OR
OUTSTANDING CHARGES THE PERSON
MAY HAVE THESE MAYBE UNTRIED
CHARGES OR PROBATION AND PAROLE
REVOCATION CHARGES CONTACT IS
MADE WITH ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AT THE LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL LEVEL TO INQUIRE ON THE
ACTIVE WARRANTS WHICH MAY
REQUIRE A DETAINER TO BE PLACED
ON THE ENEMY. THE PURPOSE OF
THIS COMMUNICATION IS FOR US TO
KNOW WHETHER THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY PLANS TO
PURSUE THESE ACTIVE WARRANTS
ARE HOLDS. THE DETAINER ASSURES
THE AGENCY WHEN THE INMATE IS
ELIGIBLE FOR RELEASE CONTACT
WILL BE MADE WITH THEM TO
ARRANGE FOR TRANSFER OF CUSTODY
TO THEIR JURISDICTION UPON
RELEASE. IT IS ULTIMATELY THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
DECISION IF I TRANSFER OF
CUSTODY WILL OCCUR UPON
RELEASED OR NOT. THE
DEPARTMENT'S ROLE IS TO PROVIDE
THE NOTIFICATION PLACED A
DETAINER EFFICIENT NOTIFY THE
AND MADE OF THE DETAINER AND
COORDINATE THE TRANSFER OF
CUSTODY UPON THE INMATE
SCHEDULED RELEASEDATE. THE
DEPARTMENT DOES NOT DETERMINE
THE IMMIGRATION STATUS OF
INCARCERATED PEOPLE IN OUR
CUSTODY THAT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF ICE. PRIOR TO
PLACING A DETAINER ANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY INCLUDING AN
ICE MAY REQUEST TO INTERVIEW
AND IN MAY. OUR DEPARTMENT
COMPLIES WITH THIS REQUEST AND
COORDINATES THE INTERVIEW
BETWEEN THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY AND THE PERSON. SENATE
BILL FIFTY FOUR CDCR IS
REQUIRED TO NOTIFY. AN INMATE
IF THAT AN INTERVIEW WITH ICE
IS VOLUNTARY AND THEY CAN HAVE
THEIR ATTORNEY PRESENT. WITHIN
FIFTEEN DAYS OF THE INMATES
REALLY STATE CASE RECORD STAFF
CONTACT ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES INCLUDING NICE WANTED
CANER HAS BEEN LODGED AGAINST A
PERSON FOR THE PURPOSES OF
COORDINATING PICK UP
ARRANGEMENTS TO FACILITATE THE
TRANSFER OF CUSTODY. FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES EXCLUDING
NICE THE LAW ALLOWS CDC ARE TO
RELEASE INMATES TO THE AGENCY
WATCHING THE DETAINER FIVE DAYS
PRIOR TO OR AFTER THE INMATE
SCHEDULED RELEASE DATE. PERSON
THANK IT'S TIME TO WRAP UP
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR ICE I
SHALL SCHEDULE PICK UP AND THE
INMATE WITHIN FIVE CALENDAR
DAYS PRIOR TO OR ON THE
OFFENDER SCHEDULED RELEASE DATE
IF ICE DOES NOT PICK UP THE
INDIVIDUAL THE INDIVIDUAL IS
RELEASED ON THEIR SCHEDULED
RELEASE DATE UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF A PAROLE OR
PROBATION. AGENT IF AT ANY
PEARLS UNDER THE SUPERVISION OF
DIVISION OF ADULT PAROLE
OPERATIONS INTO ICE CUSTODY ON
AN ICE HOLD. THE CASE IS
TRANSFERRED TO U. S. I. N. S.
CASELOADS WHICH ARE HOUSED AT
NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN REGION
PAROLE HEADQUARTERS WITHIN THE
RESPECTIVE RE ENTRY UNITS.
THERE THE CASE IS MONITORED BY
A PAROLE SERVICES ASSOCIATE ON
A BANK TO CASELOAD WHERE THEY
MONITOR HOUSING STATUS WITHIN.
THE FEDERAL DETENTION SYSTEM.
THE RALLY IS FROM ICE CUSTODY.
AND RETURN TO PEARLS. THE CASES
THEN TRY BACK TO A AGENT IN THE
LOCAL UNIT THAT IS FOR THIS.
AND THE COUNTY LAST THE REST.
OR COUNTY A COMMITMENT. A AN
INMATE PEARLS THE SAME. OF THE
DAY. OPERATIONS WITH AYE COLD
BUT ISN'T DID BY I. THEIR SUIT
IN THE KEY. AND THE SAME MANNER
AS OTHER INTO. WHO ARE I'M FOR.
EXTREMELY SORRY OKAY THANK YOU
INCOME THANK YOU SEE IN CONTROL
AS CAN SEE. CITIES YOU'RE
THEM TO OUR COOPER. WITH LINE.
AGENCIES ONE RELAY TO STILL ARE
WARRANTS CARS PERSONS LIKEWISE
AND. I JUST WANNA THANK FOR
YOUR TO SPEAK TO AND I WELCOME
IN QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU MISS AND WE WILL YOU
PROBABLY WILL SOME UPPER AND
PEOPLE ASK QUESTIONS BUT WE DO
OUR- TO OUR TIME FRAME. SO WE
CAN BEWE CAN GET THROUGH THE
EVERYONE TIME. I KNOW YOU A LOT
OF VERY IMPORTANT FOR. AND SO-
BUT WE CAN PROVIDE THAT IN
WRITING IN ADVANCE AS WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TO.
LET'S MOVE TO- TENTH ON. WHO IS
THE ASIAN FOR SUPPORT COMMITTEE.
ADVOCATE IN FORMER. PERSONS SO.
ONE THANK YOU FOR LAUNCH. MY
NAME CHAMPIONED BY. I WAS BORN
DOING THEIR AND- WHERE MOST MY
FAMILY WERE MURDERED INCLUDING
FATHER- ONE GREW UP THAT CAN
AND TYLER. AND I AT THIS THE-
OR FOOD WHEN I WAS YOUNG
BECAUSE VIDEO HAPPEN- I WAS
ROBBED THIS A STRONG SELLING
FRUITS INDUSTRY. AND I HAD A
LOT DRAMA I SAW THAT AND ENJOY.
AND. ABOUT SIX YEARS- I AM.
FROM CAMP IN TWO. A STATES WITH
KNOWING ANY AT NOT SPEAK THE
LANGUAGE OR EVEN THAT WOULD. A
HOLE FOR. THE NON THIS COUNTRY
AND MY- MIKE. AND- OLDER UNCLE.
DID JUSTICE OF. AS WE CAN AND
WILL HELP ON. THAT LIST ARE
KIDS. ON OUR OWN. IN ONE FILE
BECAUSE- WE WERE POORLY WE'RE A.
THE NATURE OF THE TROUBLED AND
I WAS LIVING WITH A LOT OF
TREMENDOUS KNOW HOW TO EXPRESS-
WHEN I TURN EIGHTEEN. ARE
COMMITTED A CRIME OF SECOND
DEGREE ROBBERY BEING A OUT IN A
ROBBERY. AND LISTEN TO FORTY
NINE YEARS- AT EIGHTEEN I
THOUGHT. THAT WAS MY LIFE AND I
GAVE UP ON IT- I FELT IN THE
DINING YOUR- BILLING THAT. I
GOT HELP FROM MYSELF AND START.
MYSELF AND- AND SO TRYING. AND
I WORKED UNTIL SB TWO SIXTY
ALLOW. TO FIGURE. AND I MY
PAROLE AND- FEBRUARY TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY TWENTY FOUR- WHEN
PICK HAPPEN. I WAS IN CENTURY.
WHEN FRANKLIN HAD THEIR OUT-
THE STAFF THE CEOS THEN TAKE A-
AND CHECK IT. SERIOUSLY THEY'RE
WALKING AROUND WITH NO- TRYING
TO WRITE A UP OR COVER NOT
BECAUSE WE'RE WE LIVE IN A
ALIGNMENT- THAT I WAS BEING
TRANSFERRED TO ICE AND THEY
ALLOW HIM TO COME INTO OUR
BUILDING. DURING THE OUTBREAK-
RIGHT WHEN- THANK WHEN OF START
TYPING FOR COLBY I WAS SCARED
THAT I WOULD ATTACK COVE IT IF
I WENT TO TAKE A CHANCE BECAUSE
THE WAY THEY TESTED AS THEY
JUST LET US CONGREGATE IN THE
IN THE YARD AND WAS JUST
WAITING ON TESTS AND WERE
SITTING SIDE BY SIDE WHY
BECAUSE THIS I REFUSED TO TEST
AND THEN. A FEW DAYS LATER I
STARTED HAVING SYMPTOMS OF A
COLD IT- I WAS SCARED TO SAY
ANYTHING I THOUGHT IT WAS JUST
A OF A COLD THAT'S COMING
THROUGH SANGUINE BUT I HAD A
FEELING IT WAS COLD BECAUSE I
WAS GETTING CHAPTERS AND LYFT-
THEY WOULD CHECK US IN THE
MORNING FOR TEMPERATURE AND I
WAS NORMAL SO I DIDN'T KNOW IT
WAS COLD IT OR WHAT'S UP- JUST
A HEADACHE- ON THE DAY AYE
PEROT- I'M STILL WAITING FOR US
TO COME SO. I WAS STRESSED AND
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO DO I
WROTE A LETTER TO MY FAMILY
SAYING MY LAST GOODBYE BECAUSE
I KNOW IF I WOULD WANT TO
MENTION I WAS GONNA DIE BUT I
DIDN'T KNOW WHO TO SEND IT TO
ANYONE I GIVE IT TO ANYBODY
THAT WOULD HELP TRAUMATIZED HIM
IF MY DEATH WHAT HAPPENS ON
THAT BUT IN MY PROPERTY. AND IN
HOPES THAT MY FAMILY FIND IT-
ON THE DAY I PEROT I WAS HAVING
A FEVER- I WASN'T TOLD NOTHING
ABOUT- WHICH DELVES INTO PRO I
WASN'T TOLD IF I CHRIS CUMMINGS
CEO OR MISTER BURN ON THE
INTERNET I'M GAPS TO ASK YOU TO
WRAP UP IF YOU CAN YES- ON THE
BAT PAROLE- NOTICE WAS GIVEN TO
ME- I COULD NOT PICK ME UP I
WAS I WAS BROUGHT TO THE
PUBLIC. SIX THE COMMUNITY. CAME
TO ME THEY GAVE ME A- HOPE AS
AND I WILL TRANSFER. AND CAN.
IN AND HELP ME WITH HEALING
THEY HELP WITH FOOD- LIVING.
THEY HELP ME WITH. ANY THAT I
NEED TO HEAL MUCH. SO AND- I
KNOW THAT IF- IF I WAS
TRANSFERRED OUT BUY. MY HAVE
THERE NOW. BUNDCHEN KILO IT'S A
FIREFIGHTER WAS INJURED IN THE
FIRE AND THEY TRANSFERRED TO
AYE. HOUSE DAILY IT'S NOT BY
ACQUIRED AS TRANSFER THE I.
AND- ATTY WALLACE. SHE WAS
TRANSFERRED TO ICE AND- NOW SHE
A- TRACTOR WITH ENACT TENSIONS
AND YOUR DOGS ARE GONNA IT
FINISH UP THE- THANK YOU OUT I
HOPE THAT YOU GUYS WOULD. THE
AND A TRANSLATOR I BECAUSE WE
SERVE OUR TIME AND A LOT OF
THOSE AT WORK ON OURSELVES AND-
WE'RE WHAT WE ASKING FOR SECOND
CHANCE LIFE. MOST OF S DON'T
KNOW OR HAVE. DON'T KNOW OUR
COUNTRY THAT WE'RE GOING TO
OKAY I DON'T EVEN KNOW IT
AMERICA IS OUR COUNTRY RIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER VAN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY I
THINK THERE MAY BE SOME
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AND-
CENTERS ASK QUESTIONS WERE YOU
MAY BE ABLE TO TALK FURTHER
ABOUT YOUR STORY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR SHARING YOUR STORY.
NEXT WE HAVE OUR NEXT
WITNESSES- MONICA. WHEN THE
RETURN FROM THE IMMIGRANTS-
RATES STAFF IS AN IMMIGRANTS
RIGHTS STAFF ATTORNEY WITH THE
ACLU'S SAN DIEGO AND IMPERIAL
COUNTIES. WELCOME THANK YOU
SENATORS AND THANK YOU
COMMUNITY FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS YOU TODAY. MY NAME
IS MICHAEL AND ANYTIME THE
IMMIGRANTS RIGHT STAFF ATTORNEY
IN BC OF SANTA MONICA COUNTIES
I REPRESENT PEOPLE DETAINED AT
ALL TO ME SENT IMPERIAL. AND
OTHER LANDS IMMIGRATION
DETENTION CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA MUST CEASE ITS-
VOLUNTARILY TRANSFERRING PEOPLE
FROM JAILS AND PRISONS TO
DEADLY ICE FACILITIES. IN
CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL AND STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH AGENCIES MUST
EXERCISE THEIR AUTHORITY TO
REGULATE THE SAFETY AND
WELFARE. OF PEOPLE IN ICE
CUSTODY DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
THE EASILY AFFILIATES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE YOU TRIED MAJOR
LAWSUITS CHALLENGING I'M GOING
I SEE TENSION DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AND ALL ICE DETENTION
CENTERS IN THE STATE INCLUDING-
TAMMY SAID IMPERIAL OTHER
LANDAU INVESTMENT BANK. THROUGH
THE COURSE OF LITIGATION WE
LEARNED ABOUT CONDITIONS IN ICE
DETENTION AND OF ICE AND
PRIVATE FACILITY OPERATORS
MISHANDLING OF THE PANDEMIC.
IT'S CONFIRMED THAT WITHOUT
CONSTANT INTERVENTION FROM ALL
ANGLES POSSIBLE MORE PEOPLE MAY
DIE IN A SUSPENSION. WE'VE
LEARNED THAT IN CALIFORNIA IT
NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTEEN
PEOPLE AND COUNTING HAVE TESTED
POSITIVE FOR CARBON NINETEEN
POLYNICE CUSTODY. AND AS WE
KNOW DURING THE COURSE OF OUR
LITIGATION IN SAN DIEGO ONE
PERSON. KILEY SAID MR SCHOOL
LED ME HERE BECAME THE FIRST
PERSON TO TRAGICALLY AND
UNNECESSARILY LOSE HIS LIFE TO
COVER NINETEEN IN DETENTION
AFTER ICE BOTH REFUSED TO
RELEASE HIM AND FAILED TO
DETAIN HIM IN A WAY. THAT WOULD.
PROTECT HIM FROM DYING FROM THE
VIRUS. FILIATION THE TEAM
ORDERS DIRECTING THE- AND
PRIVATE OPERATORS. TO
IMMEDIATELY RELEASE MEDICALLY
WONDERFUL PEOPLE FROM ATTORNEY
SENT TO MASSIVELY DEPOPULATING
THE LANDLORD TO LOVE THIS AND
SAYING IN ORDER TO ESTABLISHING
A RELEASE PROCESS AND
PROHIBITING THE INTAKES AND A
SEVEN MINUTE. ALL ORDERS WERE
BASED ON THE COURT'S FINDINGS
THAT WE WERE LIKELY TO SUCCEED
ON THEIR CLAIMS THAT CONDITIONS
OF CONFINEMENT. I DURING THE
PANDEMIC IN THESE DETENTION
CENTERS LIKELY VIOLATE PEOPLE'S
RIGHTS TO FIFTH AMENDMENT DUE
PROCESS. AS A RESULT WE SECURE
THE RELEASE OF OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY PEOPLE BUT ONLY
WITH COURT INTERVENTION AND NOT
WITHOUT FROM OBJECTIONS FROM
ICE AND PRIVATE FACILITY
OPERATORS. AT EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY. FEDERAL COURTS TO MAKE
FACTUAL FINDINGS IN SUPPORT OF
THESE ORDERS INCLUDING THAT
FIFTEEN PEOPLE CANNOT SAFELY
PHYSICALLY DISTANCE AND THE
FACILITIES. THAT DETAIN PEOPLE
AND STAFF WHEN THEY HAD ACCESS
TO MASK WE'RE NOT REQUIRED TO
WEAR THEM. THIRTEEN PEOPLE HAVE
THEMSELVES BEEN RESPONSIBLE FOR
CLEANING COMMON AREAS DURING A
PANDEMIC WITH NOTHING MORE THAN
DIRTY TOWELS AND BUCKETS OF
DIRTY WATER. AWARDED TO ME SO
WAS INITIALLY UNABLE TO
ACCURATELY COUNT THE NUMBER OF
MEDICALLY VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN
HIS CUSTODY AS OUTBREAK RAVAGED
THROUGH THIS FACILITY.
CHRISTOPHER THEY'VE FOUND THAT
ICE HAS BEEN DELIBERATELY
INDIFFERENT TO THE POTENTIAL
EXPOSURE TO TEN PEOPLE TO CALL
THE NINETEEN. THAT IT ACTED
WITH CALLOUS DISREGARD FOR THE
SAFETY OF THE TEAM PEOPLE THAT
THE POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
INSTITUTED IN RESPONSE TO THE
OUTBREAK WERE INSUFFICIENT TO
PROTECT MEDICAL WONDERFUL
PEOPLE. AND THIS IS JUST THE
TIP OF THE ICEBERG LIKE THESE
FINDINGS THERE ARE MANY MANY
MORE. CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS ARE
CATEGORICALLY UNSAFE AND IN
DANGER AND FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
DETENTION PARTICULARLY DURING
THE PANDEMIC. THIS IS WHY WE
MUST BE UNEQUIVOCAL THAT
CALIFORNIA NOT ONLY ARES ABOUT
IMMIGRANTS INTERSTATE BUT THAT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS A
CLEAR ROLE TO PLAY IN ENSURING
THAT MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. ARE NOT CAUGHT IN
THE CROSS HAIRS OF DEADLY ICE
DETENTION. THERE'S NO LAW
REQUIRING CALIFORNIA TO COMPLY
WITH REQESTS THAT CDCR IN
LOCAL JAILS TRANSFER PEOPLE TO
ICE CUSTODY. ICE TRANSFERS ARE
VOLUNTARY AND PEOPLE SUBJECT
ICETRANSFERS HAVE BEEN DEEMED
SUITABLE FOR RELEASE BY OUR
STATE'S CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM
THEY'VE SERVED THEIR TIME AND
ONLY FACE INDEFINITE. DETENTION
BECAUSE OF WHERE THEY WERE
BORN. YES YOU SEE OUR AND LOCAL
JAILS ARE THE PRIMARY SUPPLIERS
OF THE TEAMS PEOPLE TO FILL
BEDS AT ICE FACILITIES EVERY
DAY. WHEN C. C. R. LOCAL JOBS
VOLUNTARILY TRANSFER PEOPLE. TO
ICE CUSTODY THEY'RE PLACING OUR
CAN. MEMBERS OUR- ARE MEMBER IN
THE- AND COST. TODAY CAN. THE
SEATTLE DOES NOT CEASE.
TRANSFER OF PEOPLE BECAUSE THE-
FULL STOP. THIS IS ALL
OCCURRING IN THE CONTEXT OF I.
CITING ISSUED ITS OWN PANDEMIC.
OF WHICH EXPRESS DIRECTED
CENTERS. TO COORDINATE WITH
LOCAL AND STATE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. YET TODAY WE'VE
NOT SEEN PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS EXERCISE AUTHORITY
OVER CALIFORNIANS IN ICE
DETENTION MINISTRY TO WRAP UP
PLEASE. FOR EVEN AS BECAUSE
CLAIMED THE LIFE OF THE TEAM
PEOPLE AND STATE. IS THERE IS.
OF THE STATE OF. TO DO
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO PROTECT
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
IMMIGRANTS IN THAT STATE
PARTICULARLY DURING A PANDEMIC
IN WHICH IS RIGHT TO AN
INDIVIDUAL AS A THREAT TO US
ALL. WE ARE EXISTE CALIFORNIA
AND UNNECESSARY TRANSFERS OF
PEOPLE FROM JAILS AND STATE
PRISONS TO DEADLY ISIS YLIDES
AND TO EXERCISE THE AUTHORITY
OF LOCAL AND STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH AGENCIES TO REGULATE THE
SAFETY AND WELFARE OF PEOPLE
IN. CUSTODY DURING THE END OF
IT THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND OUR FINAL PANELIST IS
AMBER. MCKINNEY A PR- IT IS- AT
THE WITH THE HEALTH INSTEAD OF
PUNISHMENT PROGRAM DIRECTOR AND
HEALTH IMPACT. PARTNERS- SO
WELCOME. THANK YOU SHARE
GONZALEZ SKINNER AND DOCTOR CAN
AS WELL AS THE ESTEEMED MEMBERS
OF THESE COMMITTEES. AS A
PUBLIC HEALTH ORGANIZATION
HEADQUARTERED IN OAKLAND HIP
RECENTLY ANALYZED EXISTING
PUBLIC HEALTH EVIDENCE AND
INTERVIEWED DIRECTLY IMPACTED
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES TO
UNDERSTAND HOW DIRECT TRANSFERS
FROM CALIFORNIA PRISONS AND
JAILS THE ICE AFFECT HEALTH.
THE STUDIES DOCUMENT THE HEALTH
HARMS OF CARCERAL SYSTEMS TO
THOSE WHO ARE INCARCERATED OR
DETAINED THEIR FAMILIES AND
EVEN SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES.
FOR EXAMPLE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN INCARCERATED HAVE HIGHER
RATES OF CHRONIC DISEASE HORROR
MENTAL HEALTH AND LOWER LIFE
EXPECTANCY. AND PREGNANT PEOPLE
WHO SIMPLY LIVING TOWNIES WITH
HIGH RATES OF JAIL
INCARCERATION ARE MORE LIKELY
TO EXPERIENCE PRETERM BIRTHS.
WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT MANY
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES ARRIVE
TO THE U. S. WITH TRAUMA WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY CAN PAVE THE WAY
FOR CRIMINALIZATION. WE PUT
EXACTLY WHEN PEOPLE MOST NEED
RESOURCES TO HEAL THERE INSTEAD
POLICE AND FINAL TO JAILS.
FURTHERMORE DEPORTATION OR THE
THREAT OF DEPORTATION
EXACERBATES HEALTH CONDITIONS
LIKE HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE.
RESEARCH ALSO SHOWS THAT
CHILDREN WHO ARE WORRIED ABOUT
THEIR PARENTS DEPORTATION OFTEN
EXPERIENCE WORSENED MENTAL
HEALTH. A CENTRALLY THE PUBLIC
HEALTH DATA ARE CLEAR JAILS
PRISONS IN ICE DETENTION ARE
ANTITHETICAL TO PUBLIC HEALTH.
IT IS NOT A MATTER OF IF THERE
WILL BE COPING NINETEEN
OUTBREAKS INSIDE EVERY SINGLE
CARCERAL FACILITY BUT WHEN. AND
BECAUSE THE POOREST NATURE OF
THESE FACILITIES THESE ALEX CAN
ENDANGER AND OVERWHELM REGIONAL
HEALTH SYSTEMS. IS TRANSFERS
ARE THESE KEY PIPELINE TICE
ATTENTION ABOUT 70% OF PEOPLE
IN ICE CUSTODY ARE THERE
BECAUSE OF A DIRECT TRANSFER.
CALIFORNIA IS NOT A PASSIVE
PARTICIPANT IN THIS PROCESS
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTARILY AND
ACTIVELY COLLABORATES WITH ICE
IN THESE TRANSFERS. I NEED TO
STATE ONE THING VERY PLAINLY.
MUCH LIKE THERE'S NO TRULY
HEALTHY AMOUNT OF LEAD TO
CONSUME. AND THERE'S NO TRULY
SAFE AMOUNT OF ASBESTOS TO
BREEZE. THERE IS NO TRULY SAFE
NOR HEALTHY WAY TO INCARCERATE
PEOPLE WITHIN OR TRANSFER
PEOPLE BETWEEN JAILS PRISONS IN
ICE DETENTION CENTERS
ESPECIALLY DURING A PANDEMIC
MANY OR OTHERWISE. CALIFORNIA
IS LITERALLY GAMBLING WITH
PEOPLE'S LIVES. THE GOOD NEWS
IS THAT THE RESEARCH ALSO
POINTS US TOWARD SOLUTIONS WITH
CHILDREN FOR EXAMPLE THERE IS
EVIDENCE THAT THEY CAN RECOVER
FROM TRAUMA IF THEY HAVE
ADEQUATE SUPPORT INCLUDING
CRUCIALLY STABLE RELATIONSHIPS
WITH CAREGIVERS. LEASING
COMMUNITIES LIKE CHAMPLIN BUNS
ARE EAGER TO WELCOME THEIR
LOVED ONES HOME. IN CLOSING I
WANT TO THANK THE FORTY FIVE
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE WHO
HAVE URGED THE GOVERNOR TO TAKE
EXECUTIVE EXECUTIVE ACTION TO
STOP ICE TRANSFERS. I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF THESE
COMMITTEES WHO HAVE SPOKEN
VOTED AND MARCHED TO AFFIRM
THAT BLACK LIVES MATTER.
BECAUSE OF SYSTEMIC ANTI BLACK
RACISM IN THE CRIMINAL LEGAL
AND IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT
SYSTEMS D. CURSOR RATIONS AND
STOPPING ICE TRANSFERS ARE
CONCRETE WAYS TO USE YOUR STORY
TO LEGISLATE. THAT BLACK LIVES
MATTER. THIS HEARING IS JUST
ONE SMALL STEP TOWARD RACIAL
JUSTICE AND HEALTH EQUITY IN
CALIFORNIA. I WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS ON OUR HEALTH IMPACT
RESEARCH OR POLICY POSITIONS
AND MY QUESTION FOR YOU TODAY
IS WHAT COMMITMENTS CAN YOU
MAKE HERE BECAUSE LEGISLATE
STRUCTURAL SOLUTIONS THE END OF
THE STATE'S COLLABORATION WITH
ICE. TO RELEASE PEOPLE FROM
JAILS AND PRISONS AND TO INVEST
INTO COMMUNITY HEALTH INSTEAD
OF PUNISHMENT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- SO- WE'VE NOW
HEARD FROM OUR PANEL WE WILL BE
MOVING TO MEMBERS QUESTIONS BUT
IS- BEFORE WE GO TO MEMBER
QUESTION JUST REMINDER WILL BE
TAKING PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER THE
MEMBER QUESTIONS SO FOR THOSE.
PEOPLE WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
MAKING PUBLIC COMMENT THROUGH A
TELEPHONIC SYSTEM. PLEASE CALL
IN NOW AND YOU CAN DIAL THIS
TOLL FREE NUMBER. 844-291-6364
AND WHEN YOU'RE PROMPTED USE
THE ACCESS CODE. ACCESS CODE.
THREE THREE SEVEN TWO SEVEN
SEVEN THREE SO AGAIN WE WILL BE
TAKING PUBLIC COMMENT. AFTER
MEMBERQUESTIONS I WOULD MAKE
NOTE THERE'S AT WILL BE
ALLOWING ONE MINUTE PER.
CONTENT AND CERTAINLY FEEL FREE
TO SUBMIT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY- COMMITTEE WEBSITE OR
THE COMEDIAN PANDEMIC EMERGENCY
RESPONSE WEBSITE IF YOU HAVE
MORE EXPENSIVE- COMMENTS THAT
YOU WISH TO MAKE. SO WITH THAT-
WE'RE GONNA START OFF WITH A
CENTER- IT WILL START OFF WITH
CENTER WIENER- FOLLOWED BY
CENTER CABRIO. CENTER WIENER
OKAY AND OKAY GREAT HUNDRED I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF THE
COMMITTEES FOR COMMITTING A
SERIES OF YOU FORGET TO MY-
REMARKS AND QUESTIONS PURSUE
THIS YEAR ARE. MISTER CHAIRMAN
I DO IT'S JUST A QUESTION ON
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IS NOT PRESENT AT
THIS YEAR. ALTHOUGH WE ARE
FOCUS ON CDCR AND DRUGS.
CONDITIONS IN THE PRISONS I
TRANSFER SIZE OBVIOUSLY THIS IS
FUNDAMENTALLY. A PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUE AND I WOULD. LOVE TO HEAR
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH WHAT IT
THANKS. WHAT IS YOURS DURING
WITHIN THE FACILITIES AND
STUDENTS ARE INVOLUNTARY
DECISIONS TO SIGNS. OUR INMATES
WHEN THEY'RE RELEASED TO GREAT
AGENCY I USE. THAT IS A KNOWN
SPREADER. YOU SHOULD SEE- SO
CAN I JUST ASK- WHITE SEA KIDS
HERE I'LL GO THERE IN BY. A
CENTER WIENER I UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY WERE IN FOR- AND THAT
VENTURE THE- TO APPEAR BEFORE
COMMITTEE- I DO I CAN'T SPEAK
FOR THEM- IS TO- SO I THINK
WE'LL- CERTAINLY WE WILL WE
SHOULD. PURSUES FIND OUT WHY
BUT- OF- INDICATE THEY WERE
INVITED AND IN THE END THEY
DECLINED TO APPEAR BEFORE AT
THIS HEARING. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M NOT
CRITICIZING INTIMIDATES ANYWAY
I KNOW THEY WERE INVITED. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THEY DID SOME
RATIONALE THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER ARE YOU SIR
SOMEONE TOPICS THEY ARE
INVOLVED WITH CDCR AND SO I
THINK IT'S COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE. CDPH THIS IS. A
CLASSIC. FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUES SORT OF PUT THAT ON ONE
RECORD. SO I AM I HAVE SOME
QUESTION FOR HONEST AND YOU SEE
OUR ARMS WITH YOU I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR. LAYING OUT QUITE
CLEARLY ASSIDUOUS YOURS ARE
PROCESS AND POLICIES ARE FOR
TURNING PEOPLE OVER. ARE YOU
CENTER LAST OVERSIGHT HEARING
ON THIS ISSUE CDC ARE ALMOST
MADE IT SEEM LIKE- YOU KNOW.
THAT WAS JUST RANDOM
COINCIDENCE THEY WOULD RELEASE
ELSE WOULD BE THERE BOB IMPACT
PERSON UP AND IT TOOK SOME WORK
TO GET YOU STARTED ACTUALLY.
THAT THAT WAS NOT THE CASE I.
YOUR CLEARLY. LAID OUT AND SORT
OF- FREEZE OR CLOSE ACCORDING
YOU- SUMMIT IT'S CALL IT'S OLD
BE THAT'S- I USE ABOUT WHETHER
SOMEONE OUT- I WOULD DISAGREE
WITH THAT IT'S ACTUALLY CCAR'S
DECISION WALDRON FORM ICE IN
THE FIRST PLACE- BUT SEEMS LIKE
SIX YARDERS TRANSFORMERS.
TRANSFERRING EDITORI. I CAN YOU
STATED ARE. BASE TO START
COMPLY WITH ICE REQUESTS FOR
INTERVIEWS- AND THAT'S
VOLUNTARY- ARE YOU SEE ARE
FACILITATES THE TRANSFER OF
CUSTODY- WHICH I AGREE AT THE
OUTSET CDCR IS DOING SIX YARDS
ABSOLUTELY FACILITATING THE
TRANSFER WHILE WORKING I USE
AND- BASS WERE TURNING SOMEONE
OVER IN A PLACE ONCE A PERSON.
ON AND THEN STEVEN GARCIA
SERVICE COOPERATING WITH ICE IN
THIS SIMILAR WAY THAT A WORD
WITH OTHER. LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES. I SO ON ARTS YOU YOU
WERE OUR WAY YOU AGREE WITH ME
THAT- AND I THINK WE STOP THIS
THE LAST YEAR BUT WE SURE
YOU'RE I READ THAT CDC. HAS
ABSOLUTELY NO LEGAL OBLIGATION
TO COOPERATE WITH ICE TURNED TO
NOTIFY USED TO FACILITATE
TRANSFERS TO HAND PEOPLE OVER
TO ALLOW USE OF TO COME
INTERVIEW PEOPLE WOULD YOU
AGREE WITH THAT THAT CCR HAS NO
LEGAL OBLIGATION. TO DO ANY OF
THAT. THIS AND ARE IN OUR
INTERVIEW IS DIFFERENT AND PER
PENAL CODE SECTION FIVE AND
FIVE ZERO TWO SIX. IT MANDATES
THE DEPARTMENT COORDINATE WITH
ICE AND COOPERATE WITH ICE. SO
YOU TAKE YOUR SEATS ARE IS NOW
STATING THAT YOU BELIEVE THAT
YOU ARE LEGALLY REQUIRED TO.
ALL RIGHT SIR DO USE YOUR- IN
YOU REQUIRED TO ALERT ICE ONE
SOMEONE IS A TO BE REAL. WE ARE
WORK TO COOPER WITH ICE AND
COORDINATE WITH THEM. WHERE WE
NEED LAWN AGENCY BY YOU SEE
QUOC AND COORDINATE BUT ARE YOU
LEGAL REQUIRE. TO NOTIFY. BUT
SOMEONE IS GOING TO BE RELEASE.
IT IS OUR INTERPRETATION THAT
YES WE ARE. OKAY I THINK
THERE'S A LO OF PEOPLE MYSELF
INCLUDED DISAGREE WITH THAT
STATEMENT- INCLUDING A FORMER
SECRETARY DOING DOLLARS IN THE
LAST HEARING THAT. THIS IS
ACTIONS WERE VOLUNTARY BY
STUDENTS SHARKS SO IS IT IS IT-
THE CITIZENS UCR'S POSITION BUT
THE AGENCY HAS LEGALLY
REQUIRED. TO ALLOW. REZENDES
ENTER. BECAUSE YES IT IS
PROCEDURES ARE YOUR VOICE OR
LEGALLY REQUIRED TO DO THAT.
YES UNDER STATE LAW. UNDER
STATE LAW. K. AND IS IT OUR
STUDENTS JAHRES DECISION THE
AGENCY HAS LEGAL WAIVER UNDER
STATE LAW SOPHISTIC TWO FOR THE
TRANSFER OF CUSTODY. SO I GUESS
IF I SAW TO PURSUE. IT'S OURS
TO ICE THE OF YOUR REALLY
STATES IT'S UP TO SOMEONE OR
NOT CHOOSE TO PICK UP THE
INTERN. BUT IT SURE IF I YEAH
WE WILL THIS YOU BILLIONS
STUDENTS YOU ARE OVER IT
LEGALLY REQUIRED. TO FACILITATE
A WITH UP REQUEST IS OUR
CURRENT PROCEDURES AND POLICIES
YES. OKAY AT I SO YOU REFERRED
TO. CODE. WHAT YOU SAID SIR
POLICIES OF RISKY FOR YOU
YOU'RE GOING LEGAL REQUIRED AS
WELL THE SAME. CAN OKAY. ZERO
TWO SIX. ELMIRA IS THAT STILL
CORRECT FIVE ZERO TWO SIX IS
ABOUT TEN DEPORTS. HEARINGS I'M
NOT. AS TRANSFER. SO IF SOMEONE
DOESN'T HAVE A CERTAIN COULD
YOU CALL. EXACTLY WHAT YOU MEAN
BY HOW. ZERO FOUR FIVE OR ITS
USE APPLY HERE. SO WE ARE RISK
TO NOTE THEM AND CALL THEN
PROVIDE GENERAL IS NEEDED SO IN
THAT SUPPORT HOW ABOUT LONG RE
THAT'S WHAT OUR IS AND HOW WE
COOPERATE WITH ICE. SO YOU CAN
YOU JUST GENERALLY HOW AN
OBLIGATION TO DO WHAT I SAYS IN
TERMS OF SOMEONE THAT I SPENT
THE INTERESTED IN. WE'RE
FOLLOWING OUR POWER AND
DOWNTURN. THAT WE DO. WITH ALL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
INCLUDING. AND YOU AND IS THERE
IS THERE ANY LIKE ANYTHING THAT
ARE USING THE LOGS ON REQUIRE
SEEDS YOU'RE TO IN TERMS OF
DOING WHAT I USE S. U. ZERO OR
WHAT IS LIMITATION. JUST DOING
WHAT. WHATEVER I SAYS OR OR OR
THERE LIMITS. THAT'S NOT WHAT I
WAS RUN TO AND- I DO WHAT OUR
POLICIES PER ARE HOW WE WITH
ICE AND THEN I AND I EXPLAIN
HOW WE WITH ICE. OKAY I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE PAUL.
AND PROCEDURES ARE AND I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE- PRODUCT
YOU'RE OUT DOING BECAUSE PEOPLE
ARE BEING OVER- BUT I'M I'M
STILL- IN TERMS OF THE LEGALLY
ALL WE- TO DO THAT- I THOUGHT
THIS IS VERY TO BUT WHAT'S
YOURS TO US LAST TIME. FOUR
RESEARCH SENATOR VOLUNTARY THIS
AND NOT. CURRENTLY THAT'S WHAT
WE ARE FOLLOWING. NOW THIS
ARTISTS- ARTISTIC THE STUDENTS
HERE ARE IN ANY WY- R. I'M
HOLDING ONE SECOND. NO I GUESS
YOU JUST PULLED UP SEARCHING
FIVE OH TWO SEX- IT NOT SAY
ANYTHING ABOUT NOTIFY ICE. SO I
THINK THAT. SOMETHING IT IS TO
RETENTION. SINCE TO BE A BROAD
AS SOMEONE COULD POP STRETCH A
LOT OF BEYOND HELP BROAD THE
SECTIONS IS NOT ABOUT. NO ICE-
SO THAT SEEMS GO BEYOND THE
SCOPE THE STOCK YOUR. DO YOU
DISAGREE THAT. IT ALSO STATES
THAT WE ARE COOPER WITH ICE SO
I THINK THERE'S A I AGREE WITH
YOU THAT THERE CAN BE A BROWN
IN TERMS. OF WHAT COOPERATION
MEANS. YEAH I'M JUST ORANGE
LOOKING AT THIS I DON'T THINK
THAT'S REALLY UP TO SEARCH. SO.
I JUST I JUST DISAGREE-
DESTRUCTION. COME CDCR. TWO THE
SOUL TO TURN PEOPLE OVER- SO.
DOES SHE IS YOUR ARE YOU LOOK
AT ALL ABOUT YOUR WE HEARD WE
JUST HEARD ABOUT THE YOU KNOW I
USED TO IT. THIS FORMER GLOBAL
SPREADER USING IT'S TRANSFERRED
PEOPLE AROUND THE SO AMONG
STATES. AND COUNTRYAND THE ARE
JUST. CENTER SHE. I'M TO-
OFFICER THE HOUSE PROGRAM FOR
SACRAMENTO BY. VERIFYING THE
STANDARDS OF THE FACILITY IN
JAIL IS OUTSIDE OF THIS
JURISTIC OF C. C. R. WE ALL
CANNOT RETAIN- INMATES PASS
THEIR RELEASEDATE AND MUST
HONOR LAUNCH HOLDS ONE AND
DETAIN. OKAY I DON'T AGREE YOU
HAVE TO THIS IS RICK BUT YOU
DON'T LOOK AT THAT- OUR- I DO
YOU ARE. AND YOU ARE THANK YOU
DON'T YOU'RE ANYWAY TRACK
WHETHER YOU'RE SO PEOPLE
WHETHER THESE PEOPLE COME OVER
ONCE I GOT ICE ONE SINCE- IS
THERE ANY TO DETERMINE IF IT
BECOMES WHEN I GO TO THE
MISSILE. SO KNOW THERE'S A
PROBLEM BABIES WERE TO
REEVALUATE. I AM AWARE OF ANY.
THAT GOES REGARDING THAT. HE.
NOW YOU MAY REFERENCE ON SELECT
OR COREY. CITY BY CITY SIERRA
YES. OKAY- HOW DO YOU DETERMINE
IF SOMEONE IS FOREIGN BORN. WE
REVIEW IT ON EITHER LEGAL
DOCUMENTS THEIR RAP SHEETS ARE
CRIMINAL HISTORY RAP SHEET-
THAT FENDER IS ALSO AND ASKED
IF THERE ARE FOREIGN BORN AND
SO THEY MAY PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION TO US. AND IF I USE
FOR. TO SEE YOUR MAKING TERM OF
WHETHER THE YOU CAN. ANY COLOR
YEAH BASIS EVERY. SURPRISED WE
WANT THAT PERSON JUST SAY OKAY
COME READ COMING UP AND WE
NOTIFIED YOU THEY WERE FOR BORN.
YOU SAY YOU'RE THE- COMING UP
OF THE SONGS US ANY THOUGHT.
ANALYSIS TIME ABOUT WHETHER
ISIS ACTUAL BUSINESS ASK FOR A
PERSON. SO THERE FOR THE ICE
REQUIRE TO COME TO A WARRANT ON
THE HOME TO PAY SIX ME TO PUT
IT TO TAKE ON THE GENDER. AND
WHEN THEY COMPLETED THE FORMS
AND LET AND SENT US TO US. AND
WE REVIEW THEM IF ALL THEIR
PROBE- CIGNA OR THE- THEN WE
PLACE A DETAINER THE F. AND-
THIRD CALPERS SIGNATURES ARE
ARABIC YOU LOOK AT WHETHER THEY.
NOT ALL STOP BY WELL I WANNA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
PATIENCE IS REALLY IMPORTANT
THIS IS ABOUT LIFE AND DEATH. I
THINK THAT WHAT- CCR IS DOING
IN TERMS OF OUR FACILITATES
NOTIFY YOUR FACILITATING THESE
TRANSFERS ARE USED- IS
OUTRAGEOUS. I THINK IT IS IN
HUMANE PARTICULAR DURING THIS
PANDEMIC TO GO ALONG WE KNOW
THAT THESE ARE USED PRIVATE
PRISONS DETENTION FACILITIES
ARE COATED HOT BEDS. WE AS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT
BE SENDING PEOPLE OVER THESE
ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE COMPLETED
THEIR PRISON TERMS THEY HAVE
DONE THEIR TIME. HE TURNED OUT
TO SOCIETY WE SHOULD BE RE
INTEGRATING THEM INTO OUR
COMMUNITY I'M NOT. EXACERBATING
THIS TRAUMA BY BY BY THE
HEATING. AGENCY OF IT ARE YOU
SAID IS STILL BROKEN- AND THAT
FRANKLY IT HAS DONE A HORRIFIC
JOB PROTECTING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PEOPLE IN ITS
CUSTODY AND WE ARE FACILITATING
SENDING PEOPLE. INTO THAT
SYSTEM WHETHER OR NOT THE
PERSON IS ACTUALLY THE
PORTABLE. AND I HAVE TO THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME I'VE EVER HEARD
CDCR EXPRESSED BY THE AGENCY.
IT IS LEGALLY OBLIGATED TO DO
BASICALLY ANYTHING BUT ICE ASKS
THAT THE DEVICE IF I JUST ASK
FOR SOMEONE. BEN BEN EIGHT
GRAMS UCR'S SAYING WE'RE
OBLIGATED TO NOTIFY THEM TO
SOLITARY DO ALL THESE THINGS TO
MAKE SURE THAT I JUST ABOUT WHO
OVER THAT ONE. THAT IS NOT SIT
WELL WITH ME I THINK IT IS
OUTRAGEOUS- AND WORK IT OUT BOB
YOU LEADING DISCO THIS IS JUST
WRONG. IT USE THE STOCK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER WIENER AT
APPRECIATE YOUR- I WOULD JUST
BRIEFLY NOTE THE- I TO IN THIS.
BY THE IDEA THAT WE HAVE. WHERE
ARE THE PART PUBLIC HEALTH
THERE'S QUESTIONS A KEEN EYE GO
AND CHECK OUT AND SURE THERE'S-
AND- YOU. AT THE SAME TIME
WE'RE HAVING BECAUSE CCR
ACTIVELY TRANSFER PEOPLE.
WHETHER THEY SHOULD GO THERE IN
THE FIRST PLACE AND THAT'S ONE
QUESTION BUT CERTAINLY NOT INTO
AN UNSAFE ENVIRONMENT. SO I
APPRECIATE THAT. SO WE HAVE
LINED UP FOR SPEAKERS SUFFER
SERRA CAPIO DENSER GONZALEZ SO
CENTER CAPIO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR I THINK THAT
ISSUE FOR ME IS WHETHER-
WHETHER OUR STATION WE USE FOR
THESE DETENTION FACILITIES IN
THE FIRST PLACE- AND- I KNOW
THERE'S SOME. CONSTITUTIONAL
ISSUES ABOUT- OR SEPARATION
BETWEEN FEDERAL AUTHORITY IN IN
OUR OWN BUT- I THINK GIVEN THE
WAY AGENCIES DID PRIVATE
DEPENDENT DE DETENTION
FACILITIES HAVE BEEN OPERATING
AND- A LACK OF TRANSPARENCY AND
THE ABILITY TO REALLY EVEN
KNOW. HOW PEOPLE ARE BEING
TREATED THERE HAS LONGBEEN AN
ISSUE FOR ME BUT- I WE DO HAVE
TO GET TO PUBLIC COMMENTS I'M
GONNA BE VERY VERY BRIEF AND
JUST SAY THAT- I APPRECIATE I
ALSO APPRECIATE THE DETAIL- BY-
CHIEF DIXON I WAS VERY HELPFUL
JUST TO GET IT ALL LAID OUT IN
TERMS OF THE PROCESS. I MEAN I
WON IT- THANK AND RECOGNIZE AND
CHECK ON BOND FOR HIS TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY FOR SHARING HIS
STORY SO THAT WE CAN
UNDERSTAND- THE PERSPECTIVE OF-
THAT THAT'S VERY FAMILIAR TO ME
HAVE OF REFUGEES COMING INTO
THE COUNTRY AND TRYING TO-
ASSIMILATING IN FACING. FACING
SO MANY CHALLENGES SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
SHARING. YOUR STORY- AND THEN
IN REGARDS TO THE BOTH THE-
MISS A LOT LANGRIDGE. LET
LANGER ECA- AND- MISSED I CAN
MEET PLOT IF YOU COULD GET US-
THAT- ONE IS THE ANY LEGAL
INTERPRETATION THAT YOU'VE GOT
IN REGARDS TO- THE RELATIONSHIP
THAT YOU FILL. OUT THE STATE
SHOULD HAVE WITH- OUT BETWEEN-
OUR DETENTION FACILITIES IN ANY
PRIVATE FACILITIES- THAT ARE
THAT ARE I SUGGEST THAT IS THAT
WOULD BE GREAT AND THE HEALTH
IMPACTS- SOME OF THIS
INFORMATION IS NEW TO ME AND
I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SEE- ANY
OF THAT THIS STUDY THAT YOU.
YOU REFERENCED- IT'S SERIOUS
STUFF AND IF WE WANT. PEOPLE TO
BE HEALTHY IN OUR COMMUNITIES
IT'S UNDERSTANDING WHAT WHAT
KIND OF PREVENTION MEASURES WE
NEED TO UNDERTAKEN WHAT KIND OF
CHANGES WE NEED TO MAKE TO THE
SYSTEM SO. I WOULD APPRECIATE
IF YOU COULD- GIVE US. AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT THAT
INFORMATION THE FUTURE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THAT'S ALL MISTER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR HELLO
GOOD. YES THANK YOU- MISTER
THINK FOR OF THE PANEL FOR YOUR
VERY- COMPREHENSIVE. DO YOU IN
YOUR RESPECTIVE ROLES I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT I AM VERY MUCH-
I TO A VERY CONCERNED I'M GONNA
ADD MY VOICE TO MY COLLEAGUES
BOTHSENATOR WIENER AND-
SENATOR PAN- AND HOW WE CAN
SORT OF WASH YOUR HANDS OF THIS
THIS ISSUE- THE FIRST QUESTION
I WILL- DIRECTED COURSES DID
SHE DICKS AND- I'M WONDERING
BECAUSE- UNFORTUNATELY CDPH DID
NOT ATTEND AND WE WERE REALLY
LOOKING FOR IT I'M- TENDING I
THINK THAT'S AN ADDITIONAL
LAYER. THAT IN MY OPINION THERE
NEEDS TO BE OVERSIGHT AS WELL
IN TERMS OF THE CONDITIONS NOT
JUST IN OUR CURRENT PRESENTS
BUT ALSO DETENTION CENTERS IF
WE ARE TRANSFERRING FOLKS
WHETHER WE BELIEVE. IT OR NOT-
THERE SHOULD BE AN AT AND OVER
OF. OUR LOCAL AGENCIES ARE KIND
OF MANAGING AND LOOKING AT THE
DETENTION CENTERS WERE
TRANSFERRING PEOPLE TO. I'M
HAPPY TO BE IN L. A. COUNTY
WHERE THERE IS ACTUALLY A PLAN
THAT WAS INSTITUTED IN APRIL
BUT NOT EVERY COUNTY IS DOING
THAT. SO I'M WONDERING I GUESS
MY QUESTION CHU CHU SIX DIXON
IS. ARE THERE ANY DISCUSSIONS
WITH CD P. H. AS YOU'RE
ENGAGING IN THESE TRANSFERS
WHICH WE BELIEVE ARE VOLUNTARY
YOU SEEM TO BELIEVE AND
INTERPRET DIFFERENTLY. AND HOW
TO. AS YOU'RE SENDING THESE
CALIFORNIANS OVER. THAT THEY
ARE UNSAFE I MEAN THAT IS THERE
ANY WORK BEING DONE OR
DISCUSSION WITH CD PH ON THE
ARM. MAYBE DETENTION CENTERS.
PROVIDING PLANS SO WHAT AT
LEAST WE KNOW IT STATE.
COMPLETELY DISAGREE WITH THE
TRANSFER PROCESS BUT AT LEAST
ENSURING THAT THESE DETENTION
CENTERS HAVE SOME SORT OF.
PARTICLES IF THERE IS I'M NOT
AWARE OF ANY BUT THAT WOULD BE
A LITTLE OUT OF MY SCOPE OF
WHAT MY KNOWLEDGE AND
RESPONSIBILITY IS SO I'M NOT
AWARE. BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THERE ISN'T ANYTHING I JUST I
AM NOT AWARE OF ANYTHING. OKAY
SO I THINK THAT JUST LEADS US
TO BELIEVE THAT AGAIN WHEN WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
TRANSFERS IT SEEMS AS THOUGH
WE'RE WASHING OUR HANDS OF DATA
WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHO- IS
BEING TRANSFERRED WE DON'T
KNOW. WHO HAS- NINETEEN- WHICH
DETENTION CENTERS ARE WORSE OFF
THAN OTHERS IT SEEMS LIKE
THEY'RE ALL HORRENDOUS
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE NO PLANS
FOR WHEN YOU'RE TRANSFERRING
FOLKS THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS HAVE NO IDEAS WE
KNOW THESE CALIFORNIANS ARE
JUST BEING TRANSFERRED. IN A
VERY DIRE SITUATION- MY ANOTHER
QUESTION I HAVE IS. RELATED TO
AND I DON'T BELIEVE YOU IT.
ADDRESS THIS BUT- FOLKS WHO ARE
YOU KNOW IN THE INMATES AND
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE MEDICALLY
FRAGILE IF THERE'S ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT. IN THE
DISCUSSION OF TRANSFERRING IF
YOU ARE COOPERATING TO YOUR
INTERPRETATION WITH ICE. IS
THERE ANY COMPASSION OR
CONSIDERATION FOR INMATESWHO
MIGHT BE THAT MEDICALLY BACK
FRAGILE YOU'RE PUTTING THEM IN
AN EVEN WORSE ENVIRONMENT. I
CAN TELL YOU THAT- ICE AND
OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
AS WELL WILL SOMETIMES ASK FOR
MAYBE CO GOOD INFORMATION OR
MEDICAL INFORMATION REGARDING
OUR OFFENDERS AND THAT IS
PROVIDED TO THEM BY OUR BY THE
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES AT THE
INSTITUTION. AND IN SOME CASES-
ICE OR AND ANOTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY ME CHOOSE
NOT TO PICK UP THAT OFFENDER.
OKAY IF THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
YOU'RE WELCOME- AND IF ATTORNEY
LANDRY GOT OR IS DIRECTOR PIATT
HAS ANY ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
TO ADD ON TO THIS WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE- IT
AGAIN CLEARLY WE'RE- ON THE
SAME TEACHER IN TERMS OF THE
TRANSFERS AND THEY WERE EXACTLY
WE- DON'T WANT TO HEAD- SO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO ADD ANYTHING ELSE
YOU'D- LIKE TO HEAR THAT. THANK
YOU SENATOR GONZALEZ I CAN
START AND THEN I CAN PASS IT
OVER TO AND BURKE. JUST FIRST
TO ADDRESS YOU KNOW CONNECTIONS
FIVE ZERO TWO SIX EIGHT MY
READING IS THE SAME AS AS THAT
OF SENATOR WIENER IS A SAD FACT
THAT PEOPLE COULD REALLY
ADDRESSES. ONGOING REMOVAL
PROCEEDINGS THAT SOMETIMES CAN
HAPPEN WHILE PEOPLE ARE STILL
INSTITUTIONALIZED IN CDCR
CUSTODY IT MENTIONS. OF THE L.
SOULS IT DOES NOT MEAN TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT MANDATORY
COMPLIANCE WITH HOLDS
NOTIFICATIONS OR FACILITATION
OF TRANSFERS. IF THE READING
WERE AS EXPENSIVE AS MYSTICS
AND HAS- SHARE WITH US TODAY.
THAT WOULD CERTAINLY BE IN
CONFLICT WITH UPDATED GUIDANCE
AND CDCR I BELIEVE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I'M THAT
PROHIBITS HOLDS- YOU KNOW A
START READING WERE RIGHT AND IT
WOULD IT WOULD CERTAINLY
CONFLICT TO SEE TO SEE OUR OWN
GUIDANCE. AND A SENATOR WIENER
POINTED OUT I WOULD CDCR IS-
ALONE. HAD TESTIMONY ONE OF
THESE HEARINGS. THE SECOND AB.
WINDOW MAKE IS THAT YOU KNOW
I'M REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SORT OF OBSCURITY AND THAT THEY
INDEED SEEMINGLY INTENTIONAL
CONFLATION BETWEEN POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES. AND LAWS THOSE ARE
TWO DIFFERENT THINGS POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES DOES NOT MEAN
THAT SOMETHING IS LAWFUL AND IN
FACT WE'VE SEEN. DURING THIS
PANDEMIC THAT A LOT OF THEM ARE
UNLAWFUL I'M A IN SO I AM I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE NUMBERS
ABOUT THE OBSCURITY. I AND THEN
IT. I SORRY THAT IF THAT IT
READ WHERE IS OUR MISTAKES IN
IT EXPANDS READING WERE CORRECT
I THINK THAT WOULD INCOMES WITH
THE INSTANCE THAT WE WILL A
PEOPLE WHO NOT TRANSFERRED
PEOPLE FOR WHOM CDCR DOES NOT
FACILITATE TRANSFER NOTIFY ICE
AND THEY'RE REALLY STATE SO I
WHOLLY DISAGREE WITH STICKS IN
THE READING OF THAT STATUTE IN
A- A ENCOURAGED SEAT THE
COMMITTEE AND ALL THE SENATORS
CONTINUE LOOKING INTO THAT.
MYSKINA FIAT. I'LL JUST ADD I
WANT TO PROTECT AS MUCH TIME AS
POSSIBLE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT SO
I AM HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH
YOUR OFFICES- SENATOR GONZALEZ
AND CENTER COUPLE YOU DON'T
WITH MORE INFORMATION ON THE
HEALTH IMPACT RESEARCH THAT WE
HAVE TO ENSURE THAT YOU'RE
FULLY EQUIPPED WITH THE HEALTH
RESEARCH THAT WE HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO BE MAKING THESE
DECISIONS AND MOVING TOWARD
STOPPING ICE TRANSFERS FOR
EVERYBODY. THANK YOU AND-
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANTED TO
THINK- BOTH OF THEM- CHEAP
DIXON AS WELL AS WELL AS
CHAMPION BOND- HAVING A VERY
LARGE CAMBODIAN COMMUNITY. I'M
VERY GLAD THAT YOU'RE HERE TO
SPEAK IN TESTIMONY AND YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AS WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
CENTER GONZALEZ SENATE JACKSON.
IT'S LIKE IT'S JUST BEEN A VERY
INTERESTING DISCUSSION AND IT-
I TO SURE- SOME FRUSTRATION. ON
THAT WE'VE HEARD NOW DIFFERENT-
INTERPRETATIONS OF WHAT THE
STATE'S RESPONSIBILITIES ARE
WITH RESPECT TO ICE- I RECALL
IT BEING FAIRLY CLEAR IN
HEARINGS THAT WE'VE AD OVER
THE COURSE OF THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS. THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. DOES NOT SEE ITSELF
AS AN EXTENSION OF ICE OR THE-
A HORRIFIC EFFORTS THAT WE SEEN
FRANKLY- BY PARTICULAR THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION- TO-
REMOVE PEOPLE FROM THIS
COUNTRY- AND I THINK THAT WE
HAVE MADE IT. CLEAR IN OUR
PUBLIC- SAFETY COMMITTEE
HEARINGS AND OTHERWISE SO I
WOULD LIKE- TO ASK THE
COMMITTEE IS COMMITTEE- GOING
FORWARD TO PLEASE. CONSIDER AND
I HOPE YOU WILL- DOING SOME
MORE OVERSIGHT OVER THE WAY-
CDC. INTERPRETS ALL OR BELIEVES
ITS RESPONSIBILITIES ARE- WITH
RESPECT TO- AND PROVIDING
INFORMATION TO ICE- WORKING
WITH ICE- YOU KNOW WE HAVE DONE
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO LIMIT
ICE'S- ACTIVITIES WITHIN OUR
COURT HOUSES FOR EXAMPLE EVEN
THE CHIEF JUSTICE. MADE A VERY
STRONG STATEMENT IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BECAUSE IT DOES IMPACT
OUR ABILITY. TO DISPENSE
JUSTICE PROPERLY- WHEN PEOPLE
ARE AFRAID THEY WON'T COME TO
COURT- FOR FEAR THAT ICE IS
THERE WAITING TO BE PLUCKED
THEM OFF- WE HAVE REQUIREMENTS
NOW THAT. PEOPLE- WHEN THEY ARE
IN A COURTROOM AND THE QUESTION
ABOUT THEIR CITIZENSHIP FOR
THEIR LAWFUL A PART OF
PARTICIPATION HERE COMES INTO
QUESTION THAT THEY WILL THEN BE
ARE PERMITTED TO HAVE AN IN
CAMERA PROCEEDING SO THAT THE
PUBLIC ITSELF DOESN'T
NECESSARILY GET TO HERE- JUST
WHAT THEIR STATUS IS. I MEAN
THE FACT THAT CDCR SAYS THAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO COOPERATE I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO BE EXAMINED AND I AND I
APPRECIATE CENTER WINNER YOU
ARE CALLING ATTENTION TO THAT
AND CERTAINLY- GIVEN GIVEN WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED ABOUT THE
HORRIFIC INHUMANE TREATMENT. OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE ABSOLUTELY
INCARCERATED SHE ONLY WAY YOU
CAN DESCRIBE IT- IN THE SIZE
FACILITIES I THINK THAT IS
CONTRARY TO THE SPIRIT AND THE
INTENT TO AND PROBABLY IF I'M
NOT MISTAKEN THE ACTUAL LETTER
OF THE LAW HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND IF IT'S NOT. THEN I SUGGEST
THAT WE TAKE ANOTHER VIEW AND
REQUIRE- MORE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND OVERSIGHT OF CDC ARE- AS IT
INTERPRETS THE LAWS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MAKES AND DOES
CERTAINLY HAVE A MORE ROBUST
DISCUSSION- SO. I AM. I AM
HOPEFUL THAT GOING FORWARD THIS
IS BEEN A MEANINGFUL
OPPORTUNITY TO IDENTIFY JUST
EXACTLY THE EXTENT TO WHICH-
CDC ARE OPERATES- WITH RESPECT
TO THESE ISSUES AND FRANKLY
OTHERS I KIND. AND VERY
UNSETTLED BY THE FACT THAT
THERE WERE EIGHT THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHO IDENTIFIED AS
ELIGIBLE FOR EARLY RELEASE LOW
RISK OFFENDERS AT CENTER AND A
WHOLE EIGHTY WERE GRANTED THAT-
EARLY RELEASE I MEAN THAT WE'RE
C. COUNT ABILITY HERE. SO I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE THAT
COMMENT DESAI- RIGHT OFF INTO
THE SUNSET- AND- I APPRECIATE
THE EFFORTS OF THE PEOPLE
WORKING WITH. CDC ARE IT'S A
CULTURE. THAT I WE NEED X. AND
I AND I KNOW THE PEOPLE THERE
PARTICULAR PEOPLE BEEN ON
TODAY- DO CARE DEEPLY ARE THERE
DO TRYING TO DO THEIR BEST BUT
I THINK THIS IS AN AREA WHERE
WE REALLY NEED TO EXAMINE THE
CULTURE OF CDC ARE- CAN AND ASK
OURSELVES WHETHER THIS IS. THE
WAY WE WANTED TO PROCEED IN THE
FUTURE. SO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN OPPORTUNITIES. THANK
YOU CENTER JACKSON- IT JUST. I
ACTUALLY JUST WANTED TO GIVE-
MISTER BOND- PERHAPS ONE FINAL
OPPORTUNITY IF THERE WAS
ANYTHING ELSE HE WANTED TO
SHARE ABOUT HIS STORY I KNOW I
HAD TO CUT HIM OFF BECAUSE OF
TIME LIMITS BUT- MISTER BUNDY
G. WAS THERE ANY FINAL REMARK
THAT YOU WANT TO MAKE ABOUT
YOUR EXPERIENCE THAT YOU
WEREN'T ABLE TO MAKE BECAUSE I
HAVE TO. I PUT A TIME LIMIT.
YES THANK YOU- I JUST WANTED TO
SAY THAT. BLOOM. I WAS FACING
DEATH IT WILL BE I WOULD
TRANSFER TO THE DETENTION
CENTER IN ICE AND WITH THE HELP
OF THE COMMUNITY MY COMMUNITY
WAS READY FOR ME AND THEY WERE
TO ONE NOT CITY C. R. OR ICE
THAT TESTED ME FOR A TEST THE
ME AND HELP ME HEAL FROM COAL
BIT AND THAT ALL ALL THE PEOPLE
WORK IN. TRANSFER TO AYE AYES
ARE IN DANGER OF THEIR LIFE AND
LIKE EVERY I LIKE WHAT I HEARD
IS. WE ARE PLAYING WITH
PEOPLE'S LIVES HERE AND I ASKED
THE- WE SUPPORT. THE ENTERPRISE
TRANSFER AND DIRECT TRANSFER.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
LINE. RIGHT SEEING NO OTHER
QUESTIONS- WE'RE GONNA PREPARE
TO MOVE THE PUBLIC COMMENT BUT
BEFORE WE MOVE THE PUBLIC
COMMENT THIS IS ONE OF THE LAST
HEARINGS ON FRIDAY HAVE THIS
SESSION I KNOW THERE'S ONE MORE
EXAM CHURNING ANOTHER ONE
BEFORE WE OF SWEARING IN BUT I
CERTAINLY WANT TO RECOGNIZE. I
THINK THREE OF MY COLLEAGUES
WHO WILL BE LEAVING THE-
SENATE. AFTER BY THE END AT THE
END OF THE SESSION. AND THANK
THEM SO MUCH FOR SERVICE SO. I
WANT TO RECOGNIZE OUR MORLOCK
IS HERE WITH ME CHAMBER THANK
YOU SO MUCH. IT'S CERTAINLY IN
JOINT WORKING WITH YOU- ALSO
CENTER JACKSON. WHO I KNOW HAS
SPOKEN THERE THANK YOU CENTER
JACKSON. AND THEN- CENTER
MITCHELL WHO- CONGRATULATIONS
ON HER SUCCESS AND- SO. AGAIN
THIS I DON'T KNOW IF SHE'S ON
RIGHT NOW OR NOT BUT- WISHING
HER THE BEST IN HER NEW
POSITION OVER AND THAT THE L.
A. COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
SITES ONLY ONE RECOGNIZE EACH
OF YOU BEFORE WE CONCLUDE THIS
HEARING. SO WITH THAT LET'S
MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT- DO
CONSTRAINTS. THE LENGTH OF
HEARING SIGNAL G.
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. WE ARE INSTITUTING A
ONE MINUTE LIMIT ON TESTIMONY
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT- LET'S BEGIN
WITH WITNESSES HERE IN THE
GALLERY- SELLER TO COMMENTS
FROM THE GALLERY. RIGHT IS-
THEIR MICROPHONE WHICH THE
WITNESSES WILL BE SPEAKING AT.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. THAT ARE A YES
IT IS ALL RIGHT HIGH-
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A NICE
ADDITIONAL MINUTES BECAUSE I'M
LEARNING DISABLED AND I HAVE TO
READ SOMETHING- WELL IT SAYS
FORTUNATELY I WILL GIVE YOU A
LITTLE LATITUDE BUT- I DO WE
WANT TO BE CONSISTENT WITH
EVERYONE SO BUT YOU CAN PLEASE
START OFF BY INTRODUCING
YOURSELF I'M SURE THE FOR
PEOPLE WON'T MIND IN EVERY
COLLEGE IN THE COUNTRY GIVES
ME. ADDITIONAL TIME THAT'S HOW
I WAS ABLE TO GRADUATE. HI YOU
ARE USING OF YOUR MINUTE RIGHT
NOW. SENATOR PER AND I HEARD
YOU TALKING LAST TIME I WAS
HERE. ABOUT CHILDREN'S RIGHT TO
AN EDUCATION. THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO AN
EDUCATION. OBVIOUSLY YOU WERE
THINKING ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT WOULD YOU.
PLEASE ENTER TWO SEVEN SIX
SEVEN ONE FOUR AND TWO SEVEN
SEVEN AND TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
BY KICKING CHILDREN OUT OF
SCHOOL. FOR NOT BEING
VACCINATED. BY TELLING THEM
THEY HAD NO RELIGIOUS RECEPTION
NO PERSONAL BELIEF. AND NO
MEDICAL EXEMPTION FOR THE
OXIDATIONS. MANDATORY
INJECTIONS. DOESN'T GET ANY
MORE ANTI AMERICAN THAN THAT.
I'VE NEVER ASKED YOU TO BE IN
CHARGE OF MY HEALTH. SB WHAT'S
KNOWN YOUR JOB IS NOT TO. NOR
THE CONSTITUTIONAL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENT.
SPEAKER. SERGEANTS. WE WILL
RECESS THIS HEARING FOR A FEW
MOMENTS THANK YOU.
THROUGH MUCH
SO WE WILL CONTINUE WITH ANY
FURTHER WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. WE HAVE ONE WITNESS IN
THE GALLERY ALL RIGHT- SO
WELCOME AND- PLEASE CAN
INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND- YOU
HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. HELLO I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO- I ASSUME THAT
INMATES HAVE THE SAME RIGHTS TO
HEALTH CARE AS FOR YOUR CALL
SORRY IF YOU CAN PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOUR ACTIVISTS. WE
HAD TO DO THAT UNDERSTANDING
FOR ALL PEOPLE IN SACRAMENTO
OKAY AND YOUR USER MIGHT YOUR
USE MY ONE MINUTE WELL I AND I
ASSUME THE INMATES HAVE THE
SAME RIGHTS AND HEALTH CARE IS
FREE CALIFORNIANS. THERE'S BEEN
DISCUSSION AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
INMATES WOULD FORCIBLY BE
TESTED FOR CODE NINETEEN BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY WILL THEY BE
FORCED TO TAKE A VACCINE FOR
COVE IT BECAUSE OF THE STATE
CAN FORCE INMATES TO TAKE
VACCINES ARE FREE CALIFORNIANS
NEXT. DON'T GET ME WRONG I HATE
TO GET SICK AND I DON'T WANT TO
GET COLD NINETEEN MORE THAN I
WANT T GET THE COMMON FLU BUT
I'M NOT SCARED TO DEATH SCARED
TO DEATH OF KOBE WHAT TERRIFIES
ME IS BEING FORCED TO TAKE A
VACCINE WHICH I DO NOT TRUST.
THEY'LL BE PLENTY OF- BRAINLESS
SHEEP OUT THERE TO TEST YOUR
NEW SUPER VACCINES BUT IN SPITE
OF WHAT WE ARE BEING TOLD I
BELIEVE THE MAJORITY OF THE
GENERAL PUBLIC INCLUDING MYSELF
DO NOT WANT TO TAKE A VACCINE.
ONE MINUTE TIME LIMIT IS
RIDICULOUS YOU OBVIOUSLY DON'T
CARE VERY MUCH. WHAT THE PEOPLE
HAVE TO SAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SEE. SCENE AND ANY
ADDITIONAL WHAT DOESN'T GALLERY.
SEEING NO OTHER WITNESS AND
GALLERY WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO.
THIS ROOM ONE TWELVE IS ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES AND ROOM
ONE TWELVE WHICH PROVIDE PUBLIC
CONDUCT. OKAY I THINK I SEE TO.
THEY CAN PLEASE COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF GIVE YOUR NAME IF YOU
HAVE AN ORGANIZATION
ORGANIZATION AND THEN- YOUR
COMMENT. WELCOME TO THE- CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE BEGIN- I
WANT TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO TELL YOU- WHICH OFFENDED I
HAVE A NOTICE OF LIABILITY HERE
BECAUSE I BELIEVE IT SAID OKAY
I DON'T THINK I'VE REDUCE OUR
SELF DETERMINATION AS WELL NOW
I WILL PROCEED. WHAT HAS SO TO
THEY HAD CRIME. DISCUSSING HOW
TO MANAGE OTHER CRIMINALS. AND
COLD IN PRISONS CRIMINALS.
CRIME COMMITTING ASSEMBLY MEN
AND WMEN WHO ARE ASSISTING IN
THE SATANIC TAKEOVER OF THE
ENTIRE WORLD. MY GOD ISN'T IT
ODD. WE HAD A RACIST POWER
ABUSING HEAD OF FILES IN
OFFICES THAT GET TO JUST SIT IN
THIS BEAUTIFUL BUILDING AND
JUST STOP ALL DAY ALMOST EVERY
DAY ABOUT HOW MUCH MORE MONEY
THEY NEED TO ESSENTIALLY BE
PAID BY US. TO CONTINUE TO
COMMIT CRIMES AGAINST HUMANITY
AGAINST US READ IT PEOPLE WILL
PAY THE BILLS WE THE PEOPLE WHO
FIND THEIR TRIPS TO MAUI WE THE
PEOPLE WHO THE CONSTITUTION WAS
WRITTEN BY AND FOR. THE PEOPLE
WHO OWN THIS HOUSE THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE CERTAIN ON ELIGIBLE
RIGHTS THAT ARE BEING AND HAVE
BEEN INFRINGED UPON SINCE THE
DAWN OF TIME THANK YOU MA'AM
YES IT IF YOU DON'T WANT TO
WEAR THE MASK IF YOU LIVE IN A
DEHUMANISE YOURSELF YOU. ONE
GET PAID IS KEPT. THANK YOU.
RIGHT NEXT WOULDN'T PLEASE.
AGAIN WOULD ASK THAT YOU
INTRODUCE YOURSELF YOUR NAME IF
YOU HAVE AN ORGANIZATION AND
THEN OF COURSE YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU WELCOME. MY NAME IS
SYDNEY AND I WAS A WHOLE LOT
MORE IF WE DIDN'T JUST GET A
MEASLY MINUTE. BUT HERE IT IS
EVERYONE WHO'S LISTENING NOW
ALL OF THE EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
JUST DOING THEIR JOBS HERE IN
THE CAPITAL AND THOSE I WILL
SEE THIS LATER ON THERE'S
SOMETHING SO MANY OF US HAVE
FORGOTTEN. THE SECOND PART OF
THE SECOND AMENDMENT. IT IS
BASICALLY THERE TO PROTECT THE
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT TO
PROTECT OUR FREEDOMS I'M NOT
TALKING ABOUT NO GUN. YOU KNOW
THE GOING TO THESE PRIVILEGE
OVERPAID PADI GUARDS TOUCH ANY
TIME I BLINK MY EYES AT THEM.
THE SECOND AMENDMENT TALKS
ABOUT THE RIGHT TO A WELL
REGULATED MILITIA. THE MILITIA
IS THE PEOPLE THE MILITIA IS US
THE GUARDS AND EMPLOYEES HERE
THE DISABLED PEOPLE WHO WEREN'T
LET IN TODAY. THE DISABLED
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT GOING TO LET
IN SOME MORE- ONCE THEY CAN'T
EVEN COME HERE AND TALK.
EVERYONE IS GUARANTEED THAT
RIGHT. AND IT IS TIME THAT WE
USE IT IN THIS IS OUR COUNTRY.
THIS IS OUR COUNTY THIS IS OUR
CAPITAL. LET'S START REGULATING
OUR UPRISING BECAUSE A SMART
MAN SAID LIKE FOREVER AGO. THAT
IS A LOT. A MAN IS NOT ONLY
RIGHT. BUT HE IS OBLIGED TO IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN OTHER
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO OUR
TELEPHONIC COMMENT. WE'LL GET
SO OVER TELECOM- CONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU'D
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THANK YOU LOSE IT
NUMBER FOR PUBLIC COMMENT IS
MINE ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN OKAY MODERATOR BEFORE
WE BEGIN CAN YOU INDICATE TO ME
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE ONLINE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS POINT
TIME. WE HAVE THIRTY THREE OKAY
THANK YOU SO MODERATE- PLEASE-
AGAIN- LET'S GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
AND- SO AGAIN PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF BY YOUR NAME IF YOU
HAVE AN ORGANIZATION AND THEN
CERTAINLY YOUR COMMENT. AND
PLEASE TRY TO KEEP YOUR COMMENT
WITHIN ONE MINUTE- SO OF
MODERATOR- PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES. THANK YOU AND AGAIN MY
ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HONORABLE SENATORS
AND FELLOW CALIFORNIANS I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME LABOR
INTENSION AND DIRECTING OUR
CONCERNS ON THE CLUB IN
NINETEEN CONNECTICUT ON. MY
NAME IS MICHELLE I HAVE SANDY I
AM A MUSLIM AMERICAN AFGHAN
MEREKA HERE RIGHT OUT OF THE
KITCHEN CO FOUNDER BLANCHARD
EQUITY A PROBLEM FOR THE RIGHT
NOT PROFIT GIVING THOSE
DISCRIMINATED ON THE BASIS OF
GENDER. RACE RELIGION HERE ON A
COLD REGION. BY THE PARKING LOT
LONDON. INCARCERATED AND
SERVING APPEAL OF THOSE THAT
HAD BEEN SELL OR HAVE ONE
OPINION ST- A LONG OUR CALL
MONEY MONICA LONGER. BASED ARE
USING YOU DON'T IMPERIAL COUNTY.
GOVERNOR GAVIN YOU AND- DO YOU
SEE OUR TAKE IN. ACTION AND
GRAN ALARM FAMILY AS WELL AS
TOP I TRANSFERRED TO THE WE
NEED TO CHECK OUR- PUBLIC
HEALTH WE ARE. IN I THOUGHT.
AND CAN YOU. THE FINAL PUT IN
TO THE- HEALTH DESPERATE
CONTINUED HAPPEN. THANK YOU.
NEXT THE NEXT WITNESS. SIX
ONLINE NUMBER ONE TWELVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD. YES HI
MY NAME IS MICHAEL LEVINSON I
LIVE IN DALY CITY HELLO WHAT
THE SAN MATEO COUNTY COALITION
FOR IMMIGRANT RIGHTS. I WANT TO
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH MANY OF
THE COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE
DURING THIS HEARING.
PARTICULARLY THE ONES HAVING TO
DO WITH THE RELEASE AND
TRANSFER TO ICE. SOME PEOPLE TO
VERY UNSAFE ENVIRONMENTS IN THE
DETENTION FACILITIES I THINK
WHATEVER LIST OF CRIMES IS USED
TO- DETAIN PEOPLE RELEASED
PEOPLE SHOULD BE EQUALLY
APPLIED TO UNDOCUMENTED
INDIVIDUALS AS WELL AS THE RESTOF THE POPULATION. OUR ACCOUNT
IS TRYING TO GET A LIST OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE RELEASED AND
WHAT THEIR OFFENSES WERE SO
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY GATHER
EVIDENCE. ON WHO WAS RELEASED
AND IT WAS TRANSFERRED AND
COMPARE THAT TO THE REST OF THE
GENERAL POPULATION AND MAKE
SURE THE STANDARD IS THE SAME.
AND NOT DISCRIMINATORY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. WELCOME. NINE FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE I'M FROM SAN JOSE AND
I REMEMBER THINKING HARD. BOB
THANK NOT VERY COALITION
STRANDS BETWEEN PRISONS THE
COMMON MAKING OUT AT NINE POINT
EIGHT. THE RENT SHOULD NOT THE
THING THAT THE CAR. WAS FOUND
GUILTY OF VIOLATING EIGHT MEN
RIGHT MCCARTY PEOPLE AT FIND
PROPER TRYING CALL LEARNING OUT
BREAKING THE FURTHER TRANSFER
THE MAKING TO LIBERTY DIFFERENT
BERMAN HE YEAH MY LOOKING TO
WHAT THE CLIENT. PLAN EXCLUSION.
WIPERS AND OTHER- COULD BE
COMPLETED BY MY- LIKE YOU
COULDN'T TURN IT DIFFICULT AND
GIVEN THEIR RED COMPUTER. AND
HIGH OF THE QUESTION. VETERANS
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION I THINK WE
ARE NOT PART FOR TAXIS YOUR THE
CULTURE WE NEED TO EXAMINE WE
COULD NOT. THANK THANK THANK
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS THIS. NINE ONE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN TO GO AHEAD. NINE
ONE AND SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES PLEASE BEGIN.
OKAY GREAT HI THANK YOU DON'T
MONEY IS ON THE NISSAN AXIOM
ACTUALLY I CALL ON THE MENTAL
HEALTH CLINICAL TO GROW AT
TWENTY HOW CORRECTIONAL. AND I
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND ALSO-
THEANY ASSEMBLY NATIONAL OF
SOCIAL WORKERS READ UNDER IN
OUR AREA AND I'M COOL BECAUSE
I'M VERY CONCERNED WITH THE
DISK. OF WHAT IS YOUR AND
MENTAL DASH TO BE COMING INTO
THE SYSTEM ESPECIALLY AS WE'RE
IN PEAK OF OUR THIRD IS HE
GOING AND HIGHER. IN OUR
FACILITY WE HAVE A BEEN TOLD TO
A FOURTEEN FORTY OF FORTY. THAT
HAVE NOW BEEN OUT THAT HAVE TWO
WEEKS TO COME FOR COULD HAVE.
INTO HOURS. WHERE THEY ARE. YET
HAS ANY OF- YOU KNOW FOR
FASHION WE'VE HAD INFECTED AND
NOW THEY CRIMINAL GALA TESTING
THERE'S REALLY NO WE CAN. HOW
ACTIVE CASES ARE HAPPENING WE
DON'T HAVE A- CHECKING OR
MONITOR ANYBODY IS NOT TAX
THERE ARE NO ON NINETY
GUARANTEE A MASK WEARING YOUR.
OKAY THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
COULD. NEXT WITNESS. FIND ONE
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE ONE HUNDRED AND
ELEVEN ONE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CLAUDIA HAS ME ONE CHALLENGE I
IN THE ADVOCATE EVERY YOU DON'T
I AM A LOOKING GREAT WE
COULDN'T SURVIVE IN NINETEEN.
THIS COST ME BOTH THE MONEY AND
MY ALL LEVEL DROPPED TO FIFTY I
ALMOST. BUT I KNOW HAN STUCK
WITH YOU THE BEST CARE. I WOULD
FIGHT FOR MY LIFE THEY MIGHT
PROP HE HAS NOT BEEN THE CASE
FOR YOU BECAUSE PEOPLE RESPECT
FOR THE A PEOPLE WHO HAVE. I
COULDN'T OF THE WAIT AND SEE
ARE PEOPLE SUFFERING AND YOU
HAVE CMPLETE CAL TO PROTECT
THEM. NINE ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON
MEMBERS ANDREA RIVERA ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER CHEC IS A
CONSTITUENT DAY STATE MIGHT
IMMIGRANTS RIGHTS ORGANIZATION
THAT ADVANCES EFFORTS TO
DISENTANGLE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM THE FEDERAL
DEPORTATION PIPELINE AND
THEREFORE BUILD A PROSPEROUS
FUTURE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
I'M HERE TODAY TO RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND
GTCR IMMEDIATELY GRANT TO LARGE
SCALE RELEASES AND PUT AN END
TO ALL TRANSFERS FOR THE
FOLLOWING REASONS. FIRST
INCARCERATION THREATENS THE
PUBLIC HEALTH ALL CALIFORNIANS
GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND CDCR
NEGLIGENCEHAS ALREADY LED TO
EIGHTY THREE PREVENTABLE DEATH
MICHAEL THIS NINETEEN AND OVER
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND POSITIVE
CASES IN STATE PRISONS. SECOND
THE PIPELINE FROM PRISON TO ICE
ATTENTION AND DEPORTATION HAS
ADVERSE HEALTH OUTCOMES
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE WHO ARE
UNDERGOING THE EXPERIENCE OF
DETENTION THEIR LOVED ONES AND
THE BROADER COMMUNITY AND IT IS
EVEN MORE DANGEROUS DURING THE
CALL THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. IN
ORDER TO SAVE LIVES AND PROTECT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH WE MUST STOP
BASED TRANSFERS THANK YOU
LASTLY. I'D LIKE TO CLOSE BY
SAYING. THANK YOU THANK THANK
THANK YOU VERY. OUR NEXT
WITNESS PLAY. MY NINETY YOUR IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE ALSO
BE USED HAVE COLUSA BASE IN LOS
ANGELES- MY SECOND AND I AM
ALSO COME BORN IN THAILAND AND
I TO WAS A TRANSFER FROM STATE
PRISON TYSON FIFTEEN AFTER
BEING ONE OF THE FIRST SB TWO
SIXTY RECENT. I WAS ABLE TO GET
IN GOVERNOR BROWN AND EIGHTEEN
TO RISK MY RIGHT. AND I
CONTINUE TO HAVE. NIGHTMARES
TODAY FROM MY EXPERIENCE. OF
TIME IN HIGH CLOCK. MIKE DO YOU
DISPLAY FAMILIES AND WE
SUFFERED. AND HAVE RECEIVED. A
MODICUM WORK WERE TO. THIS CALL
WITH PRINTER IN FLOCK OF. IN
SPITE IN ANY OTHER COUNTRY WHAT
DOES HELPED SYSTEM- CAL COULD
NOT BE PROUD OF JUST AND I IT
MORE TO. THIS. SLATED TO END
PRACTICE THANK YOU. THANK SO
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. NINE
ONE AND YOUR IS- OPEN OKAY HE'S
GOING. HELLO T. HERE ME YES.
HELLO MY NAME IS SANDY AND I
MET COMMUNITY ORGANIZER AT THE
IMMIGRANT LEGAL WE START BACK
OVER THE PAST YEAR I HAVE FORTY
PEOPLE INSIDE IMMIGRATION
DETENTION CENTER. HAVE BEEN
FAILED BY THE CRIMINAL LEGAL
SYSTEM A CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM
WHO FALSELY PROMISED THEM
REHABILITATION BUT STRIPPED
THEM OF THEIR RIGHTS AND THE
THOUGHT OF THEM INTO THE HANDS
OF OUR YOUTH. IN DOING SO THE
STATE HAS BEEN AND BEING
COMPLICIT OF THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN RIGHTS VIOLATIONS THAT
ARE OCCURRING INSIDE.
IMMIGRATION DETENTION CENTER.
WE ARE AND SHARE. TAKE AWAY THE
MORE. HOPEFUL AND YOU MOM.
FAMILIES HOW DURING SUCH A-
TIME AND SET UP THAT NEED TO
CHANGED WELCOME TO LOVED ONES.
THEY ARE. WELL WHY A WAY. HERE.
I THINK WE'LL BE CHECKING OVER
TO OUR- ALL DIFFERENT TO OUR
CUSTODY IN AND ARE. THE LADY
LEGISLATE AND THE GOVERNOR MY
AND ALL. I AND BOB ALL. THE
NEXT- IT IS I'M AND- THAT SUCH
A DIFFICULT TIME THAT THE
DUBLINER CONTINUES TO FAIL TO
USE EXECUTIVE POWER THANK YOU
SHARED ALL. OUR FAITH DURING
THE PANDEMIC THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED. NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NINE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO. HI MY NAME IS
LISA AND I'M WITH THE LONG
BEACH RIGHT IMMIGRANTS RIGHTS
COALITION FROM DISTRICT THIRTY
THREE WHAT THE RAMPANT SPREAD
OF COVERT NINETEEN ON THE RATE
OF INFECTION BEING MUCH HIGHER
DETENTION FACILITY WE ARE
URGING GOVERNOR NEWSOM THANK
YOU SEE OUR THOUGHT I
TRANSFERRED NOW IN ORDER TO
STOP PREVENTABLE DEATHS AND
PROTECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE. WE IN THE
COMMUNITY ARE ASKING CALIFORNIA
TO STOP HANDING PEOPLE OVER WHO
EARNED A REEDY OVER TO AYE-
DETENTION CENTER UTILITIES ARE
SITE THE RAMPANT MEDICAL
NEGLECT AND ABUSE EVEN PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC WHAT THE CURRENT
ATHLETIC HIGHEST IT'S BEEN IN
FIFTEEN YEARS. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE A DUTY TO
UPHOLD OUR VALUES OF FAIRNESS
EQUALITY. AND CARING FOR OUR
COMMUNITY. ALL HAVE ALREADY HAD
TO. AN OUTWARD WITHIN THE- ARE
FACILITY IT IS NOT HUMANE THEY
HAVE TO. SURVIVE YOU KNOW EVEN
DYING FOR ANOTHER OUT IN THE-
OF AYE. FOR WELL KNOWN FOR
THEIR- MEDICAL TREATMENT AND
ABUSE. I HAVE BEEN
IRRESPONSIBLE DURING THE
PANDEMIC BY ACTIVELY COVERING
UP SYMPTOMS OF THE DEADLY VIRUS
IN ORDER TO DEPORT IMMIGRANTS.
I HAD NO CONCERN OVER THE
PEOPLE THEY HAVE IN THEIR
CUSTODY. NOR FOR ANY OTHER
COUNTRY TEY KNOW ANYTHING THE
VIRUS- BUT OUR STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD CARE ABOUT
IT. IN UNITY MEMBERS AND ARE
YOU THEIR LIFE BY POPULAR RIGHT
OF THE VIRUS AND POPULAR
TRANSACTION YOU. WILL FROM PKR
DIVERTICULA THESE UNDER
INHUMANE PRACTICES. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY. MUCH- NEXT WITH
THIS PLEASE. NINE FIFTY YOUR
LONG IS OPEN. HI GO AHEAD. YES
PLEASE BEGIN HEARING. YES OKAY
HI HI MY NAME GET REAL WELLS
AND THE HUMAN RIGHTS ACTIVIST
IN SAN FRANCISCO. AND I FRIENDS
INCARCERATED AT SAN QUENTIN ALL
OF WHOM SUFFERED TERRIFYING
CASES A GOLD AT. THE OUTBREAK
AT PENN QUIN WAS AN AVOIDABLE
HUMAN RIGHTS DISASTER. THERE'S
BEEN A TRAUMATIZING EXPERIENCE
FOR INCARCERATED PEOPLE THEIR
LOVED ONES. AND THE LARGER
COMMUNITY. AND IT WAS CAUSED BY
A PRISON TRANSFER. AND ISIS
YLIDES LIKE PRISONS ARE COATED
SUPER SPREADERS. TRANSFERRING
PEOPLE FROM PRISONS TO ICE
DETENTION CENTERS. IS A 100%
UNACCEPTABLE. AND DEPORTING
PEOPLE INCLUDING OUR FIRE
WORKERS. THE ROIC PEOPLE WHO
ARE TASKED WITH RISKING THEIR
LIVES TO SAVE OURS IS AN ACT OF
INCOMPREHENSIBLE- INJUSTICE.
AND I TOOK THE RECORD OF
MEDICAL NEGLECT. ABUSE AND
PEOPLE ARE GETTING SICK AND
EVEN DIE IN THEIR FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA IS JUST SO MUCH
BETTER THAN THAT. GOVERNOR
NEWSOM MUST DEMONSTRATE OUR
HUMANITY. AND WE HAVE TO STOP
THESE UNCONSCIONABLE HUMAN
RIGHTS ABUSES. PLEASE STOP ALL
TRANSFERS AND PLEASE SAVE LIVES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NINE ONE SIX
FIVE YOUR IS. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO- OF MINE IS THE TWENTY AS
AND I'M COLD. ON BEHALF OF MY
HUSBAND WHO IS ACTUALLY IN CAN
CLINTON AND YOU KNOW ABSOLUTELY
EVERYTHING AND SPEAKING WITH
HIM ON A RECORD NUMBER EIGHT
YOU KNOW HE SERVED TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS YOU'VE DONE EVERYTHING TO
REHABILITATE HIMSELF MADE
REQUESTED THE GOVERNOR OR DONE
EVERYTHING FOR RESENTENCING.
AND CDC ARE NOT CONSIDERING ANY
OF THOSE INMATES THAT HAVE PUT
IN THE TIME TO COMPLETELY
REFORM THEIR LIVES AND YOU KNOW
TO WORK IN AN AREA WHERE I
ACTIVELY HELP TO PROTECT THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF TEN
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES. IN SAN
FRANCISCO I KNOW THE THING THAT
THEY COULD DO TO ACTUALLY MAKE
THINGS BETTER WITHIN THE
PRESIDENT BUT THEY'RE NOT
MEETING CREATED- COMMITTEE
HOLDING THEIR STAFF ACCOUNTABLE
AND THEY'RE NOT PROVIDING THE
PPP FOR ANY OF THE INMATES TO.
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE STATE SO I
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT AGAIN
YOU KNOW- MASS RELEASE DATES
FOR PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY SERVED
TIME SHOWN REHABILITATION EVEN
IF THERE IS ELECTRONIC
MONITORING OR OTHER SERVICES
THAT SAYING WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO KEEP YOU ON YOU
KNOW SOME KIND OF PROBATION.
YEAH ALL THOSE COUNTRIES AND TO
HELP- IN MAY BE RELEASED THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NINE ONE FIFTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS LISA
STRONG I WOULD CARTER BANQUET
NINE TRANSFORM AND I WILL EVERY
TO KNOW. THAT WE CAN BE REALLY
AND SUCCESSFUL I AM NOW THE
FIRST TRAINED PERSON ON THE RE
ENTRY COUNCIL AT STANFORD DID
GO. I'M DOING REALLY GREAT
THINGS OUT HERE WE NEED TO
SPEED UP THESE RELEASES IT'S
HORRIBLE IN THERE I HOPE
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS. CBPR HAD
JUST NOW. EVERYONE INCARCERATED.
TO A DEATH SENTENCE. THIS IS
NOT A- WE NEED TO UP THE
RELEASE DATE. THANK YOU. FOR
YOU VERY MUCH OUR NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NINE ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD-
GOOD AFTERNOON ISRAEL READOUT
THAT YOU DIRECTED CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY JUSTICE- ARE FOREMOST
ON THE KNOWLEDGE AND BAKER
LEADERSHIP. GREAT QUESTION THAT
CONCERNS RANGE TODAY. SECOND IT
IS CLEAR THAT WE CANNOT RELY ON
CDC TO IMPLEMENT THE NECESSARY
SAFEGUARDS TO SECURE THE LIVES
OF OUR CARCERI RELATIVES. I
HEARD TODAY WAS UP TO EIGHT
THOUSAND ELIGIBLE AND ONLY
EIGHTY THAT WERE RELEASED- I'M
ALSO AWARE THAT THERE ARE AT
LEAST THREE THOUSAND NONVIOLENT
THOUSAND PEOPLE HEEDED YOUR
TOTAL GLOBAL PROP FIFTY SEVEN
WHICH WAS WRONG YOU KNOW THE
CASE TO THE PEOPLE GETTING
STRUCK AN OPERA PIZZA PAKISTAN
TO CHARACTER WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RECTIFY THAT THE
PROPERTY. THIRD ITEM FOR ME
BEHIND MR KING'S RECOMMENDATION.
WHAT ARE YOUR LEADERSHIP TO LET
YOU THE ISSUE OF TRACK. MAY I
DISCUSSED AND LAST HE- MUST BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR INTENTION
OR ON. NEGLECT TRANSFER INMATES
SPREADING THE VIRUS. ULTIMATELY
WE IN TROUBLE NOT SO FIVE THANK
YOU. THANKS FOR MUCH- MODERATE-
HOW MANY ADDITIONAL PEOPLE ARE
IN THE- WE HAVE TWENTY TWO.
OKAY WE DO HAVE A HARD STOP
FIVE ANNOUNCER WANT TO BE SO TO
ALL THE PEOPLE HERE IN THE ROOM
I REALIZED THAT WE DID HAVE
HAVE TO DO A BRIEF RECESS THAT
TOOK AWAY SOME TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT- WAY GOING TO ASK IS
THAT- WILL TAKE SOME MORE
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR A TIME DOWN
ANOTHER TEN MINUTES THERE'S
TWENTY TWO VIEWS SO YOU
TECHNICALLY DO YOU HAVE A
MINUTE AND I'M NOT GOING TO CUT
YOU OFF IF YOU GO OVER YOUR
THIRTY SECONDS BUT- KEEP THAT
IN MIND- BUT WHEN WE DO HIT. BY
A TEN MINUTE MARK I'M GOING TO
HAVE TO CLOSE THIS HEARING SO-
JUST TO REMINDER TO KEEP YOUR
REMARKS BRIEF AND THEN LET'S
SEE WHAT WE CAN TRY TO DO IN
THE NEXT TEN MINUTES SO-
MODERATOR KEEP PLEASE REOPEN
THE LINE AND- GOES. NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU NINE
SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
MARGARET BAKER REPRESENTING
SOUTH BAY PEOPLE POWER I'M
RETIRED UBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL I LIVE A NEAR NINE
MILES FROM OTAY MESA DETENTION
CENTER. WHERE WE RECENTLY HAD
THE HIGHEST NUMBER COOLEY CASES
IN THE COUNTRY APPARATUS INTO
CENTER AND DEATH A DEATH THAT
COULD HAVE BEEN PREVENTED THE
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE ALTHOUGH
ANY SUBJECT. AND GOVERNOR
NEWSOM AND DID YOU SEE OUR OUR-
FAILING TO ADDRESS THE
INJUSTICES IN CRITICAL PUBLIC
HEALTH PROBLEMS IN A CALIFORNIA
PRISON SYSTEM ALREADY THIS YEAR
THEY HAVE ALLOWED ONE THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE
IMMIGRANT TO BE FUNNELED FROM
CALIFORNIA PREDICT I CUTTING
RAMPANT. CRITICAL BIT
UNNECESSARY FAMILY SEPARATION
BEEN WIDESPREAD AG ANGUISH WE
CAN'T WAIT FOR CPR TO CHANGE
ALL OF THAT COULD BE USED. IN
THE MEANTIME GOVERNOR SOME OF
HIS HIS EXECUTIVE POWERS NOW TO
STOP BY CHAPTERS GRANT PARDON.
AND IN THE INTEREST OF BOTH
PUBLIC HEALTH AND JUSTICE FOR
ALL COMPANIES THANK YOU THANK.
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE OPEN
PLEASE GO. NINE EIGHTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY BE ON.
IF YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE BEGIN.
OKAY I'M SORRY OKAY I JUST
WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AND I WANT
TO APOLOGIZE- BUT- AND THE YOU
KNOW THE DISPLAYS OF ANGER THAT
YOU WITNESS TO WOULD BE JUST
THE SMARTEST. OF THAT ANGER IN
HER AND FRUSTRATION CONTINUE.
AND NEGLIGENT ON BEHALF OF THE
PEOPLE. WE LOVED AS AN ADVOCATE.
ANGRY AND VERY PLEASANT. THE
BUILDINGS HEARING STARTED WILL
ATTENDED WEEK. HERE- THAT WHEN
THEY COME TO WILL THAT MAKE IT
POLICY AND PROCEDURES THAT ARE
CURRENT TO POPULATE. AND
INDIVIDUALS AND LARGER IT. SO
CLEAR THAT YOU ME THEIR ARE. WE
RIGHT NOW AND FOLLOWED HE.
HELLO OKAY A LAPTOP. HOW IT IS
IN A DIFFERENT LIGHT NINETY AND
IT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE WE HAVE
ALSO- BEEN REQUIRED AND
MANDATED TO MAKE UNPRECEDENTED
SOMETHING. SORRY YES OR NO
CHANGES AND MANDATORY READING-
I THINK SENATORS SKINNER HIS
ELOQUENT COULD BE ENSURING
THEY'RE GOING OPINION I HAVE TO
AGREE THAT THE EFFECTIVE OF
TRYING TO REMEMBER TO AYE.
OPERATE IT'S AN HOUR THANK YOU
ACTUALLY DURING THE- AND. YEAH
THE TIME UP BUT- THANK YOU YOU
CAN ALWAYS DO SOMETHING
COMMENTS OUR WEB TO SO THANK SO
MUCH FOR. THE NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NINE ONE EIGHTY. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS JULIE MARTINEZ
AND I'VE BEEN A VOLUNTEER WITH-
JUSTICE FOR IMMIGRANTS I HAVE
EXPERIENCE ONLY CHEERING
INTERVIEWING. DETAINEES AND THE
CALIFORNIA DETENTION CENTERS
AND UNFORTUNATELY THE REPORTS
BACK- ALWAYS BACK HEALTH CARE
IS COMPROMISED THE VERY RARELY
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SEE A
DOCTOR THERE MAINLY A CERTIFIED
NURSE'S WHICH IS A TERRIBLE
TERRIBLE POSITION TO BE
ESPECIALLY WHEN. CALIFORNIA
PRISON SYSTEM CONTINUES TO
TRANSFER INDIVIDUALS. TO AYE AM
UNFORTUNATE INDIVIDUALS ARE
GOING INTO DETENTION CENTERS MY
PLEASE MY ASK IS NOT GOVERNOR
NEW SENATE CALIFORNIA LAKE
LEGISLATURE PLEASE CREATE A
STOP GAP ON INDY FIVE TRANSFERS
CALIFORNIA CLINTON DO ANY
DETENTION CENTERS. IN ADDITION
TO THAT PLEASE- PLEASE. A MORE
CONCRETE PLAN TO WORK MORE
INMATE FROM PRISON AND IN DOING
THAT YOU WERE ABLE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. ONE ONE
FIFTY YOUR LINE OPEN PLEASE GO.
MY NAME IS KATRINA GALA AN I'M
ON BEHALF OF MY HUSBAND WHO IS
HOUSE THAT SAT AT THE COURT
AGREED MR GALLAGHER A. KATE
NINE ONE ONE FIVE WHO HAS BEEN
A VICTIM OF THE CURRENT
POSITIVE OUTBREAK. INSIDE IT
AND TESTING POSITIVE FOR COATED
NINETEEN TO PROTECT THEM REDUCE
THE PRISON POPULATION FROM
COVERT NINETEEN MY SUGGESTION
ON A MASS RELEASE AND TO
INCLUDE THOSE SUCH AS MY
HUSBAND WHO HAVE SERVED THEIR
BASED TERM OR AT LEAST 80% OF
THEIR BASE TERM AND ARE ONLY OR
WILL ONLY BE SERVING
ENHANCEMENT TIME. IF IT WEREN'T
FOR ENHANCEMENTS MY HUSBAND MAY
HAVE BEEN RELEASED AND PROTECT
IT FROM COLD AT NINETEEN AS WE
ALL KNOW CALIFORNIA HAS SUBJECT
MANY INMATES TO HARSH EXCESSIVE
ENHANCEMENTS SUCH AS MY HUSBAND
HAS SERVED ALL TE YEARS OF HIS
BASED TERM. HAVE BEEN HIT WITH
AN ADDITIONAL NINETEEN YEARS
AND EIGHT MONTHS OF
ENHANCEMENTS AND HE'S ALSO
CLASSIFIED AS A YOUTH OFFENDER.
THOUSANDS OF OFFENDERS HAVE
SERVED THEIR TIME DESERVE TO BE
SAFE FROM COLD AND GO HOME IN
CLOSING PLEASE LOOK INTO A
RELEASE OF THOSE WHO ARE
SUBJECT TO THE SITUATION WHO
HAVE SERVED THEIR TIME PLEASE
PROTECT THEIR LOVED ONES FROM
CO THAT NINETEEN THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NINE ONE TWO EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS THE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
AM GOING TO MAKE THIS ROCK
BECAUSE RATHER TIME NAME IS
YOUR MIND IN READY I'M A
RETIRED UC DAVIS AND CHLOE AND
I AM THE DROPPED A LOT
COALITION ORGANIZER- AND YOU
CAN GO AHEAD IF THEY WILL CLICK
ON THE CODE THAT. CDC ARE DID
NOT KNOW GOVERNMENT CODE.
SECTION EIGHTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT-
AND- TO INCLUDE THE A LOT
RESTRICT AND LIFERS. YOU'RE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN HUNDRED YOU
CAN LIKELY HAD COME HOME AND
THEY'RE LOOKING AT THE RATE IS
ZERO- WE NEED TO ABOLISHED I
AND WE NEED TO SAVE LIFE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NINE ONE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
OLENA J. LOBBY I CARE
CALIFORNIA. I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT ANY A DEAL IS
ONE OF THE HIGH SCHOOL THE
NINETEEN INFLICTED ON DETENTION
CENTERS AND ALSO- COULDN'T. I
WOULD REALLY LIKE THE GOVERNOR
AND THE FOLKS WHO ARE NOT. TO
SUPPORT OUR POLICY BY MAKING
SURE THAT THERE IS NO I
TRANSFERRED. IN FACT THE TWENTY
EIGHT- ARCHERS DEPARTMENT HAS
BEEN. EXTREMELY HIGH
INFORMATION ABOUT PUT THEM IN.
THE LEAD AND ALSO EVEN WITH. ME
TO ONLY. YEAH THEY WERE JUST
SURE BECAUSE WHOEVER WAS PAYING
LOT WATER WHICH IS GOING THERE
NOTHING WE CAN PEOPLE. LEAVE
ANOTHER CALL ACTION YOU REALLY
WERE THREE I DON'T THINK. YOUR
LONG TERM SO. STOP I TURNED
PURGE THE AMERICAN FAMILY AND
BUNDLES HOME THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NINE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE OPEN GO
OUT. HEY I GOT THAT MY NAME IS
BOBBY RAY AND PART OF THE THANK
OUTBREAKS OF VOLUNTEER AT
IMPORTANT PRISON AND PUBLIC
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL WITH EXPERT
IN BY HEALTH IMPACTS DISEASE I
SOMEONE WHO GIVES COM ON THE
PART OF JOB I JUST WANTED TO
THAT ONE PUBLIC. IS NOT
DESIGNED TO ELICIT FEEDBACK
FROM THE PUBLIC BUT JUST TO
PRACTICE IF WE ARE TO LEARN
FROM THE WORD EPIDEMIOLOGICAL
BILL AFTER EACH CORRECTION
HISTORY WE USED SPREAD ACROSS
THE NINETEEN EIGHTY CARE
FACILITY. TRANSFERRED LIKE WHAT
AT TEN POINT IN OUR NOT ALLOWED.
IF YOU WERE GOT SAYING THAT
CARS AT THE SHOULD NOT TRANSFER
INDIVIDUAL UNLESS ABSOLUTE
NECESSARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
FROM THANK HALL LIKE BE TAKEN
DIRECTLY WITH- WHERE CONDITION.
WE ARE MOVING FROM FOR NETWORK
INVOLVING IN THE MIDST OF A-
ITS CREW AND A- CPR GOVERNING
YOU ON. DEMOCRATS ARE PANDEMIC
OR REDUCE THE PRISON. AND OVER
FIFTY INCARCERATED AT YOUR
FACILITY HAVE LEAST ONE THAT
INCREASE THE RISK OF YOUR CALL
THE NINETEEN ACTION. BUT IN
OCTOBER THE INDICATED THAT HE
ARE ONLY APPROVED IT AND
RECOMMENDED CLEMENCY LESS THAN
ONE OF THE POWER OF PEOPLE THAT
THEY TAKEN HI MEDICAL. MY NAME
IS SYLVIA BRANDON THE PRINTERS
I AM A PRACTICING. THREE AND MY
CHURCH IS CALLED PEOPLE WITHOUT
BORDERS JUSTICE TEMPLE I AM
ALSO A RETIRED ATTORNEY WHO DID
A LOT OF IMMIGRATION PRACTICE
INCLUDING AT TIMES WHEN UNITED
STATES- MADE IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR
PEOPLE TO COME IN INCLUDING THE
HAITIANS DURING THE DUVALIER
DICTATORSHIP. THAT THE
TESTIMONY OF THAT YOUNG
CAMBODIAN MAN I MOVED ME TODAY
BECAUSE THAT WAS ANY LEGAL
BOTTOM BEING CARRIED OUT BY
RICHARD NIXON ON THE ORDERS OF
HENRY KISSINGER THE FACT THAT
WE WOULD CONSIDER DOING
ANYTHING TO ANYBODY. ABOUT YET
POLICE ME ABSOLUTELY AGHAST IT
IS TIME FOR US TO BE. KINDER TO
REMEMBER WHAT YOU UNDER PARKER
SHARED AND MARTIN LUTHER KING
REPEATED THE ARC OF JUSTICE THE
NEW YORKER HISTORY BENDS TOWARD
JUSTICE. TRYING TO SAY WE
CANNOT. CONTINUE TO DO THE- AND
BOY PATROL MEMBER PATROL YOU
AND IMMIGRATION ARE A WAR CRIME
COURT. WE THANK YOU WHICH I UP
OKAY YOUR THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NINE ONE THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI AND MY NAME IS IN
THE BALLPARK RESIDENT AT
BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND I'M
JUST CALLING TO BOLSTER ALL
DEMANDED OF ALREADY BEEN MADE
Q. AND I TRANSFERRED AND- HAVE
AN IMMEDIATE. LARGE SCALE
RELEASING THE NAY- ON IT.
REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME THAT-
EVEN CLEAR TO A LOT OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO HEAR THAT
INACTION IN THE CASE IS MURDER
OF PEOPLE WITH FAMILIES AND
HOMES AND CHILDREN. AND TO NOT.
TO HONG THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
THAT OFF ON TV THE R. OR OTHER
PEOPLE REGARDLESS OF HOW
INHUMANE AND CRUEL THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS OX BLOOD ON YOUR
HANDS Q. AND THE LONGER YOU
WAIT THE MORE PEOPLE ARE LOT.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO BE
IMMEDIATELY THAT. SOMETHING IS
DONE AND THAT PEOPLE ARE HOME
WITH THEIR FAMILIES AND OUT OF
WHAT WAS PREVIOUSLY AND VERY
ACCURATELY CALLED SUPER
SPREADERS INSTITUTION- YES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU FOR ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
SHOWED UP HERE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE NOW
EXHAUSTED THE TEN MINUTE
EXTENSION- HOT MODERATOR HOW
MANY WITNESSES ARE STILL ON THE
PHONE. WE HAVE SIXTEEN
CURRENTLY ON THAT IN THE PHONE
QUEUE OKAY- WE DID HAVE A HARD
STOP AT FIVE O'CLOCK I DID GIVE
EXTENSION BECAUSE WE DID HAVE
TO GO INTO A BRIEF RECESS-
UNFORTUNATELY I THINK WE- WE
ARE. AT THE TIME WHERE I DO
NEED TO ADJOURN- I WANT TO DO
IS FIRST OF ALL PLEASE I KNOW
WE STILL HAVE PEOPLE ON THE
LINE IF. YOU CAN MAKE COMMENTS
ON THE WEBSITE FOR THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY. OR
THE COMMITTEE A PANDEMIC
EMERGENCY RESPONSE OR BOTH.
YOUR VOICE IS VERY IMPORTANT
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU-
YOU KNOW LISTENING INTO THIS
HEARING AND WE DO WANT TO HEAR
FROM YOU ALSO FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO DID TESTIFY. GIVE PUBLIC
COMMENT I KNOW MANY OF YOU HAD
MORE TO SAY SO PLEASE AGAIN-
THAT'S OF IT- YOU PLEASE SHARE
THAT WITH US AT THE WEBSITE AS
WELL- I DO WANT TO THANK ALL
THE PANELISTS WHO ARE
PRESENTED- REALLY APPRECIATE.
THEIR PRESENTATIONS- AND ALSO-
THE CENTERS IN THE BAG AND THE
QUESTIONS THAT WE HAD I KNOW
THAT DID TAKE SOME TIME TO BUT
THAT'S PART OF HOW WE TRY TO.
FORMULATE BETTER POLICY. SO-
WITH THAT- I WANT TO ALSO IF
ALL THE STAFF HERE AS WELL-
WHO- WHO. ALSO HAD TO MANAGE.
EVERYTHING RELATING TO A REMOTE
PARTICIPATION A ROAD TEST MEAN.
TESTIMONY SO AGAIN JUST IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE OR THE
SPECIAL PANDEMIC EMERGENCY
RESPONSE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND
THAT THOSE ARE VERY IMPORTANT-
SO WITH THAT- I GUESS I GUESS
JUST VERY BRIEFLY- BECAUSE I.
DO NEED TO THAT WE DO NEED TO
WRAP UP- BUT CHAIRED GONZALEZ
FLETCHER SKINNER WERE THERE ANY
REAL. FINAL REMARKS YOU WISH TO
MAKE BEFORE WE ADJOURN. IF YOU
PUT YOUR HAND UP. THEN I'LL
KNOW IF YOU DID WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING. OKAY YES- CENTER
GONZALEZ. I JUST WANT TO
QUICKLY SAY THANK YOU TO MANY
OF THE ADVOCATES WHO HAD SPOKEN
UP TODAY I AGREE WITH YOU
WHOLEHEARTEDLY THERE NEEDS TO
BE LEGISLATIVE ACTION SOONER
THAN LATER- MANY OF THE-
ANSWERS TO OUR QUESTIONS WERE-
NOT SUFFICIENT AND WE DO NEED
MORE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY HERE AND SO I
JUST WANNA THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
FOR BEING A PART OF THIS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
GONZALEZ ON OF CENTER
SKINNER'S- ABLE TO. THE SAME
THING ALL RIGHT I DON'T THINK
SO AT THIS POINT IN TIME AGAIN
pPARTICIPATION WANT THANK
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION- WE AT THIS TIME
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA AND
THIS JOINT HEARING OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY AND SPECIAL
PANDEMIC EMERGENCY RESPONSE
COMMITTEES. IS NOW A CHARRED